[Music]
thank you
oh I just need to pee really quickly and
grab water it'll take me two minutes
may I do that
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is a
five-time feed a world chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
has methodically done what he needed to
do to get another shot at the title
that's your 2022 feed a Candace champion
and just an absolutely stunning
performance from Young
the pressure to seize the moment this
time rests heavily upon him
the Red Nose firsthand what the end of
this dynasty means an unexpected chance
to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame dingly Wren has
secured second place here amazing what a
big last round win for ding the legacy
of this Championship spans across
centuries it reads from the names of
Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
a table a chessboard and two chairs
Grace the elegant Ballroom of the Saint
Regis Hotel in Astana Kazakhstan where
exactly 12 minutes from now at 3 pm
local time 2023 e-day World Championship
will commence and for the first time in
10 years Magnus Carlson will not be
sitting in one of these chairs Welcome
to our coverage of this momentous event
I am your host Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinski and alongside me today is a
great honor to welcome world number six
Super Grand Master Anish giri Anish good
morning to you I can't believe we're
here
good morning Dania I'm very excited I
can only imagine how the nervous the
players must be feeling even I'm
extremely excited and I'm nowhere near
Asana Kazakhstan what are your thoughts
neither am I I was nervous this morning
I'm going to admit I'm I'm feeling
nervous I'm feeling honored to just be
sitting in the commentators chair
we'll talk about how terrified the
players must feel but first we need to
talk about the players themselves
dingleren and Jan napomnushi are
contesting the 2023 world championship
and this is by all metrics one of the
most if not the most evenly matched
world championship match in history from
the age perspective from the rating
perspective seven points set them apart
and from the perspective of their head
to head in both classical and Rapid
Anish no matter how you slice it this
hatch is incredibly unpredictable
of course now that Magnus Carlson is no
longer there who is dominating chess for
the past decade the match is uh close as
ever at the same time you see that every
little line has never having a small
Edge that's it's a nice little fun fact
doesn't you know doesn't deserve the
balance much but still also the last
event that they both played yand is a
little just just quite a bit better so
somehow
and also you know I'm keep hearing these
comments from experienced players
Experian people uh Grandmasters other
experts and pundits all give or most of
them give Nepal a small small extra Edge
that's that's definitely there
I've picked up on that as well a niche
of course the only experience that nepo
has over ding which might be a negative
is uh his previous experience sitting in
the world championship chair against
Magnus Carlson where would you put that
on the spectrum between positive and
negative initi is this going to impact
his mentality in a good way hey I've
been here before I know what this is
like or I've been here before it didn't
go too well
yeah it's a really good question I guess
it depends on how it goes any experience
is useful for sure but imagine if he
loses game six I mean somehow just
imagine oh five draws and he loses the
game six it's gonna bring some really
bad flashbacks so they can come report
both ways certainly
what if he loses it in trying to
remember the number of moves 137 moves
well he lost it to a guy named Magnus
Carlson uh this is a an individual that
we have named a lot in reference to
World Championship matches he has won
exactly five of them for the first time
in 2013 crushing visionant defending his
title four times after that he's won
matches in the classical portion he's
one matches in the rapid portion the
Magnus era was fun while it lasted a
niche I can't believe I'm saying this
but after 10 years or the time being
Magnus era is going to come to an end
after this world championship match
concludes
yeah indeed and that's just remarkable I
should though add that um these matches
although Magnus won all of them and he's
really been by far world number one
there's no debate there for all the
throttle these years some of these
matches were a lot closer than you would
think the 2016 match was trailing uh
near the end and he just edged out the
variant in the tie break Fabiana Karana
was a very close match as well it hasn't
all been easy but somehow he's got this
Champions characters always you know the
what Champions need and he's always been
able to uh Edge ahead and now indeed he
stepped down voluntarily and we will for
the first time in many years for sure
will have a new world champion
indeed we will one of the most dominant
stretches of Chess comes to an end not
the most dominant that honor belongs to
Emmanuel Lasker uh who defended his
title six times and was world champion
over the course of 27 years but for now
it's time for the world number two and
world number three players to take the
spotlight and there is quite a bit at
stake here other than the world champion
title there is a massive prize pool the
champion earns 1.2 million euros and the
runner-up gets a pretty decent payday as
well 800k I think they'll take it and of
course the world champion automatically
earns the opportunity to defend their
title in 2024 so Anish and we really
don't have to belabor this point this is
massive
a of course of course it's uh it's huge
uh world championship title it's a dream
of every child I guess you as well uh me
we will start chess you know would you
want to become a little Dania there's
you know six year old or I don't know
however old you are I want to be a world
champion you know we're all like that
aren't we
we are indeed and uh some of us you know
only some of us have managed to achieve
this incredible honor and we don't want
to sugarcoat an inish it's disappointing
the Magnus Carlson is not sitting in one
of those shows we're not here to pretend
like that is a good thing but we are
here not to pretend but to claim that
this is going to be just an incredible
match world number two world number
three so let's enjoy the moment what
happened has happened right now we have
a world championship match in front of
us and we have a match that has a pretty
interesting format there are a couple of
changes from the previous world
championship match so listen very
carefully of course there's one point
assigned per win and a half a point or
Draw as is standard the players swap
colors each game that is a change from
the previous world championship match
where there were two consecutive whites
a draw cannot be offered before move 30
move 40. of course a repetition of moves
uh is allowed and the most important
bullet point there the first to seven
and a half points wins the championship
also known as a best of 14. Anish I
think best of 14 is a nice balance
between what we've had throughout chess
history we had a best of 24 in a capoba
Blanca Oscar we've also had best of 10.
I think this represents a happy medium
what do you think
yeah agreed you know things moving
faster with the times you can no longer
sit there for over a month and debate
who's the best player in the world
that's just not in spirit of the times
that said you do want a substantial
number of games so that you feel free to
take risks at the start even if you lose
you have enough time to come back you
don't have to be nervous you don't have
to play all to save and so I think yeah
14 games that's what everybody sort of
have you know the consensus that has
been established and I think it's a fair
number
and I think a big part of this consensus
is the negative experience that was had
in 1984 between Kasparov and karpov and
matches used to be first to six wins of
course we know what can happen there an
endless number of draws that match
lasted for five months before it was
canceled by fide president campomanas so
we're not doing that anymore we're doing
a set number of games and as we've been
speaking the players have assumed their
seats for the first time they have
chosen their shares carefully
and we're five minutes away five minutes
away from the start of the 2023 World
Championship Anish I think now is the
time to talk about how the players are
feeling do we even need to talk about
the players are feeling is that up for
debate
no I mean Jan is trying to
to pretend like he's all he's all chill
but I mean it's quite obvious the you
know the the pressure pressure is huge
especially I can tell you at least from
my perspective as a player how I feel
these minutes before the game these are
the peak of your of your tenseness you
know that once the game starts somehow
the the old habits kick in and you just
you know you just just focus on the
process really but now you've got
nothing to do the five minutes to go and
again you're twirling in your chair
everything you know trying to look cool
but uh the nerves are nerves are high
and I'm sure sure both layers are very
very very very very very nervous right
now
it's a relatable feeling I mean each
player knows that hundreds of thousands
of fans family friends coaches
supporters seconds teammates I mean
classmates Everybody is watching this
match everybody's eyes are trained onion
on Ding and they will be trained on the
pieces in front of them Anish Jan has
the white pieces in game one does that
add a certain amount of pressure does he
have to assert himself or are you
expecting a kind of slow roll okay let
me get settled into this match let me
make sure I don't lose game one kind of
thing
yeah I was thinking about it as well
actually and you they're just two ways
to go about it really you could indeed
and as most players traditionally have
done from what I remember so far the
first game white players treating it as
something you know as a warm-up but that
gives a small Edge to the player with
the black pieces because maybe the
second game is no longer a warm up and
he's got one more white uh I do think it
could be interesting to really go all
out in the first game just try to apply
the most psychological pressure on ding
before he settles in that's an
interesting approach that's a little bit
unusual I haven't seen people take that
in a world championship matches recently
not the ones that I watched but I do
think that's an interesting one maybe
and I think it's safe to say Anish that
that decision as to whether to take
risks not is influenced by who you bring
uh to the world championship match with
you and of course there's been a lot of
speculation a lot of talk about the
teams that these two players have
assembled Yan is known for having a very
vast team of grand Masters and seconds
and supporters ding really on the
opposite side of the map but of course
breaking news uh was made by my client a
couple of days ago the ding has brought
Richard report to Astana with him what
do you make of uh that piece of news
it's very surprising I mean I wouldn't
have guessed it if you give me
10 guesses and you there are 11 names
with reporting and in there I just
wouldn't wouldn't be able I mean he's a
one of the greatest players
um of Our Generation Richard and a top
player very knowledgeable but somehow I
just couldn't I just don't see the
connection you know ding there in China
Richard uh from Hungary currently in um
Romanian represents Romanian chess
and the openings don't really match uh
ding has a very very clear-cut solid
repairs are Richard's jumping all over
the place with crazy ideas perhaps ding
wanted that something extra that's
something unusual to add to his
to his very consistent narrow style so
maybe maybe that's that's something
something new some special extra
ingredient that he that he needs
and the world championship is a good
opportunity to bring that extra
something to the table we say Yan
debuting his Petrov at the world
championship that became a Mainstay of
his repertoire ding is perennially an E4
E5 player but we saw ding make some
pretty crazy changes that Todd of Steel
he was playing E4 but probably that
would be associated with the fact that
he had to hide his preparation there was
a handshake I don't think the players
are shaking hands just yet these are the
dignitaries the officials the Arbiters
who surround the board this is a
production Niche these aren't just two
players there is a village that's behind
this and the first move is about to be
made
you know let's let's see what happens
there sometimes these moves uh they can
be taken back so they could go like one
E4 and take it back and then play D4 so
it doesn't mean much what what happened
just now so but let's see for Jan to
make his first move
yeah some players like to troll and uh
you know order the dignitary to play H4
and then they retract it and play it
more normal if sometimes the move does
indeed correspond to the one that they
want to play and already and unknown and
unknown to start the match what move is
Jan going to play Anish quickly what's
her call each word
did you say E4 and if I said I said let
me see what I said
you're gonna watch it it's you're good
to see what he played the game has
started it is in fact E4 that's what I
heard okay now Dodge the bullet there
now E4 is Jan's favorite throughout his
career he's especially recently he's
brought in his repair a lot he also
plays one C4 also the D4 the Catalan all
sorts of different openings but I guess
for the first game it's so important
yeah you you stick uh you stick to your
uh Comfort comfort zone to what you know
best it's one E4
and ding taking a couple of seconds to
just settle in and he has that couple of
seconds to spare the time control in the
world championship is vast you've got
two hours 40 moves and then 60 minutes
for the next 20 moves and then another
15 minutes after move 60 is made and
there's the 30 second increment and that
Anish was not a surprise E4 E5 is on the
board
yeah you know what's interesting about
taking these 50 seconds maybe not only
to settle in but to make it look like
he has options and to make Yan for the
next time sort of think that you know
you have to also be ready for other
first moves so the E5 is not the default
I am choosing if I have options maybe
that's the thought
that's such a great Point wait a second
should I play the Sicilian or should I
save that for game three exactly Knight
F3 Knight C6 is on the board so no
Petrov ding sticking to his guns and
every Lopez by Jana ponchianich
yeah that's um that's what young plays
uh as his main weapon he played that
against uh Magnus Carlson as well I do
think in this match we will see at some
point the Italian the third move Bishop
C4 as well another very very big
Direction where uh E4 players are
looking into but for the first game I
think Spanish makes sense he just wants
to see as well does ding Play The
Marshall that he always plays that's his
A6 first or does he go perhaps for the
Berlin which is another very solid
opening the ding sometimes plays as well
that is three out of six
in your earlier point and he's just well
taken ding again takes you know 30 45
seconds there no Berlin he will play A6
and there is an intermediate question
before the ultimate bigger question of
whether ding will play the Marshall of
course Yan can also deviate with an
early D3 for example uh there have been
some changes in real Lopez fashion over
the last couple of years but
historically Jana has been a Mainline
real Lopez player
yeah indeed and uh I guess within the
Royal Lopez there are other openings
there is this uh opens open
um uh Spanish so-called Knight takes the
E4 after a short castle and um there is
also these are count just variations
where the bishop comes to C5 but I do
think um these martial setups are by far
the most likely ones and I expect them
to happen today let's see Knight F6 uh
young can play D3 already here or he can
Castle first
they'll following the main line he
castles carefully adjusting his rook and
presses the clock the players executing
the opening moves fairly quickly now
that they've gone into the routine you
can almost feel the tension subsiding
just a little bit your point I think is
very well taken the Jitters have
subsided just a bit they've settled in
here they are they're just playing a
regular chess game at this point Bishop
E7 on the board still following the main
line
yeah now that's a good point uh as I
told you once at some point the Instinct
sort of take over and you know sitting
there moving the pieces that's that's
our comfort zone that's what we all
chess players have uh grew up doing uh
you know still
oh okay nice nice it's a I know the
first exchange you know you know who
played it against ding
I don't
enlighten me
okay take a guess it's someone named
giri there is someone named Daniel did
and you know I love him vaguely you know
but I don't really remember what he's
known for yeah no no no other CEO of
justice.com of course but amongst others
uh oh rookie one okay I have actually
managed to to beat ding in the
candidates um not the last one the one
before uh In This Very system I played
D3 rookie one that is a small small
twist point being that you wait uh for
the d-pawn perhaps it will take a
two-step two-step approach and go to D4
at some point so
and the Deferred exchange initial you
can correct me uh if I'm wrong I'm not a
specialist in this line from White's
perspective is first of all very
different from the regular exchange
where you take on C6 immediately on uh
in response to A6 this is a different
type of structure uh it's been a veil
it's been played for many many decades
so this isn't exactly a new line but I
think people have to understand in the
early going that you can find new ideas
you know a new wine and old bottles you
can re-enliven old lines that have
existed for a very long time and that's
been happening uh quite a bit more in
recent years as players try to search
for relatively unexplored territory
yeah indeed it's really hard to reinvent
the wheel in chess like to come up with
an entirely new opening as early as move
one two three four five it's going to be
really difficult it almost doesn't exist
what you do now indeed is you go for
directions that are explored and then
within those try to find a surprise and
I have to say that this already is a
really big surprise
um by by Yan I have looked at this move
at some point in shortly so did ding but
it is really a sideline within the
sideline very well hidden far from what
you expect
um definitely in the first game so I
think uh very unusual starts and a very
interesting start with the match ding
already taking his time he might uh it
might take quite quite a moment here
it's an important moment as well E5 Pawn
is hanging Bishop G4 is very principled
then you have to deal with H3 G4 ideas
well a lot of a lot of uh things to
consider here
I want to ask about your Insight as to
what exactly he's thinking about but
before we do that of course it should be
pointed out as you did earlier that
blind adherence to chess principles
would dictate that D3 is automatic I
mean you're supposed to defend pawns
with a pawn if possible he defends it
with a rook and I think you've made a
very important point that he now
reserves the possibility of pushing the
pawn two squares to D4
um are there any lines off the top of
your head where that move can be played
maybe in response to Knight D7 yeah very
much so very much so let's say 97 and
now definitely D4 makes sense sometimes
c3d4 also makes sense uh you you want to
support the pawn so that after he takes
D4 you recapture towards the center uh
create this strong
um strong central pawns that is also an
idea certainly there is logic behind
move rookie one of course the downside
is that the bishop is even further from
getting developed now the opponent is
blocking its way
I actually had this idea of going Rocky
one and yeah it's it's
already here very crucial
Bishop G4 is extremely attempting
especially that these pieces are not not
well developed yet then H3 you usually
don't want to give up the bishop right
you go here
G4 comes to mind it's tactical very very
quickly doesn't it you can secondize
here very often it's a typical imagine
if that happens in Game one of the world
championship how crazy would that be
and imagine how uncomfortable ding would
be feeling here facing Jan's World
Championship level preparation here that
would be insane Bishop G6 is also a very
common move sometimes you can even
sacrifice the spawn here E4
sort of
I'm not sure I can take here because
Bishop takes his G5
Knight takes is Knight G6 so maybe I
cannot take what they sometimes do in
these kind of positions sometimes they
sort of play a pawn down because if
let's say I take here you get some
you get some ideas okay that isn't
probably bad you want to clean out and
cast along all the stuff could happen
um Bishop G4 is definitely the sharpest
option but we'll see
but yeah I think you you make a good
point that the E5 Pawn could potentially
be sacrificed so people should not be
shocked if in a certain position ding
sacks the E5 Pawn uh and gains
development or weakens whites kingside
in return but let me return Anish uh if
I may to the question of what exactly
he's thinking about he's now taken uh a
good chunk of time four minutes and
Counting uh is dingler and spending on
this move is he trying to remember
existing analysis or is there any
likelihood a niche that he hasn't looked
at this would you assign that a
likelihood of Zero no no no no not zero
not zero there's a there is a chance so
uh ding
he is of course well prepared everybody
is well prepared at the top but I know
players that are even more meticulous
um and more of a sort of a control freak
uh types ding even when I took and
played D3 in the in that candidates
tournament uh that afterwards he
confessed took him sort of by surprise
already
you could certainly see him uh patching
up this line and forgetting about the
optional for q1 so I do assign this uh
probability of let's say 20 percent
uh much more likely that he had looked
at it what happened a lot uh with ding
in my experience and also the games of
him that I watched so very often he
takes I think it's around 10 minutes
usually 10 minutes after his
sort of surprised
and then he starts playing the variation
that is sort of some forcing variation
without thinking so he wants to
recollect the entire line before showing
another showing it on the board and that
takes him usually around 10 minutes that
could be happening so we could see like
a 10 minute pause and then both players
are starting to Blitz
interesting so the way I'm seeing it
there's almost two levels of surprise to
what Jan is doing the first of course is
Bishop takes C6 avoiding Mainline rule
up Lopez and presumably avoiding ding's
famed Marshall preparation and the
second one within one surprise there is
another uh like the Russian doll Jan
Lang Rook to E1 avoiding the main line
with D3 and posing black with an
entirely new set of problems Anish what
is the main move for black after D3
maybe we can compare specifically the
virtues of rookie one in contrast to D3
as we pull up an analysis board
yeah so uh I should also mention that
this position is very similar to the one
arising from the ante Berlin and I think
it's relevant to bring that up as well
just so we so we compare because there
it's a lot more common so this is the
Berlin this is the ante Berlin not
letting the on getting captured Bishop
comes uh justify very often and now
white can take here takes Castle I've
seen this once or twice yeah you've
definitely definitely did it's a very
very very common system now there are a
few uh differences first of all in the
Spanish we have black has played A6
now that comes with advantages and
disadvantages very very tiny ones and
the other difference is the bishop there
is on E7 and here is on C5 now if the
bishop comes back to D6 it's going to be
the same thing
but
it could uh it could not and then there
are differences so in this position
there are a few approaches so Knight D7
is always possible it's defending the
pawn
Bishop D6 is also possible and this
bishop G4 move that's sort of always the
most principled yet the most risky one
as I mentioned because of HTTP G4 uh in
this particular position Queen A7 also
is a possibility now in the position we
have
um in the game if Jana played D3 Queen
A7 is out of the picture
Bishop D6 or Knight D7 are the most
solid moves and there is the wicked
Bishop G4 there is also sometimes the
move Queen D6
a little clumsy but possible if white
goes for Knight D2
then black can choose between B5 or
Bishop E6 this also exists
uh I think the the most popular move is
Knight D7 but in that game that I play
against ding he played Bishop to D6
I can go on yes
just really quickly from what you're
saying rookie1 almost combats three
moves at once Queen D6 is met with D4
Bishop D6 is met with D4 and Knight D7
can be met with D4 uh please continue
yeah that's that's exactly what I um
what I think is the point so
looking at this sort of logically uh you
could say that Bishop G4 here is
extremely tempting now when you say com
is met with D4 of course uh this is not
the end of the variation Bishop D6
um D4 does look particularly nice for
white I have to say but already
um let's let's say the
the move like Queen D6
that is uh
a second
instead of Bishop yeah yeah D4
it's not the end of the world of course
you don't want to take and allow the
fork
but there are options here uh I'm
looking at I'm wondering if Bishop G4 is
the possibility I think it is 97 also is
uh is one Bishop G4 looks
then black takes the queen and
recaptures on e4 with an extremely
favorable end game very much so very
much so so uh D4 is far from from a
collapse for black also Knight D7 it's
not like DeForest uh necessarily better
than d380
yeah it's sort of an assumption we make
that now we can play and we will play D4
after C3 all right or directly
is did he did he just play 97 as well he
did 97 has just been played
after a pretty long think right around
10 minutes ding has indeed played 97 you
called it an issue he took exactly the
amount of time that he tends to take
when he gets surprise kind of
recollecting his analysis and Knight t7
is on the board and now the ball passed
right back to Yana pomnishi will we see
D4 will we see a sort of flexible move
like Knight C3 uh or will we see a
transposition back into mainstream with
D3 that's the least likely option and we
get our answer D4 is on the board
yeah Jan doesn't uh doesn't do these
little tricks where he takes a moment or
two he just when he's prepped he's
prepped you know he announces it I I was
prepared for the stuff I've come
prepared I have something in mind and
I'm gonna play it right away I remember
everything I don't need to think um and
you just played D4 directly I like this
much more confusing is approach that
some other players take like Magnus
Carlsen uh I think he he stole it from
Grisha grishek was the OJ he was the OJ
of this approach of
knowing what you're supposed to play yet
taking a lot of time
sometimes to remember but more often
than not sort of confuse your opponent
because imagine you take five minutes
for a move you know
and at some point five minutes for the
move that you no longer know and the
opponent just doesn't know where where
did the prep end is it still prep it's
already moved 30 or or was it never prep
but how could it be demo prep he knew
I'm playing this and then you're just
going crazy behind the board thinking
that the prep is lasting forever it's an
approach
and when you're particularly eager to
drag your opponent into certain
territory let's say you've prepared an
incredibly dangerous tactical line you
want your opponent to not smell a rat
and go into the main line confidently
hey clearly he's not prepared that's
where I think that method is at its most
effective here ding knows that Jan
didn't just pick rookie one and that
move fell from the sky he just decided
to play it so I agree with Jan's
approach there's no need to play games
Jana's not one to play games on takes D4
and game one has reached move nine the
queen recaptures attacking the pawn on
G7 and will ding Castle short that seems
to be the only feasible option Anish
maybe Knight F6 is a possibility
what do we think is going to happen here
yeah I mean Castle is very tempting like
uh generally A good rule of thumb is
when you can Castle you should Castle
and uh it's really rare in chess in the
opening that when Cass and Castle is
possible it also defends the pawn on G7
you would look for an alternative like
you mentioned of course there are
options especially Knight F6 is probably
the in alternative and it's definitely
not losing by no means doesn't even look
terrible but I I guess our instinct is
right here just constantly right that's
what he does as well
he castles he doesn't belabor the point
he plays quickly and now it's right back
Tiana promise you who continues to Blitz
out his moves the bishop the bishop
comes out to F4 which one could argue is
less natural Anish than Knight to C3 but
this is a let's get down to business
kind of move because it immediately hits
the pawn on C7 and maybe discourages
black for that reason from moving the
Knight let's say to F6
yeah black is quite cramps you could see
that this uh Bishop's uh sort of blocked
by the Knight
and now the
the upside of this Knight D7 setup in
general is that
when white 2.66 what happened is white
has given up the bishop pair
in return for a better Pawn structure
now black has got these two Bishops as
their main asset now when you play
Knight D7 the bishop is sort of hidden
on C8 the same time it's nicely hidden
from the enemy so you preserve the
bishop pair with this 97 approach to
later develop this bishop pair and use
use and utilize the advantage in your
position now that said still the short
term black has to find a way to somehow
regroup his pieces because this is not
harmonious right now the the sort of the
back rank the pieces out all
disconnected The Rook on A8 uh one you
know the Rook should belong belong to
the center files the bishop belongs
somewhere out there so black has to
somehow reshuffle their pieces move like
Knight C5 comes to mind I don't know
what else what do you think Daniel might
be able to create or something
yeah I'm trying to figure out where the
bishop the light squared Bishop can be
deployed uh of course one could suggest
a move like B6 but that seems incredibly
cumbersome because once you feed keto
then the Knight on D7 is also weakened
Anish so maybe B6 could be met with
Knight C3 then The Rook comes out to D1
very quickly that doesn't seem
appetizing to me in the least
yes indeed now I want to briefly discuss
uh pick your brain on why young played
Bishop F4 before developing the Knight
usually that was a rule I believe it's
attributed to Alaska developing the 94
Bishops right that was the role yep
certainly before Queens by the way
certainly but I I have come up with an
alternative rule uh in in the opening so
I believe the queen can be developed to
the center as long as it can't be
targeted by the Knight
um in this fashion with Knight C6 I
think the queen does stand pretty well
here now the question is why did Jan
Play Bishop F4 and note 93 now the
answer is because the computer said so
but the question is why did computer say
so
say so yeah I guess I I think I
understand why so after Knight C5
trading Queens is the most natural and
now black can recapture with the Rook
activating the rook and in the case of
Bishop F4 first
if now you do the same the C7 Pawn is
going to fall and so you have to do this
less uh less harmonious recapture with
the bishop where the Rook is still
passive so probably that's the reason
and one could say well is that really
important the Queens are off the board
it kind of is because C7 is a very
Troublesome point you want the d8 score
for your Rook so now in order to to
change hands you have to go 96 and that
blocks the light squared Bishop so you
know it's when you're operating in a
cramped space uh you put a piece on one
square it hurts another piece so Jan
could be aiming for a small but enduring
Edge in the end game which Anish would
be very consistent with the type of
strategy that we predicted this is kind
of the ideal scenario you settle into
the match with I don't want to call this
a two result game right I don't want to
jump the gun but a position where Jan
would feel very confident that he's
unlikely to lose
yeah at the same time the more I look at
this the more I realize that maybe uh
when you ask me how big a deal is that I
was thinking yeah maybe not such a big
deal because you will develop the bishop
eventually maybe Knight comes to E6 and
what I realized the other point that
Bishop F4 has and that's maybe the more
relevant one even is it after Bishop of
49 C5 I can now attack my queen away
very nicely on E3 just behind this
bishop because if I have done it if I
had done it after Knight C3 it would
have blocked this bishop so maybe
besides having a
um option of going to the end game maybe
the point is to go Queen E3 and I think
we'll see that shortly I think Queen E3
is the more natural move and um
and uh ding just played Knight C5
already so
and I believe the Yawn is away from the
board otherwise I think we would have
seen a move already there's no way that
Knight C5 was not anticipated by Mr
Napoli so an early exciting moment will
we see a queen trade will we see the
Queens remain on the board Queen E3 I
like the look of that it aims keeps
aiming at the Knight black it just feels
a little bit awkward and white wants to
go Knight C3 Rook 81 very active easy
play in the center guess what we need
three and ding was taking a rest there
we need three is already on the board
and up from the chair again
yeah and I have to say one thing is
clear to me the ding is prepared Knight
C5
is not an OP it's it's a obvious move
but there are options here you could
consider maybe C5 maybe rookie 8 in a
pretty situation with so much you know
so much tension and such an important
one as well so early in the match unless
you know Knight C5 you don't play this
fast so I can tell you that Ding is
still in his uh preparation the question
is how far the preparation goes How
Deeply he knows the subtleties after
9523 Jan certainly uh better prepared
for this game in what sense perhaps
their files are identical but Jan knew
that this is coming today whereas ding
had no idea so Jan has rehearsed and
delved into the details much more
recently and knows them much better so
in any case Yan is better prepared for
this for this battle today but maybe
ding also remembers things quite well
we'll see here depending on how quickly
he responds
not to take our attention away from your
excellent insights over the board but
ding is not currently at the board he uh
was resting on a very plush chair in the
rest area he of course is aware that a
move has been made uh or is he I think
there must be a monitor there that
alerts him to the move that's usually
the setup what do you think do you think
that he is resting is he relaxes he
thinking I'm sure you've played
tournaments where you have this kind of
setup you have the option of sitting
away from the board and resting
yeah you do so that is a normal setup
certainly it takes this High event this
will organize there's going to be a
monitor I believe ding is looking at
that monitor thinking I think we had
seen the same thing in the previous
match Jan was doing this a lot you might
as well think in front of the monitor
now that with all the online she has
been some popular it's a normal normal
kind of situation yeah looking at the
monitor thinking
um trying to recollect not no need to to
be there at uh at the board now what I
do wonder is if if ding is aware that uh
there's camera in that room I hope for
him he is because I remember that once
in the match um when Magnus played he
was in a very strange position in his
chair definitely not aware of the fact
that he's being filmed
Well for now you know doing hands in his
pockets he's kind of sitting pretty much
motionless hope he's not asleep it is 3
23 p.m over in Astana of course it is it
goes without saying that the
pre-tournament routine the pre-match
routine is essential particularly in the
last couple of days the players have to
arrive with Boundless Energy and he's
particularly given the time control so I
don't want to overstate the case here
he's not asleep he's thinking he's
trying to remember his file and I'm with
you sometimes it's easier to remember a
file that you created on the monitor
it's easier to remember it on the
monitor
that is that is true now I wonder if
he's able to flip the colors and change
the board scheme as well to make it even
more familiar
and make it more like chess base and you
know put in a little stock fish on the
bottom you know
uh
[Music]
I see also some some food there I guess
it's always nice these restrooms um
you know it's a little oh there's always
a little bit of food a little bit of
drinks nice couch
um always a nice uh nice place to be in
but ding yeah quite Motionless
what what moves come to mind here Dania
what do you think
what moves come to mind after Queen E3
it's move 11. it's Black's turn he's 20
minutes down if I would go with my
intuition well there's obviously Bishop
G4 uh developing the bishop maybe
walking into 95 but 95 isn't necessarily
all all that great uh because that
creates some problems for white as well
then there is of course a knight back to
E6 which we've uh mentioned in several
different positions then maybe you could
revert back to the plan of B6 Bishop B7
um once if he encato the bishop you
vacate an escape Square for the queen
because presumably white will go Rook 81
at some point so that's a problem that
black will eventually have to solve so
that's what I'd say comes to my mind
Anish Bishop G4 96 and maybe a
non-descript move like rookie 8 although
I think ding is much bigger fish to fry
right now than worrying about his Rook
yeah I agree my instinct also was Bishop
G4 I honestly don't quite recollect this
position maybe it is in my file as well
somewhere but I don't quite recollect it
like you I totally agree with what what
you said
um we could add by the way that there is
sometimes the idea of going F5 at some
point that's sort of a theme maybe
somewhere you could uh you could
consider uh going for F5 but I'm not
sure if
yeah that's that feels way too premature
here frankly uh Bishop G4 followed by 96
or 96 first and then developing Bishop
to B7 that's uh that's a tough one and I
hope things knows what to do at the same
time even if he doesn't
this kind of position
you know how how wrong can it go
um it's a playable position I think it's
not going to lose out of the opening but
he could get under pressure that that
could happen
and that was exactly the scenario that I
wanted to attempt to illustrate if I may
show a very rough sample line we could
ask ourselves okay what is what is the
worst case scenario for black well the
worst case scenario is he plays Queen D6
here I don't think that's gonna happen
let's say he goes Bishop G4 what is
White's ideal setup well I would imagine
that White's ideal setup involves
bringing the Knight to C3 putting the
Rook on D1 but before you solve that
problem you have to decide whether or
not you're playing Knight to E5 the
downside of Knight to E5 is that black
Now controls the D1 square but just
complete the topic of White's ideal
setup
um after
Bishop two G4 white plays Knight C3
let's make a random move for black white
plays rook 8d1 and gets everything
assembled in the center if we assess
Anish how good this is how impressive
this is I gotta say I think black is
still solid even if Yan makes all the
quote-unquote ideal moves what do you
think about that
no certainly I mean Rook on defile you
know it is not not impressing anybody
too much
um I'm not even sure I'm not even sure
indeed if what is better here now
currently what bugs me uh frankly the
only thing that bothers me here is the
Rook 98 if had it already been on d8 I
think black would have been perfectly
fine we would be able to trade Rooks on
the open defile and even long term if we
if we speak really long term if we ever
get to an end game with a bishop pair
black could even take over the
initiative but in with the Rook on I8
yeah that that's frankly what what bugs
me here and white could exploit it maybe
even do something ambitious with
maybe with a even H3 G4 I dare say would
be consistent with the unstyle
certainly yes and um
after Bishop G4 I also had the thought
I'm not sure it's it's good uh to chase
this bishop with a move like Queen H3 uh
trying to get rid of the bishop pair now
if you've got Bishop G6 which seems to
me like probably the only sensible move
I could start with knights3 and then
bring the rook and then later get rid of
the bishop pair now if we trade the
Knight for a bishop and white loses this
um issue of not having the bishoper and
then the position should be one-sided
pretty much although even so these
doubled pawns as we know from various uh
various openings such as the the Berlin
uh end game and so on this is not the
end of the world for black of course
with the spawn structure you have to
always realize if we enter opponent game
one day
right will be winning
but as long as there is a pair of light
pieces on the board it's no no longer so
easily winning and uh in the long run
you could push all these pawns forward
and even though
you know the they're doubled still you
could generate some country play and
sometimes undouble them later on and so
on so a very subtle position uh ding
meanwhile has played Bishop G4 as an fg4
all right Bishop G4 is on the board and
I think you brought up a great point
about the pawn end game some people they
hear that they think well we're very far
from upon end game but it's super
important to have a general roadmap when
you're playing you have to be aware in
rough terms of who benefits in the event
of a queen trade who benefits in the
event of a heavy P straight queens and
both Rooks because that helps you make
decisions later down the line Queen
trade uh is not available right now but
it could be in a couple of moves so next
big decision for Yan he has adopted the
kind of pose Anish of one who is still
in his preparation or is he
um his body language suggests to me that
Bishop G4 is sub-optimal
he is giving that look of uh yeah I
probably had seen that move but it
wasn't so good now let me try to
remember what to do against it how to
refute it of course the age-old question
that has plagued super Grand Masters
forever I know I looked at this move I
know it's not in the top two options but
I don't remember what to do against it
it's actually an infuriating feeling and
you should my you know pitiful low level
I imagine that when you're playing
someone of Jan's caliber and you know
that you have an opportunity to punish a
sub-optimal move but you don't remember
how that's got to be a frustrating
sensation
yeah that said in this particular
position since it's so sort of slow and
non too concrete
you you know it's not the case of why
it's having to necessarily find that one
um one killer blow right there's nothing
forcing you don't have sacrifice any
piece you don't have to go for checkmate
I mean frankly you could choose between
93 or 95 and whatever you choose
it looks it looks kind of nice for white
uh for the time being both of these most
clearly don't mean by force Flex
position is extremely solid there's not
that much pressure on Yan but of course
it would be nicer if he if he remembered
what to do and go for the position with
the yeah with the best chances
I assume the answer to this is no is
there any case to be made for Knight bd2
or is Knight C3 basically automatic
yeah I know
I think 92
would make sense if black intended to
take so that you could recapture with
the Knight I don't think black ever
wants to take
yeah yeah I mean it's not going yeah I
mean it could go to C4 or to F1 G3
first of all to G3 it could go via E2 as
well
and on C4
I think if the bishop was on D6 you
would be sort of targeting that Bishop
but given that the bishop is already on
E7 I'm not sure Knight on C4 is such a
great piece also you should
keep in mind that there is this rule
it's it's a very
it's not a rule you have to live by but
there is this rule that nice to defend
each other are not great
they should sort of not really be doing
that and the point is that somehow
there's one square less for each of them
that they sort of control because they
control each other if you see what I
mean this is not the rule that always
works but but it's a rule and I think it
could apply here somewhat 93 I guess to
you as well it feels feels more natural
good move
height F3 to D4 has been played in a
relatively short span of time
wow yeah for sure remembers hey for sure
remembers this move because uh it
doesn't come to mind so quickly if you
don't know this move you might just not
come up with it
it's all nice a little bit odd
but it but it makes it certainly makes
sense but it's just a little bit odd um
93 certainly more logical to begin with
but I guess it's prep
so what exactly is the purpose well
first of all white is preventing the
option of Bishop takes F3 which arguably
was not a huge problem that's sort of
the direct thing that this move
accomplishes the Knight on D4 could be
used as a vehicle for Middle game
tactics in the event that black plays
Bishop F6 there could be some Knight
takes E6 ideas not immediately because
B2 will hang there and then you'll lose
the rook in the corner so to me Bishop
F6 is the move I'd play in a bullet game
and you know I play a lot of those so
maybe we can take this move to just
really tease out some of the finer
points of Knight D4 what do you think is
going to be why it's response is it
gonna be E5 or something like C3
I have to say I like the I mean I always
like your instincts their bullet just
thinks I'm a big fan uh I think if you
just played your bullet instincts in a
classical game you would also become
Grandmaster they're really really good
uh and I like this move Bishop of six a
lot because for working E5 that's a very
clever strategic idea because now it
weakens these light squares and uh the
only thing I have going for E5 is that
maybe here because black wastes so much
time we have a good development and
perhaps can exploit some short-term
factors such as the fact that the Rooks
are not connected here
is definitely a move that comes to mind
as you mentioned 96 just doesn't work
because at the end of the tactic there
is the uh yeah there's a little issue
there
C3
it weakens the D3 square a bit and
doesn't gain us time unlike E5 so I
guess at this point I'm thinking by
elimination E5
um must sort of be the way to go
and yeah things things get very
interesting now the question is what are
the Alternatives now the first move that
came to my miserable mind is 96. my
horror understands things to try and
trade all the pieces as fast as possible
are kicking in
no it makes sense trades whites trade
White's strongest piece takes takes and
maybe I can try
yeah maybe Knight C3 Rook D1 you know
along standard lines yeah I would indeed
start with that and what I like for
white is that uh at some point I'm going
to make the smoke Queen G3
targeting the C and C7 pawn and also uh
creating some chances here on the king
side at least I I just like this for why
it just looks slightly better to me I
mean
I like this configuration of the queen
here at Bishop here is Queen G3 coming
in with the one 96 96 a little bit of a
um it's not too bad but it's a little
bit passive a little bit unprincipled
there is also a possibility now perhaps
more than ever the rookie it makes sense
makes a lot of sense here now and after
K8 I assume Knight C3 F like 94 very
often can be followed by the move F3
reinforcing the pawn right and uh
hitting the bishop but I would guess
Knight C3 first still more logical and
here we could go between six and after
E5 now we don't have to directly Retreat
the um there's also 96 I think now oh
that was that was that was exactly yes
this is the moment where it works good
point now it works no Bishop takes B2
yeah so rookie eight probably just not
not a good move
um yeah honestly besides a bishop of six
in 1996
I mean there's always this move like
Queen to this seven
bringing the route to d8 maybe that's
not so stupid with the sound
I think it's totally reasonable this is
a problem you had been highlighting for
a while where the queen
interrupts the natural coordination of
black Strokes you play Queen D7 you
reinforce the F5 Square Knight takes C6
doesn't come with Tempo anymore so
there's a couple positive byproducts of
this move and after Knight C3 Rook d8
white doesn't have Rook D1 that is that
is a drawback of the move Knight D4 you
will have to chase the bishop out of G4
to enable the move Rook 81. so here it
seems like white will have to act very
accurately
yeah after Queen descent perhaps F3 or
H3 and then I could do this instrumental
with Rook data so let's say
something like
it's hard to say after your H let's say
just for argument's sake what I meant is
after H3 I could consider Rook 88
if that makes sense
it does Knight take C6 is still you know
I said it's impossible now but
blackheads this big development
Advantage yeah Knight drops back to E6
at the end doesn't feel
doesn't feel like it you know yeah no no
it feels a bit wrong you sort of helped
me develop a lot and I'm taking over the
um initiative to an extent
yeah a big
big moment now it's interesting you know
the
this is like uh it's one of these
positions
that is on one hand could be random
because I don't recall any high level
games here I don't think there are we
could check in the opening Explorer at
some point but I I don't recollect and
certainly nothing recent uh
at the same time it could sort of be a
large tabia within nepo's preparation he
could have spent hours and hours on this
uh so it happens a lot in modern chess
there are these positions that are on
one hand obscure and random because
nobody played them on the other hand
there are big tabias because people have
big analysis on them in their opening
files this looks like one of those like
it's a very rich important position or
Jan's world championship match
today people have other than Jan and
maybe Ding and maybe a couple more in
the world maybe Fabiano I don't know but
people have just never seen it you know
it just it blows my mind it's a very
primitive point but how rich and
expansive of a game chess is where 12
moves into one of the most well-known
openings an opening that has existed
since the 16th century rulopas himself
authored one of the very first chess
manuscripts where he introduced the
opening that is now named after him
where 12 moves into a line Bishop takes
C6 deferred exchange that's been known
for many decades and we're basically in
completely new territory not just in
terms of the position but also
ideational in terms of the ideas
available for both sides in the meantime
just wanted to bring your attention and
the fact that Ding he's been taking a
good chunk of time he's already 33
minutes into his two hours that are
allocated for the first 40 moves he was
snuggled up on that favorite chair of
his in the rest area with a hoodie on so
he's getting real comfortable but maybe
not as comfortable on the board as he
was on that couch
I have to say that I don't really like
that this
being in staying in the sort of in your
restroom
um this was what Jan did a lot last last
time
I don't know I mean I I'm used to like I
want to see players sitting there um I
don't know if that's the spectator on me
but even as a player this is just a bit
it's a little weird I mean I think
you're supposed to sit at the board and
that's that's where the magic happens
you know if you play over the board
chess it's not over the restroom chess
right so I don't know it's a little
unusual and I'm hoping we won't see too
much of that but maybe maybe that's the
New World Championship uh way of playing
it you just sit at the restroom think uh
in front of your screen I don't know
I would bet a silver dollar that Ding
has spent more time uh in on that chair
than he has at the board and uh you know
I'm getting Justified with every second
that he's spending there now ding has
spent uh many many years trying to get
to where he is today he's had an
incredible chess career but a very
topsy-turvy ride that ultimately has
brought him to Astana let's take a
somewhat deeper dive into dingleren's
incredible path to the world
championship
dangly wren's unpredictable path to this
year's fide World Championship was born
from the right combination of good
fortune and persistent gameplay
ding's journey to Kazakhstan almost
never got started travel restrictions in
China prevented him from qualifying for
the candidates the Gateway tournament to
the world championship but when a spot
unexpectedly opened up ding ground away
to earn the vacated seat and punch his
ticket to Madrid
[Music]
his foot in the candidate's door ding
struggled in the first half of the
tournament failing to earn a win and
falling to the eventual winner Yana
pomnushi
but that's when the magic began in the
second half ding began to turn things
around starting with a resounding win
over yankea we have a victory for
dingley Ren and his candidates chances
are not gone at this time
ding then continued his momentum with
back-to-back wins over Rickard Rapport
and Fabiano caruana
in his final match of the tournament
ding squared off with Hikaru Nakamura in
a battle for second place with rumors
suggesting Magnus Carlson might step
down as Champion second place at the
candidates now had an entirely new
meaning
needing a win ding took advantage of a
missed Opportunity by Hikaru on move 38
and worked steadily from there to secure
the Victory and second place the second
half of the tournament has been his four
wins in seven games
while his runner-up finish at the
candidates was certainly an
accomplishment ding left Madrid without
a seat at the world championship
that all changed later that summer when
Magnus announced he would not be
defending his title
with the five-time champion out of the
mix ding's second place finish at the
candidate suddenly became a golden
ticket to Kazakhstan with the rare
opportunity to cement his name amongst
the distinguished list of fide world's
champions much like his opponent ding
chose to skip most of the high-profile
classical events over the past few
months and instead selected to immerse
himself in his preparation to face nepom
machine
time will tell if that approach and
ding's string of good luck and
competitiveness will earn him the most
famous title In classical chess
well ding is a consummate professional
he is extremely well liked by everybody
even Jan fans have to admit the ding is
just one of the most wholesome figures
in chess it just feels great that he's
finally been able to earn himself a spot
uh to potentially achieve the biggest
most prestigious title in Chess World
Champion but that title is very far away
Anish as we take a quick look at dingly
wren's uh overview career overview Queen
D7 by the way by the way has been played
by ding we will get to that move very
shortly but Anish your Insight of course
is incredibly valuable you've played
ding countless times what comes to mind
when you look at uh this short resume
yeah certainly one of the greatest
players of Our Generation been high
rated for a consistent period of time
for many many years currently number
three what was number two for a long
time it's beaten Carlson at various
occasions and the famously at the
sinkfield cup once they played a tie
break and at that point Magnus has had
an incredible record in tie breaks he's
the one like all of them since like I
don't know 2006 or whatever it was for
decades he was winning all the tie
breaks and then ding managed to overcome
him and win that syncful cup was a
a prestigious event so dink definitely
definitely a world championship
Challenger already for many years when
it comes to his level and his Rise um
recently
it's been sort of a combination of
bad luck because he got stuck in China
due to the pandemic couldn't travel very
much but also this unexpected good luck
where suddenly
he somehow got all these opportunities
he got into the candidates thanks to the
rating spots where somehow the things
just came together and he played Just
Enough games in China to to get eligible
for that and then finishing second which
usually doesn't bring you anything and
now just was good enough so the
combination of sort of having a bad luck
and then having good luck somehow
propels him to the world top but he's
always always been at that world top for
many years and
one of the greatest players and
especially when he is at his best some
of the games that I played against him
when he was at his best it felt like
playing against the computer and
afterwards I looked at the games and
I've lost a couple of games against him
and it's just like you faced the
computer they were perfect I didn't play
that I didn't play too badly but um
he was just so accurate and his
understanding of the opening was so deep
um but that certainly comes through all
the hard work it's a hard-working player
that he is so definitely a very
impressive player
one of the most just memorable
experiences that I had commentating the
candidates in Madrid was just watching
ding share his analysis after his win
against district report the way that he
demystified a position that we could not
grapple with at all he just seemed to
know which lines to calculate he
calculated them with machine-like
precision and that is indeed uh the
dingly ren that we have come to know and
the dingly ren that will have to show up
here in Astana if he wants to deal
janapanushi his second world
championship match lost and as we
mentioned that we also need to mention
that Queen D7 is the latest move played
here in game one 12 moves have been
played in janapanushi he has adjusted
his sitting position he's actually at
the board uh Anish which is a pretty big
step for these players thus far
yeah it's a big deal now I had a chance
to pick uh you know when we were
watching this marvelous video about ding
I picked into my uh files I was curious
I couldn't resist and I can tell you all
right with a little more insight of what
what actually happened there in the
opening yes please now indeed I I have a
file on over rookie one and there are
indeed a bunch of options 97 being one
of them and again there were all the
options we mentioned c393 all possible
D4 also one of them indeed Queen D4
Castle Bishop F4 actually reasonably
known very few games in fact this movie
rookie one it hasn't been played at high
level at all apart from one recent game
by Massive drawer by Lee a azerbaijani
player not quite a top player but a very
nice
competent strong GM very competent
certainly certainly a very strong GM
just not uh you know top 10 player or
anything like that but but definitely
but that was just one game of him a very
obscure uh variations of no no reason
why this would come up in your
preparation as something urgent but the
computers
say this is possible it's more or less
equal and um the new move came here
indeed Bishop G4 is very is very rare
it's not been played at all in fact the
six or six to ten games that have
occurred here went 96 and in my file one
of the variations goes Knight E6
and then the uh what you mentioned not
but not B6 but even D5 that's what
computer prefers B5 a little bit more
active and then developing the bishop
here uh that is estimated by the
computer as sort of roughly equal and
that is also what the games what the
game suggested Bishop G4 is playable but
a little sub-optimal according to the
computer and just no games here
afternoon before I picked I have to tell
you the line here is very beautiful and
very difficult as well everything would
have been okay for black if not for a
nice little trick and I will let you
spot it after H3 oh uh Rook 88
in fact
okay I'll let you just put it here in
this position yeah let's just move in
this position is it Bishop takes C7
uh it's it's slightly it's a tricky one
because it's not a trick Justin you have
to set up a trick you have to set up a
trick okay yeah
I can sense you know I look at this
position I can just smell it I can smell
that there's something
um give me a second it's a difficult one
I'm curious if you find it because I
don't think I would definitely found
that if I knew not none it existed but
the computer pointed out to me so it's a
nice one also for our viewers the more
advanced ones to try and uh find the
best one excuse Mike juices is still 549
but please continue yeah certainly AG 24
is sort of the normal uh way to proceed
but that will be more or less equal it
should be seven which some of you
mentioned as well as we have pointed out
before in some versions I guess is I
guess black just has a lot of
um activity here for uh for the uh for
the pawn but yeah they have an idea yeah
is it Knight B3 and queen takes B3 Queen
B7
I'm putting you on the spot here I'm
really sorry because I it's just very
hard uh Bishop E5 was an idea that I had
Knight C3 e
Knight C3 that did not I mean I saw that
this existed Queen D4 and now can you
get an advantage in the end game or no
Queen no but you could start with 8G
right then if you wanted the end game
here is a trick
and now you will spot it now you will
spot it I'll give you nine seconds
95. oh my God yes it's very difficult
stuff I mean I just didn't see it coming
it's incredible but that's important in
fact the computer even starts with nice
history for some subtle reason
and after Rook 88 now H3 intending 24 95
saying and that that is the reason why
white is better and Young
maybe doesn't know because Queen is not
light because of it and if he doesn't
know it no way he finds this no I don't
know no I mean well he knows that this
is good for white and he's got a lot of
time so you know he's a world
championship Challenger so he might find
it but it's not going to be easy at all
and you know what the issue is you
mentioned the bishop C7 sub-optimal I
feel like when there are these red
herrings it actually makes it much much
harder if there wasn't the option of
winning a pawn two different ways I
think the likelihood he would find this
increases tremendously I hate the
situation where you know that you can
win a pawn but you don't know if it's
the refutation so what are the facts you
know you know that this is sub-optimal
for black you you know that there exists
some sort of punishment but you don't
know what form this punishment takes do
you win the pawn or is this or tactical
is it more positional we talked about it
it's an infuriating feeling
yeah and Knight C3 is actually none of
the above its positional based on the
Tactical it's just really hard and you
may you made a very good point I mean if
you know that there is reputation and I
told you that there is something as well
uh Bishop C7 indeed comes to mind uh the
winning the pawn but it's also hard for
a human to judge um like is is blood
does black have enough compensation
um
because if I get Knight to D2 on Ponto
C3
uh it will not be enough but I guess
what comes to mind here is takes a 96
maybe that is the way to regain the pawn
that's a really pretty idea because you
seem to give white control the center
but it's very concrete white just
doesn't have the horsepower literally to
defend the G4 Pawn Yeah the horse is not
on D2 yet the course is a bit far from
the power yeah exactly
um no Jan doesn't doesn't know this that
makes it actually very very exciting
because the yeah I will I will be hugely
impressed and if he finds that actually
nicely I would think that he might even
have it in the file and
if you should have it in the final I
should mention how many options black
has before the move Bishop G4 uh
there is even the option like the
incredibly beautiful one I had in my
file here there's some G5 move here it
makes sense apparently as well no way
why I mean
he's pushing the pieces back and then I
guess then that's why that's also in my
file and that's probably neon's file as
well there's all sorts of options and
instead of Knight D7 every move is
possible there as we mentioned Queen D6
and Bishop G4 are very valid and they
all the three of variations becomes very
wide and the file is very big and both
sides have a lot of options and from all
these different trees there is a small
branch which goes um well this is still
a big Branch but then there is a small
branch of Bishop G4 within which Knight
D4 within which there is another
Suboxone move Queen D7 it could be in
that huge file but would be not would
could be in the file but not in Jan's
head because often what I experience
when I have these huge files from my
seconds
I don't have the time or the energy to
go through the entire file I go through
the things that I find most relevant and
this is a sideline of a sideline you
might just not have clicked through it
and now he has a pressure is on him to
find this incredible incredible idea of
knights of three H3 and Knight to D5
to quote my uh High School physics
teacher remembering a line like this is
like trying to find a fly in a cathedral
and I think a lot of viewers they tend
to assume that top players are immune to
human influences like you know memory
loss and the inability to remember eight
million different lines and
subvariations absolutely not they spend
much more time than uh you know your
average Grandmaster even reviewing
studying memorizing I'm sure you can
co-sign this point uh Anish but uh you
know that does not mean that they will
automatically remember everything even
in a world championship match and I
think it's safe to say Jan is going to
invest a good deal of time to try to
figure out the proper way to squeeze the
most out of this position it's an
incredibly exciting moment the stakes
could not be higher will he find this
beautiful idea with Knight D5 that
remains to be seen and folks this is a
good opportunity for us to take our
first break you are watching the 2023
fee day world championship between
janaponishi and dangly rendes is game
one do not go anywhere we will be back
with more World Championship action on
the other side of this short break
sorry
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 fide world
championship this is game one of this
incredibly exciting match between world
number two janapam Yoshi world number
three dingley Wren and yes if you're
just joining us if you're new to the
chess scene Magnus Carlson for the first
time in 10 years is not participating in
the world championship match he has
abdicated the throne to one of these two
players jaminish giri GM Daniel
nerdinski chopping it up for you today
as the game enters its second hour a
niche we left Jan was thinking we
arrived Jana is still thinking but it's
not a surprise because the idea that he
has to find if he wants to squeeze the
most out of this position is beyond
complex
yeah yeah let's let's just uh show it
again 9c3 Rook date H3 in some order I
think after H3 first uh I think
certainly intense Rook 88 as well it's
going to seven update idea I really
liked as uh as you did as well that one
with when we first found it and now this
uh incredible tactical resource nc324
and 95 increments so disrupting the
connection between the rook and the
Queen and if takes you've got this
intermediate checked 97 check and then
you recapture with a bishop and that
actually is a crucial Cog in the machine
because now like as two minor pieces
hanging at the same time
yeah it's incredible stuff no I was
wondering now okay so let's suppose Jan
doesn't see it which is normal because
the human doesn't see it now what what
things come to mind here and I was
thinking I kind of wanted to disrupt
this diagonal because I want my Rook on
D1 so one thought it was F3 the other
thought was ninth one to D2 and Knight
to F3 perhaps
yeah if I may before I get to that just
wanted to clarify one very small point
which is that after and you can correct
me if I'm you you're the one with the
incredible file after Knight C3 Rook ad8
H3
one would wonder you know what happens
if black just goes Bishop H5 I just
wanted to show that white does have the
incredibly nasty Knight F5 putting huge
pressure on Lex Bishop the G7 Pawn Etc
sorry that's just what I wanted to
clarify that's why Queen takes D4 is
just kind of obligatory if you wanna you
know keep the Flames of White's
initiative uh at Bay except you don't
yeah also notice this movie Bishop H3 I
assume the idea here is the same GH and
Knight D5
I guess or maybe not
there's some sort of Bishop of
sacrifices
maybe is the point
Knight F6 and if Queen Bishop G5 there's
Queen G6 oh yeah the G coin is kind of
kind of missing you win the bishop
move like H6 in the worst case yeah
but the computer was not happy with
something so there was some reputation
here let's see
is it could it be Rook 81
could be for F3 yeah
Bishop G4 F3 I've got and then I've got
Knight F5 discovery
yeah nice yeah this one's Knight F5
comes not obvious you know when you
don't have the bar uh on the stones on
the left telling you that it's all good
it's not obvious you have to think about
all these things really not easy
um yeah I'm wondering what the honest uh
what I was thinking about here so
how bad is this move F3
I was thinking there might be 96. I
forget if we already discussed this
not in this particular version I guess
yeah it makes makes sense here and then
now when I take
you just feel like the initiative loses
its luster once you
you know once the nights are traded
maybe a minuscule a little something
something for white but
I feel like they won't hold this
position very little for two reasons
first of all compared to a position we
looked at earlier today first of all
black got the rookin so the queen is now
nicely tucked away and the other thing
is that the spawn after actually
disrupts this queen G3 idea which was
really nice
not sure it's a good version for white
indeed F3 I actually just doesn't feel
doesn't feel very nice Knight one did so
that's also I don't know I'm not
impressed with that move
possible yeah so process of elimination
would dictate I feel like he's gonna
play H3
you think so yeah I mean 92 and Knight
to F3 you see the engine the eval
barrels doesn't hate it maybe it's it's
a move to consider it feels a little bit
I don't know a little bit off a little
bit wrong perhaps not the most ambitious
yeah H3 okay but H3 I mean he knows the
Rook idea it's coming that is because
you mentioned Knight F5 so in Ozark area
it's coming and you play H3 if you have
something in mind for okay d8 I would
better and better be something something
good like that because um
the other things are Bishop to someone
as we saw was nothing thrilling we
discussed the line Queen takes C7 and uh
at the very least maybe black has other
ways but at the very least uh fourth
line you just regain it again the pawn
looks kind of equal uh on the I the
first I test let's say and
um otherwise this HG HG move
it's not too impressive right Queen D4
you take okay you can go for the same
game okay by the way you can play the
same game you can play this in game 93
maybe now or
yeah I think the former world champion
would you know salivate at the prospect
of a position like this with white and
it's black
yeah exactly you would win this with
either color yeah yeah yeah it would
saliva it's just uh you know either
either way because he's very good at
everything but um in terms of computer
didn't like 93 yeah the bar went down
I'm thinking is it something to do with
some sort of thing yeah Rook before is
what I was thinking some tactics yeah
maybe yeah because you can never play E5
because of rooftex f4 probably and not
again not obvious I mean 93 is the by
far the most natural move so what is the
bar want me to play does he want me to
play F3 or
I think it is probably was the bar
giving an advantage to White
not really I mean you can see the lines
here and okay Knight D2 is the one with
the small
or yeah this is really far from
impressive now black black has got a
slightly worse uh phone structure of
course but so active the knights nice
the Rooks yeah the defile are nice I
wouldn't be scared at all
you could lose control of such a
position with white like some Knight A4
move could come and then Bishop F6 I
just yeah this just doesn't feel like it
has the weight you know of something
he's going to choose Knight C3 has been
played Knight C3 yeah and and he that is
even the right order by the way that's
even the right move order in fact that's
what the engine suggested to me
but let's you know as the expression
goes count the chickens when they've
hatched because after Rook 88 you know
H3
no other chickens no night that's the
only chicken here there's not the
chickens here after okay did so they've
already hatched Knight B3 here is there
any easy made for that I don't think so
now of course I mean
no but this is Knight F3 maybe is
appealing to him because of 95 now it's
miserable and I came from F34 remember
and now it went back okay
it makes no sense makes no sense at all
no no no the the chickens have hatched
the game is on Wow because Jan has
spotted the idea what is really possible
I tell you that it is in the file and he
was thinking thinking thinking what
happens a lot to to me personally so I'm
thinking I think I've never seen this
before and I calculate calculator
suddenly I think oh my God I'm a genius
93 Rook d8 H3 24.95 occurs to me okay I
am a genius and then I'm like wait a
second I've seen this before
am I such a genius and I'm like oh yeah
yeah this this was this was actually in
my file this is this probably what
happened very likely what happened to
Jan as well it takes you sometimes 10 20
minutes but then it comes back to you as
you calculate and at the same time your
calculation and memory they sort of
click together and that's beautiful
because that's what you want you don't
want memory to be separate from
calculation you want that your memory
calculation to be clicked you're like a
cyborg that has the AI you know in the
prep and the human brain uh during the
game and you had a cyborg Who is the
very Mighty and he played Rook 88 not
seeing H3
h395 I suspect
now one more thing that we I don't think
we mentioned after H3 could you dial it
back with Bishop E6 could that be a form
of damage control or night or night oh
or or Knight E6 yeah even maybe even
better because Bishop E6 allows Rook a
to do one
the bar just went four I mean because
white is just it's just it's just
crushing in the center yeah yeah I mean
everything we got everything your whole
Bishop G4 uh maneuver just the bishop
never belonged on on E6 so this is just
really bad The Rook is protected so
there's some x-ray issue there's Queen
G3 issue as well I I think the damage
control move maybe is 96 in fact would
that be the damage control idea
also not yeah a little bit of damage
control yeah but it's no no it's uh yeah
a little bit but
very very bad yeah
the point you made about F3 is really
well taken because we had a line where
White had F3 included and here we see
how crucial the move Queen G3 is to the
successive white strategy it's you
absolutely get the advantage without it
absolutely compared to the line where we
had the pawn on F3 here yeah when we
couldn't uh have swung here the queen
that was almost nothing and here we are
crashing so yeah what would be the
damage control move after H3
oh wow
wow oh wow that's nice I think our
reaction is one in the same and that's
prophylaxis against that the defense of
the bishop nice no this is this is high
class this high class Rook F2 E8 oh my
gosh
and now after 8G 24 Knight D5 no longer
comes with the same effect because you
can take take and now the bishop is
protected
beautiful stuff wow
I have a theory that yeah go ahead
and I was about to say that I I think
ding will have to find that by
elimination I think he will but but it
is really really beautiful and hard
but speaking of beautiful and hard first
of all nepo still has to play H3 he has
the face of someone
who is you know he's literally
salivating at the prospect I think of
making this move as he looks to the side
was this in my file is this actually
what I looked at yesian it is and we are
fully expecting at this point the move
H3 what a disappointment it would be a
niche or a royal disappointment it would
be if he didn't play it if he played
something like Queen G3 or Knight B3
yeah I know this is Knight F5 by the way
uh that is also an alternative text says
it doesn't look um that looks actually
quite interesting maybe rookie eight
maybe F6 or something oh I don't know
some your bullet instincts must be must
be enjoying oh yeah this is this is the
30 Bishop
yeah yes
complicated
I'm scared but it is also tempting but
Jan indeed
at this in this position he he's I think
he realizes Queen he realizes 24.95 is a
theme now but he has a position in front
of him with the right move order as well
so
oh no no we thought we thought
oh
four Falls you see before you mention
this move he would have played H3 and
then you put it into his mind and Knight
F5 is on the board yeah I mean okay uh
it was a really hard idea and it
probably wasn't in the file or even if
it was he has never seen it because if
he had ever seen it
he would have it would have come to him
neither five yeah I when I opened the
engine with the moves the list of moves
I saw this Knight F5 it's one of the
moves and I that is also a little bit
better for it and I was like oh you got
the feeling that this might be the one
that he's attracted to because it is
nice as well it is nice if it wasn't
nice you would have no options because
Knight B3 that we suggested Knight F3
that was that was second rate stuff you
don't want to play that that's sad
Knight to five that's also going forward
it's also exciting that's something that
you might might be learned
um into and then you just don't see this
95 idea I mean good to see that
everybody is human and it wasn't really
really difficult I mean if you hadn't
seen it um even knowing that it's there
is logical it it doesn't occur to player
even like Jan but this is this is still
challenging so the line we looked at
let's continue that yeah if we could
bring them in an hour this line looked
really promising actually so Bishop F6
is not possible because you dropped the
Knight on C5 that's why yes F6 is so
powerful
and GF we should also point out that GF
is maybe a reasonable candidate move
actually but by the way yeah I I assume
that this it looks like it's made but
it's actually not because once the king
is here The Rook is here it's okay it's
okay yeah gf's possible but of course
the the classical move is Bishop f8
right that's the classic move and then
after Queen G3 now you're thinking here
I mean it doesn't impress
um
too much but it it could get tempting
for white this could get tempting I
don't know G6 or
something snapped the pawn off on c7a
yeah probably that's his idea
yeah maybe yeah I mean
that pawn was kind of dead weight anyway
though so it's almost like blackheads a
tempo
and can use this Temple 22 maybe but
probably the tactics fail they're for
black I'm wondering if I just play like
that this F6 spawn I mean if I had a
queen on H6 delivering Checkmate on G7
had Bishop not been on f8 that would
have been a huge asset but if we
actually trade stuff and Bishop remains
on a f8 it's a weakness and it's kind of
doomed I think pretty much I'm gonna
pick it up eventually and then if this
situation will become very equal so yeah
not not sure this is too promising maybe
F6 is a little rushed maybe there are
some other ideas like cleaning G3 first
perhaps
although the fight is hanging by the way
sorry I should not forget the five thing
or is it yeah it is
it is yeah it's not not tricks here yeah
I don't see 37 or rookie five
everything's perfect Bishop C7
is possible but again it's never
impressive if white if white has to
resort to this move you know that white
is out of you know aggressive resources
yeah I mean trading the F1 to the C1
actually will uh what is the word like
symmetrize the structure again Google go
back to symmetry which is uh not not
very uh and not very impressive and
everyone
[Music]
Rook D1 so now Queen F5 impossible
because if Rook takes d8 but I think
there might be
six yeah yeah yeah it is six yeah Bishop
D6 I was hoping for some kind of
some kind of something 35 but no no this
definitely doesn't work even rookie one
I'm pinning the the queen
um and if I move the queen yeah where do
I well in fact the problem is you will
take only one and I will have to take
back with the rook and then there is no
more pin on the bishop so yeah Rook D1
was was a mistake
um
yeah I think F6 I think he's putting his
eggs in the F6 basket
yeah I guess so I mean just move like
Queen H3 doesn't make much sense I'll go
Bishop to F6
I guess is there six is the basket
um
Now Plenty funny thoughts some Queen
said Queen sec how ridiculous is the
queen sack I was thinking about it
briefly um rookie three
GF first of course and then you I assume
wanted to recapture the rook and go for
some or with the bishop
and go for 94.
yeah yeah
I'm wondering also if black wants to
recapture with the recorder King maybe
the king keeping the Rook active
okay these are starting things but
because yeah a frog takes like you said
maybe a rook takes
yeah but even like I feel like 96 and
that yields the four square you know
yeah there are some aggressive ideas
here some some but I I don't think that
this kind of uh stuff is more than uh
more than equality for white unless
there's something concrete because
material is just really not in White's
favor you've given the queen for only
rook and the bishop even if you have a
pawn it's not quite enough and black
king is not that uh poor especially once
the pawn appears on F6
quite safe of course you you don't want
to allow like the infiltration but I I
don't know I'm not sure this is like
nepo's idea I think he sees it but I
don't think this is like the the main
point of his um of his play
maybe in a rapid game but it feels like
a solvable problem with the amount of
time that that Ding has I had a more
general question but I I didn't you know
don't want to take us away from the
analysis let me float it to you and you
know you can mull it over I want to
proceed very delicately because
everybody you know knows that I I hold
these players in the absolute highest of
regards but in terms of weaknesses and
you know the self-assessment inducted by
these players you know the so-called
pundits have claimed throughout Jan's
career that he can tend towards
superficiality sometimes he's a very
fast player he's always played really
fast do you think that there's any Merit
to the idea that that has cost him or is
this what makes him yanubaneshi or both
yeah I guess it's always both right I
mean you notice that with the uh you
know in life like everywhere the your
weaknesses are extensions of your
strengths and uh same with Yan I mean he
put so much pressure he's so quick
but at the same time the other side of
the coin is that he is a indeed
sometimes too superficial
what surprised both myself and Jan here
he made a visible um surprise gesture
effects 96. he expected
I think dinga is somewhat scared uh yeah
scared by this F6 business and he went
for 96 which is
it is
solid but now white can sort of
recapture the bishop that no longer is a
bishop pair on the board
and so white doesn't risk anything
anymore
there's just the pawn majority
if I get to stabilize
um yeah I don't know will I be slightly
better or is that not enough
it feels like black has maybe Knight D4
and some piece activity yeah kind of
like the end games that we looked at
that's why I said if I get to stabilize
because I right now I mean maybe you
have some options but I'm thinking you
know if I get even if I trade even
everything even the knights somehow
um I will be slightly better because
your C7 Pawn will be doomed in the end
but I should keep the Queens on the
board
now if you imagine hypothetically just
for for the argument's sake
I play F3 I trade the knights
I
don't need to trade Rooks but I could
even but if I get like Bishop to F4
Queen to G3 King to H2
you'll never touch me and I'll hit your
C7 pawn and that'll be very nice so
white has something to look forward so I
guess
question yeah that looks very pleasant I
think the Knight is the engine of
Black's counter play here you have to
try Knight D4 and you have to try to
protect the knight from a trade maybe
with C5 but then that yields the D5
Square
yes yeah so uh once we established that
white one something then we know the
black should uh try to put sticks in
into our wheels and and try to disturb
our long-term plan of trading uh all the
right pieces indeed 96 a question is do
I have to take right away now
unfortunately I don't have that Rook D1
tempo
because the Bishop is hitting that point
out the clever internet so F3 is not so
clever after Bishop C5 yeah
the hunter becomes The Hunted yeah very
much so
into g into G3 yeah takes and takes
right yeah it just not very good yeah
just takes and takes and then okay this
bishop is very strong
and Bishop E5 I thought was the other oh
yeah it looks nice that looks nice I
like it
yeah that puts a lot of pressure doesn't
it f F6 Maybe
maybe F6 mm-hmm
some clever incrementals here maybe
wow there's not something really
tactical there
it's lots of uh takes takes takes takes
takes takes and logical logical logical
so that's not so much here
not so much here going on any other
tricks
it looks like there's there are tactics
here but it's it's hard to put your
finger on something yeah yeah I don't
quite see it because
if I go back you allow Bishop C5 so
maybe I can take oh yeah I can make now
first
yeah and just go and say that you've
induced a small weakness yeah maybe
um maybe I mean it's very hard to say F6
is a weakness
um or or a slightly useful move it's
really hard to say
yeah it's it's a double-sided coin just
like yeah
rapid play
exactly
um it's not too obvious it's a very
subtle but possible yeah so I guess
that's what Jan is choosing so are you
correct to say that Tiana is basically
choosing whether to take and go Bishop
G3 directly or induce F6 is that is that
the point here
yeah so Bishop I think he also has to
establish that after Bishop B5 F6 there
are no juicy tactics so I think that
that's probably step one is to look at
all the queen g3s of the world and then
to conclude okay I have to play 97 then
step two is okay do I induce F6 or do I
play 97 immediately that this is World
Championship chess right here ladies and
gentlemen do I induce this tiny pawn
move that could be good it could be bad
it could decide the game it could not
this is what Yan uh has to occupy his
mind with Jan has been very occupied uh
in the last year or so to get to where
he is right now this is his second
appearance uh at the world championship
he lost a Magnus in uh Dubai 2021 but
he's gotta keep that out of his head and
he's keeping his Knight in his hand and
he's capturing the bishop no F6 induced
yeah I just unfortunately sort of guns
played this move because just as I was
about to uh you know prune the and check
check whether the engine uh suggests
that we missed some tactics we actually
missed the resource here there's a
beautiful idea of Bishop H6 which is
really cool
definitely analysis board needed for
this
yeah just a very cool idea if you go GH
I go Knight H6 which is a double attack
and if you go Bishop F5 I go EF and now
I Target your knight as well so this is
very interesting option that it's far
from obvious to me and didn't probably
occur to Young because if it did
um he probably would spend more time or
maybe he dismissed it on the account of
Bishop F6 either way he just went for a
solid uh solid small um class with 97 27
and I told you I like that I like that
94 you mentioned honestly Rook C1 not
scared too much no Roxy one
yeah I mean I I mean I see what you're
trying also C7 was saying by the way but
but let's say I didn't see the sample on
the second and Bishop is on Bishop E5
probably was very good but even if I
don't see it
I mean yeah it's it's very limited how
much counter play Black gets and after
F3
okay night time before is nice but I
will try to trade it with 92 I anyway
wanted to trade it
no white setup is lovely and The Rook 91
stops Queen takes C3 here which is kind
of a nice detail
yeah I mean
I really like uh Jan's chances but it's
also because I am often biased towards
uh positions where where things are very
one-sided that are risk-free so I tend
to overestimate there is three
advantages which also comes back in my
style but uh I'd really like this a lot
for white
uh just a very clean position Everything
is Everything is balanced apart from the
pawn structure which is to my advantage
so this is this is really lovely like
everything's balanced the only
unbalanced is in my favor so just just a
slightly better position for white and
nothing for black and a very unpleasant
start to the match for ding it's very
unpleasant yeah I think for the first
time we can State clearly that the
position is unpleasant or one side
because before we didn't have sufficient
Clarity to be able to make that claim
because it was all contingent on one
side finding a certain move now we can
say that Jan probably has more than one
candidate move uh at in each position
you pointed out F3 I think that's very
likely to shut out the bishop and make
the move Knight C3 to E2 possible in
response later on tonight to D4 of
course you're gonna have to defend the
C2 Pawn first as we had discussed so F3
is a clear candidate move Anish are
there any other clear ways to improve
your position
uh like you said yeah we've reached a
position that's quite stable uh we can
delay of say we can start with uh
another move let's say H3
uh but in essence I do I do think F3 is
is a good move to start I I think
um white the danger for white is to sell
the advantage a little too short so uh
in pursuit of uh trading all these
pieces you could by accident
land in a situation where you have to
also trade the queen somehow or you
somehow Focus too much on trading all
the right pieces that like at some point
jumps to the queen side of Queen before
and generates enough counter play for a
draw so the adventure wise that you just
might sell it too short and uh Play
Slightly too inaccurate and give like
good drawing chances uh so you could try
to be very subtle here with white to go
for the maximum advantage that you have
but essentially the price of a move is
very low and you can just do whatever
you like the only question is yeah what
is your matter of choice really what you
do I I would stay away from
I would stay away from the idea of f4
which is tempting
but I think this is uh how things can go
wrong for white so if you let's say
you you sort of spot that F5 is meant by
EF which is very nice but maybe you will
allow
a knight D4 first right and then and
then a five and then black gets to
control these slide squares and the
bishop gets shut off so I would stay
away from this other than than that I
think yeah all the moves like F3 maybe
H3 first with B3 first maybe Rook C1
first are good I wouldn't start with 92
because I don't think I want to allow
this trade I think the knights is a very
good piece and I think I want to keep
the opposite color Bishops I want to
trade the knights eventually and um
and not give like the opportunity to
keep this from nice
and why give black that option and I
just wanted to clarify uh that Black's
position is solid we're not saying black
isn't solid but the position can be
solid and unpleasant at the same time
you pointed out that the price of a move
is pretty low for white guess what it's
relatively low for black as well we're
not expecting Jan to win this in three
moves we're not expecting him to win
this in 33 moves maybe he won't win it
at all the only thing we're saying is
that you know comparatively White's risk
is very low and white has a clear path
toward improving his position
better Pawn structure objective metrics
indicate that white is slightly better
and this is exactly what Jana punish you
what the doctor ordered for him uh in
the first match game of his second world
championship So speaking of his world
championship experience let's take a
listen uh to Yan nepomnishi's path to
getting to where he is right here in
Astana
the story of Jan napomnishi's return to
the fide world championship and the
mounting pressure that perhaps follows
him in Kazakhstan began two years ago
it was then at the 2021 fide World
Championship
faced Magnus Carlson who was in search
of his fifth straight title in his
prestigious event
o gave Magnus plenty to handle through
game six which proved to be the longest
game in event history ultimately taken
by Carlson and that is Magnus Carlson
taking three and a half two and a half
lead
after that nepo never recovered and
failed to win a game for the rest of the
match Magnus had his fifth World Chess
Championship and the promise she left
Dubai with a bitter taste of Unfinished
Business
his loss to Magnus behind him napomnishi
entered the 2022 candidates tournament
last summer in Madrid with a renewed
sense of purpose
with rumors bouncing about Magnus not
wanting to defend nepo managed to steady
and at times dominant performance we
have a massive victory for young upon
machine what did you say Almira Catch Me
If You Can with four wins under his belt
from the first half an upon issue
cruised through the second half with
another win over for Russia and a string
of useful draws to secure the bid as
Challenger
undefeated in Madrid napomnushi had
earned his return trip to the world
championship without truly knowing who
he would face or prepare for who do you
want to play in the World Chess
Championship literally I don't care yet
a question of who his opponent would be
was answered later that summer when
Magnus decided to step down as world
champion the door was now open for an
apomishi to capture the most coveted
title In classical chess
at the candidates in a foreshadow of
things to come neponishi squared off
twice with dingley Ren drawing as white
and winning in a dominant 32 move
fashion as black
nepomishi has given ding little to
prepare off of nopo has played sparingly
over the board since Madrid dropping
just one game at the sinkfield's cup and
playing in only one other major
tournament
fresh rested and with World Championship
experience from his clash with Magnus
two years ago that pomnishi is
considered by many to be poised to
become the first fide world champion not
named Carlson in over a decade only time
will tell
well the longest game in any world
championship match was 136 moves that
was the famous sixth Match Game of the
last Carlson nepo match that's where the
wheels really started to come off for
Jana pomnishi but uh Anish I think
what's often missed in the conversation
about Jan's first uh match you might
disagree with this but before game six
he actually had some serious chances or
advantages we always seem to talk about
this like it's determinist that this is
how things had to happen but guess what
if Jan had saved the sixth game do you
think there's any Merit to the point to
the idea that that match might have
looked completely different
yeah obviously absolutely and I feel
there are two uh yeah there is the one
um that is
playing incredible chess and is one of
the best players in the world the one
that can challenge Magnus Carlsen
unequal terms and pull a lot of pressure
but then there is the one who collapses
once things don't go his way but you
have to understand that things have to
first not go his way for that to happen
so if the entire tournament or a match
goes without any major issues for him
from start to finish he might just play
very well on sort of one breath he's not
known for his comebacks but if there's
nothing to come back from he would just
be there and he will just win and that
could have happened yeah that game six
in fact if you remember uh it was not
just that he could save it he had
multiple opportunities in that game to
even take over the advantage at some
point he was even close to winning or
actually objectively speaking winning so
if he had won that game I mean Magnus is
a great great fighter and who knows
obviously but uh it would be a different
yarn and you know the energy as well
like you get tired but positive emotions
they give so much energy so much so much
boost you can achieve by just having
these positive emotions and I think
things could have gone very different as
a good point you bring you bring to our
attention
yeah and it doesn't mean Magnus isn't
the superior player he obviously is Max
is the best player in the world but you
know we know that these matches uh they
can go in unexpected ways because
there's so much more at play no pun
intended than just you know the playing
strength taken in a vacuum in the
meantime F3 has been played by Yan and
ding he says I like that idea he plays
the same type of move F7 F6 of course
the idea from ding's perspective is
different than uh the mirror image yawn
played F3 to open up the D1 Square for
his Rook uh to cut off Black's uh Bishop
on H5 which no longer controls uh D1 to
create a pawn chain why did ding play F6
and now yeppo plays H3 so some Pawn play
on the king side what do we make of this
yeah I I like that as I told you before
this HD King H2 I mean I love the
construction here nothing can ever touch
the king uh Jan doesn't Rush with 92-94
which is which feels right I think https
feels very good now the move F6 is just
a move um not too much to say about it I
should mention we skipped an important
moment here
this particular position
almost are similar for black apart from
one there was the opportunity to go for
F5 which is a very uh interesting idea
enough to F3 or H3 there is F4
intermezzo oh
and okay E5 would be a strategic missed
okay also tactical mistake on a
strategic mistake uh even if let's say
you're allowed whites to to go for F4
this would be really bad for white since
the night only six is beautiful the
spawns are blocked now forever
uh what white probably would have done
is taking on F5 then you can take with
the bishop and protect the Knight have
some counter play against
I'm sorry why I'm laughing in a second
because they just played H6 by the way
the same with the nepo but please please
please continue this is obviously a very
serious Canada move uh yeah ding
probably didn't take too seriously given
the speed with which she played Bishop
H5
yeah and uh I think that was a big
moment uh but once you skip that moment
once you choose not to go for a five
then yes you you can uh you can just
make commentators happy and copycat each
other's moves or or not or I mean it's a
matter of taste
um but you know
with every it's
it's there's something about this this
is an interesting point about this F3 F6
h3h6 thing and uh
it's very instructive in fact so
in positions where you have
a long-term advantage
these
small useful moves they are not of equal
value so with every F3 F6 h3h6 every
little consolidation
um consolidating move white is gaining
something he's coming getting closer to
consolidating the big long-term
strategic advantage so I'm pretty sure
that when F3 F6 and hdh6 happens it is a
yarn that that gets happier and happier
with every such move because if you get
King H2 and you got King H7 I go Rook C1
and you go Rook C8 you know I uh I go 92
94 like
I am coming closer to my to my end goal
to uh to get my desired position which
is to trade the right pieces and
establish a one-sided uh Advantage
whereas black is actually just standing
and waiting because yeah like at some
point runs out of ways to improve the
the his position so I think that this uh
the fact that they call each other
doesn't mean the position is equal I
think it gets nice and nicer for Rihanna
with every move in fact
well it's almost like you know it's
making one of my usual awkward analogies
it's like Jan has more money you know
invested in the market and they each put
the same additional uh amount in but
obviously that additional amount uh it
compounds because you had more money
invested initially so maybe that's one
way to understand it you know when you
improve your position the side that's
better to begin with uh benefits more
from that Improvement and King H2 has
been played by Young so we have
transferred the play completely from the
center uh Slash Queen side to the king
side and now three moves in a row
improving white situation on the king
side F3 and H3 we kind of decoded so H3
King H2 that's kind of one unit what
does that accomplish exactly is that to
make the king safer is that to uh
prepare something aggressive uh or is it
just sort of one of those surface level
moves that that can't possibly hurt
yeah I think I I don't think it's a
preparation for something concrete
aggressive I don't think F4 is really
ever on cars I'm not even sure even if
you get a four F5 I don't think it
proves your position at all it only
weakens your E4 Pawn if anything so I
think this is just a way to safeguard
the king now and look at how incredibly
safe and Untouchable this team is if it
was on G1 there would be some check uh
potential check opportunity but on H2
there's just no way you can ever touch
that King and it's so wonderful because
black can cannot say the same because
after King 7 Bishop G6
it's not quite the same uh we have
various ways to get to the to the king
eventually now I think these moves were
automatic so far but it's the next one
that will be off
the next one that will actually
determine what Jan wants to do and I
think he has the choice of either
getting himself ready for a rook trade
or um the this night trade and I I don't
know which path he will choose but
either either way it's just very
pleasant for for white I believe
is there any chance that black plays G5
in response to Knight E2
or is that just way too drastic
uh I think this idea yeah yeah but let's
say we inverse the move order just for
argument's sake I I think that
I don't know about about you I guess it
could be a matter of taste the bar
didn't uh Flinch very much but I
personally think that this is an
unnecessary further weakening because
you're not going to attack right or you
say that you could maybe you could yeah
too many weaknesses to begin with I feel
like black is just operating from an
unstable base yeah exactly I can
initiate too many trades really quickly
with Rook 81. yes and I I feel that
there is this sort of rule don't play
which is also by the very ambiguous and
you should not abide by it always but
there is this rule that says don't play
on the side where of the board where
you're weaker and I think this sort of
probably applies here but again yeah
this is very abstract not sure I I think
G5 is not going to happen I don't think
that's the the approach maybe to go back
to this F5 idea 265
I do I do like the fact that we would be
able to Target the C Pawn I think black
should be happy to
generate some sort of uh counter play
that has to do with something on the
queen side
so I guess Bishop G6 but then you wonder
why he played F6 uh in fact so it was
here yeah you could play H6 H3 and
Bishop G6 if uh so please if you had
wanted to play F5 yeah exactly
I don't I don't know why you you play F6
but mainly as we've said the price of a
move is not too high and uh yeah it's
sort of a more slow long term game but
the one where white is white is
definitely in control yeah so so it's uh
yeah black black has options
things move as moves have been
consistent with the sitting position
just sort of meditative slow and it's
also easy to procrastinate when you're
on the defending side because nothing's
gonna happen to you on the next move so
it's not you know it maybe lowers the
temptation of playing a move like F5 or
executing an idea like that when you're
getting attacked you know that you have
to act immediately here you're still
solid you know you still got your your
knight on E6 uh so it's suffering but
it's bearable suffering for the time
being
yeah it's you know it's hard to say if
it's uh what's better um on one hand
there is indeed no pressing questions
that you have to answer and you know
that you can't go much wrong right now
at the same time you do know also that
the problem with that is that sooner or
later there will come a question and
it's going to be a hard question that
you'll have to answer and uh you just
sort of delayed you know the effect is
delayed you know you will suffer nothing
on this move on one you will suffer long
it's not you know and at some point
there's going to be a question at some
point Jan will ask him the question like
what do you play and yeah I think we'll
have choice of two three moves and he
has to pick one and it's only one it
will be only one will be right but for
now yes you can for now postpone that
moment and you can play Rook to D7 you
can I don't know push put pawns B6 A5 or
or not or um
or put a king to H7 or not or Bishop to
G6 or to F7 or the price of a moves now
is not high but something at some point
will happen to you and so you shouldn't
relax
yeah the white walkers winter is coming
the white walkers have been spotted uh
and right now the player is kind of
crossing their T's uh no I always get
this expression wrong it's uh dotting
your eye yes and crossing your t's and
presumably they kind of will continue to
do so for the next couple of moves many
many ways in which black could try to
build up uh more robust defensive
foundation and we will take this
opportunity ding taking it uh to adopt
his new usual sitting position in the
rest area kind of continuing to meditate
on the best way to continue defending
folks we will take a short break you're
watching the fide World Championship
2023 it's Yana pomnishi against England
here in game one we're almost two hours
into the first game don't go anywhere
because there's so much more action
ahead we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I've
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got on
adjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if there's going to be folders now
so I can categorize by white black and
all tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how are you
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the way this is why I like to use
stressful it actually helps me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
welcome to check with mates the only
podcast by chess pieces for chess pieces
I'm a rook and I'm a pawn let me ask you
this you ever feel like you're
undervalued absolutely everyone's like
oh pawns they can only move one square
they can't go backwards new we don't
want to go backwards know maybe we're
focused on the future yeah I feel that
sometimes I wonder why we're even
protecting a king he wasn't elected
through a democratic process maybe I
want to be king dude I think about that
every day yeah okay real quick shout out
to our sponsor hellofresh I don't use
them because I'm a chess piece but I'm
sure they're great
[Music]
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
World Championship 2023 it is Yana
pamushi's second appearance uh here in
the most prestigious event he lost to
Magnus Carlson in 2021 this time he
tries to defeat dingwireen to take the
chess Throne this is the first game and
we are only 19 moves in so all of the
action is still ahead Grandmaster Anish
giri world number six and GM Daniel
nariditsuki world number I don't even
want to say uh bringing you commentary
today we hope you're enjoying the show
folks once again you got to keep your
seat belts fastened because it's only
going to get more fascinating from here
Anish I think you put it best during the
break it's almost like you can divide
this game into phases and not I'm not
talking opening middle game different
types of phases faster and slower we've
entered kind of a slower more chill
phase
yeah absolutely not so much happening
not many forcing concrete lines both
sides are black is mostly waiting white
is mostly choosing which pieces to trade
which slide a better position to go for
and eventually things will implode the
one thing I should mention now
especially for dink is I believe in a
position like that which is eventually
going to get unpleasant
a mistake you could make is to spend too
much time here because no matter what
movie you make you're not going to be
able to equalize so you shouldn't also
get down on the clock at the same time
you shouldn't play too quickly because
that will set up a wrong habit of you
know and get you out of the playing
Rhythm but I think uh especially playing
against the end things should not
over overdo the time spending and just
make some move maybe play Rook G7 and
don't don't overthink it
I had a more general question on the
broad subject of overthinking
from your perch on you know the Mount
Olympus of Chess I think fans in general
are really interested in the question of
form and how top players uh decide and
determine form would how early in a
tournament would you say you feel pretty
certain about whether your form is good
or is it something that you don't really
introspect on until the tournament ends
do you tell that to yourself during a
tournament man this is in my tournament
I'm not in good form I need to adjust my
playing style or is that invalid
yeah the question is really really
interesting and I think the one question
is what do I do the other thing would
should I be doing
um
I think inevitably you notice that you
are either in a good form or bad form or
rather
you sort of think that you notice and
that impacts
the way you play
whether that's good or bad I don't know
I I think it's more often than not isn't
very good because when you are thinking
you are in a bad shape it hurts your
confidence that means you start
adjusting your otherwise pretty well
tuned values you know you start to be
maybe more defensive which is really be
really bad or you start to play slower
because you double triple check stuff
you start to play more passive for some
reason you
you become even less ambitious or I I
think generally realizing or thinking
that you are in a bad shape it's a big
big issue
but inevitably I think players do you
just see how the game goes and it just
gets in your head and uh
it could happen as early as game one if
the game one goes really well or really
badly it could also happen much later if
the games are pretty neutral you know if
let's say today ding will depend pretty
well he will think that okay he's in a
fine shape hoping didn't go well but
everything is okay whereas if ding loses
he'll think that okay you know it's just
that uh well I mean even if you are in a
good shape if you're lost it's a problem
so losing is bad news
um
yeah when it happens after round one or
it just depends sometimes you know you
have games not like this one where just
not much happens somehow the players
meet each other in some theoretical
battle and then they somehow don't make
big mistakes and the game sort of
pitchers into some sort of a draw and
that could happen for one two three four
games and then nobody knows who is in
good shape I mean you can only tell that
okay the memory Works
um some Basic Instincts are there but
nobody's in a great shape whereas today
I think we will see uh we will see today
actually who is in what kind of shape
because uh game
is already in Balance so if Yan will
ruin his small Advantage then it's a bad
sign for him if ding will not defend
this position it's a bad sign for him so
already something something you know
something will come out there there will
be some feedback based on today's game
because things are already uh imbalanced
and Jan is in a very good good position
yeah I think compared to some of the
previous world championship game ones
that we've had and decisive uh results
were not uncommon throughout world
championship history uh in the 80s and
90s 9 out of 16 matches featured a
decisive game once so we might see a rip
a reprise of some of the old school
matches where the players just went
after each other uh but one player who's
not going after anybody is of course
Magnus Carlson and I said this at the
beginning of the show uh we're not here
to uh you know to to say things that
everybody knows is untrue it's a
disappointment and Magnus Carlson is not
playing in this match it's I I think
it's safe to say that it's an objective
negative it doesn't mean that this match
is anything less than absolutely
fascinating and that the title is
anything less than legitimate it is and
it is but as we look at the Magnus
machine and his 10-year Reign uh of the
world championship title and you should
still sometimes doesn't add up in my
head that no Magnus is not going to be
the world champion after this match can
includes
yeah we'll have to get used to that and
that's been the case before in history
it's not the first time we don't have to
look too far back uh the last time that
happened is when the Magnus was world
number one already for a few years and
what happened was still bishanan who is
a legend of Chess a great player uh
certainly was the world number one at
some point in uh uh at virus points
probably in his career but towards the
end of his reign as well Champion Magnus
was growing up uh both in terms of uh
Israeli but also literally growing up he
was he was quite early uh the party and
he was maturing as a player and already
it was clear by the time
we speak year
2010 11 12. uh I wish it was the world
champion Magnus was the world number one
and everybody knew that you know best
player in the world probably Magnus he
was winning most of the tournaments he
had by far High rating I wish it was a
world champion he was a legitimate world
champion and uh what number one and the
world champion were two slightly
different uh well slightly different I
mean entirely different people and that
that is okay that happened and in
history before it happened many times in
fact even when kramney has beaten
Kasparov he has proven that he is a
legitimate world champion he literally
beat Kasparov in an incredible match
still following that I played many
tournaments
as part of remained world number one he
won most of the tournaments he
was the best player in the world by all
these objective metrics but it was
kramnik was beating him and became the
world champion so such things occur uh
in history and we also had the case of
Fisher who walked away from Jess
entirely while being at the peak so
nothing entirely new but certainly
something we'll have to get used to
because indeed for the past 10 years
we've had the best player in the world
and uh the highest rated player in the
world all in one and the one with the
best haircut as well so it was just
Magnus all over and now we have to get
used to some other people running the
show
Bishop F7 has been played and we'll get
to the move uh in a moment I just wanted
to ask you do you remember the first
game that you played against Magnus is
that you know something that you'll put
in your Memoirs years down the line
certainly it was a very memorable game
for me because I actually won that game
and I haven't beaten Magnus Wow since
that until uh just January this year in
my kanzan I think it it was 12 years in
between these two
so first of all I'm really grateful that
you uh really grateful that you bring
back these memories uh so we can talk
about this topic for a long time and
it's a very important topic for in chess
history as well but yeah no I
can say both times it was a Celestial
tournament it was my first year in the
Master's group it was called group a at
the time and I was a player age 2670. I
think that is somewhere in the world
maybe top 70 or something like that and
I played the Magnus in round three
with the black pieces so nothing was uh
you know nothing was suspicious about
that he was world number one I was uh
playing Black so nobody expected me to
do a well there certainly not to win the
game but somehow things really went my
way I was extremely fortunate with
everything the opening went my way
um and then he blundered inexplicably uh
blunder the piece around wolf 20 and
resigned around move 23 or something so
it was an incredible day for me and I
won that game and a testament to
magnus's strength is that I haven't
beaten him
after that for years and years until I
managed to beat him this year in vacancy
again and that took a
12 years so certainly uh my relations
with Magnus goes way back and for the
most part it's been uh painful for me of
course as he is the best player in the
world he has a plus core against uh I
think everybody at this point and I had
a plus score for for a long time because
I after I've beaten him I managed to
make a lot of draws after that not
losing a game I was lucky in multiple of
those games I was losing in many but I
didn't lose any but of course finally
the fact that he is a better player uh
eventually you know it's it was you
cannot you know you cannot be lucky
forever and sooner or later I lost a
bunch of games to him and he's got this
big plus score against me as well and uh
yeah now uh of course there's no doubt
that he's proven to be the best player
in the world uh for so many years but uh
yeah for in this event he's not there
well your most recent game uh against
magnuson's how to steal is of course
what everybody uh remembers but
everybody will remember the 10-year
streak uh that is now over and it will
be replaced by either the nepomishi era
or the dingler and era will it be an era
or will it be uh you know a little
segment uh just like a year or two that
remains to be seen and the results of
the first game also remains to be seen
we've had a couple of moves played in
the meantime still very slow nothing
really changing but we have had
something concrete happen something
actually in the center a niche happens
so they've shifted finally away from the
King side again toward the center a rook
trade has been offered so presumably
ding is seriously evaluating the
prospect of taking on D1 and then
putting the other Rook on d8
yeah let's uh look at it at the analysis
board here after takes and Rook d8 now
indeed this is a decision first by Jan
to allow it and then we'll be by Dink
whether to go for it
I think so one thing is clear white
should not trade everything but the
Bishops because if you do that even if
you win the C7 Pawn it's well known the
opposite color Bishop's end game is a
draw
as long as you keep
some pieces on the board it could be
just Queens
or even just Rooks white will white will
be significantly better
and
whether the trade of Rooks is the
I don't know which side it necessarily
benefits it's so hard to say
um
I think probably both sides don't mind
it yeah my instinct mutually beneficial
yeah I mean it's just a natural follow I
mean there's no you know what's very
common is when you have an open file the
Rooks get traded there it's just like
it's like it's like you know a gun that
sits there in the in this in the play
and it will eventually shoot that's
that's kind of the thing like the file
is there troops will get traded and it
doesn't benefit anybody but it just it
just will happen
I had this
I don't know my instinct was to go for
the nitrate maybe first but I'm not sure
if that's the correct instinct
and also having trade one pair Jan could
not trade the second and it's often very
smart like one of the things we learned
uh there is this famous example of vasil
ivanchuk in the game and then also a few
examples by Alpha zero uh you're talking
about the game of Kasparov
uh evanchooks uh I think Evancho's
example I'm a cabin mind is against 11
aronian in a position with the isolated
against isolated Pawn at some point
there is one openc file and so it goes
like Rook text C1 Rook takes C1 Rook C8
like uh in this case trade a pair of
Rooks and then another 28 and then there
is one open file and suddenly Vasily
just moves The Rook to like be one like
behind a pawn where it's extremely
passive but he does so just to keep
these Rooks on board to reactivate it
later
and we had seen uh the same in many of
the uh games of alpha zero because
previously the old stockfish was
programmed by humans and humans input
open files are good
so the engine is like okay open file is
good I bring the Rook there but Alpha
zero has figured out because it's
self-learning that open files are not
always crucial and sometimes you can
give up the open file because nothing
will happen there and it's much more
important to keep more piece so there
are cases I'm not sure this is the one
but there are cases where it's
beneficial for for a site that's putting
the pressure you just walk out of the
trade and for in the meantime this Rook
is better than this one but in the
future as I regroup I will eventually
manage to activate my Rook
so this could could be a thing but most
likely here
um the Rooks will will just get traded
and then
yeah it's a
it's it's a question how the the play
will proceed I don't know what are your
thoughts
yeah no I mean you brought up some
amazing points but Alpha zero and
stockfish which uh uh you know there's a
great philosophical discussion to be had
We're not gonna have it uh right now uh
just about the sort of notion of spatial
advantages we think of an open file as
an inherently good thing but you could
almost say that an open file is uh an
illusion you know it's just space you
know it's it's a square cannot be good
inherently you can if if you fast
forward everything
um why would a square be good well it's
because you're attacking something when
you reach that square so you know you
always have to kind of deconstruct your
assumptions right you assume that an
open file is good you assume that
squares in the center are good but you
always have to tie down those General
considerations to the concrete you know
the specifics of the position
um but my thoughts on whether uh The
Rook trades are gonna happen I think the
answer is likely yes I just there's just
such a pull to take on D1 and play Rook
data it's just such an automatic thing
that you you do as you're saying if
black doesn't take on D1 the question
would be is there a move that keeps the
status quo and slightly improves the
position maybe B6 as you're pointing out
to prevent Queen A7 is that something to
consider so one uh thing indeed maybe
there is a queen A7 somewhere maybe and
the other thing I was thinking about it
happens also a lot in this kind of
showdowns or stand Downs whatever the
word is between the Rooks now when
especially when that happens when both
sides don't mind the trade you might
wait for a move so you could take with
black and play Route 8 but maybe if you
choose to make a useful way to move like
B6 maybe white will take and play Rook
D1 and then then you had gained to Tempe
it does is not worth much
because nothing's happening anyway but
it is nice so uh maybe ding is thinking
you know we will trade the Rooks but
let's do it on my terms or at least
let's wait so what's likely to happen is
that we will have waiting moves from
both sides let's say Let's Plays B6 why
those Place 92 like also plays King H7
both sides are waiting who doesn't want
to lose the tempo on the trade
and uh yeah that is certainly like the
scenario
yeah that's an intense situation
normally you could also make what's
called a collinear move now where two
Rooks or two Bishops are staring at each
other on a file or a diagonal it's a
move that's on that file but it's not a
capture so Rook D2 and Rook D3 I mean
Rook D4 it would be a collinearium not a
very good one uh but those types of
moves are very common in trying to rest
control of the open file here I think
it's highly ineffective to try to play
Rook D2 for example because black is
it's going to have the opposite effect
Black's gonna take and play Rook d8 and
you know you don't want to occupy open
file with a queen typically because it
can just get chased away with a rook
but you do bring a very important point
and uh it is not relevant right here
because of Rook D2 indeed this takes
through it but after 92 that I suggested
then it's actually very relevant then
you could play Rook the seven because
now after takes takes there is only one
because Knight is not on C3 so you bring
indeed a good point so when this square
is not protected this I didn't even know
that word you used what it was called a
collinear and I didn't know it either
until I read an article I read some
culinary yeah
okay
similar
yeah yeah no I mean I I'm well aware of
your uh of the breadth of your
vocabulary so I'm here to learn I'm here
to learn I am ready for it but yeah
indeed this idea is is a way to fight
for the open file there are multiple
cool uh gimmicks like there's also this
famous idea
of uh Anthony carpool where he had Rooks
on A1 and a a file and some other file
blackhead group on the a file and
somewhere he made this move the a-file
was open so these pawns were not here
and white played this moved Bishop to A7
in front of this Rook to then
comfortably double the Rooks and then
retract the bishop back
and get that file so there are all these
nice little gimmicks and tricks uh to do
with open files and meanwhile their ding
just made a waiting move and it's now up
to Young uh I don't know if A3 is
uh
I short term for sure because you want
to not see the queen appear here
um but like if you think very long term
how do you want to position these Pawns
hard to say because if you want to
position them on the dark squares
they will be never attacked by the
bishop but then the bishop has this B3
Square in the future that will control
the D file let's say so uh B3 on the
other hand
it kind of is like a granite for this S7
Bishop
um but at the same time it might later
get challenged by C4 so you these are
these abstract thoughts that you should
be having here because there's nothing
short term going on I mean A3 or B3
nothing like Queen before Queen H3 is
not not a big deal but just long term
you have to think like how do I want my
pawns what are the consequences just a
very slow abstract stuff basically
and Jan speaking of abstract stuff he is
you know deep in some sort of meditation
30 moves into the line that he's
calculating kind of leaning back in his
chair ding has not been at the board you
know virtually at all I mean he has made
a home at the rest area so the players
you know kind of revealing their habits
early on in the match it will be
interesting to see how their habits
change but right now big decision for
gun does he roll up his sleeves is this
the time to play 92 or does he keep
playing the waiting game at some point
he's the one who's gonna have to press
the button because ding is more than
happy to you know just screw around for
a little while and make some improving
moves he's kind of waiting for Yan to
press on the gas pedal and get on with
it you know start the tension yeah and
uh when we're talking about racing moves
I had an interesting
thought okay I don't think it's good
here
but somewhere the move Queen to G1 could
make sense to reconnect with the
with the Rooks I mean here it allows
Queen before but let's let's say in a
scenario like this 92 takes takes Rook
date here most likely move probably is
rooted two using that same idea
but also Queen Juan comes to mind and uh
in case of Rook D7
yeah then the small Queen G1 it sort of
might make sense
uh you could also consider taking and
then going nice trip back now you again
fight for the file
but essentially it's just a way to
just a way to get a trade of Rooks in a
favorable version uh pretty much
I don't know um
I want this guy do not support but it's
it's my instinct to trade off the only
piece that could potentially jump again
it's uh it doesn't mean it's a good move
it's just mind sync this to trade off
this Knight I had a game recently
against the go cash was very similar Ops
color Bishops and I traded his Knight as
well I gave a lecture after that saying
it's a great idea I'm not sure it was
but this is how I treat these positions
but maybe there are other ways
well it's it's clear that C7 is much
easier to attack in the absence of the
Knight so we can start with that basic
fact
um also you know just operating on in
the center maybe E4 E5 if you trade the
knights with a heavy pieces still on the
board you know maybe there will be some
attacking chances on the king and that's
the interesting thing about opposite
colored Bishops is the famous kind of uh
double-sided nature of them take the
Queens off take the heavy pieces off
very very drawish put the Queen's back
on you have a lot of famous games
there's a spar of karpov game where
opposite Lord Bishops favored the
attacker obviously because you have
access to a whole uncontested set of
squares so the Queen Bishop battery with
opposite card Bishops is tremendously
effective
exactly and even Rooks Rook Bishop
against Rook bishop and I uh I noticed a
lot of it in this Alpha Zero game uh in
the book by Matthew Sadler I believe uh
he he looked at these games and there's
a chapter there I think about the
opposite color Bishops and uh how many
times and how many games Rook Bishop
against Rook Bishop
he's actually not Jewish at all and how
many of them are were won by the side
that is pressing uh even when that site
is not an upper Pawn like here it just
has a better Pawn structure and might
have the game with Gucci that one I
mentioned and I also reached a position
with Rook Bishop against Rook bishop and
I thought I was better of course I
didn't manage to win but I never could
imagine I was winning at any point and
when I analyzed the game later with the
engine I I realized I missed the win and
to my surprise there were positions
there where material is equal we have
Rook Bishop against Rook Bishop open
Scholars and I have this uh deep
tendency to believe that it has to be
drawish because of this open scholar
Bishop thing because you cannot trade
drugs but sometimes you'll just never
trade Rogues
and so not only Queen Bishop but even
The Rook Bishop can often be really
really huge for the side that's pressing
so I would not at all be bothered with
white uh to trade to trade the knights
because of course if you keep the
knights on the drawing sentences uh is a
lot less but I think trading Knights is
a safe bet here
um
I I think trading nice would have gone
better uh in the combination with
keeping the Rooks on the board so a more
conceptual speaking I think my dream
scenario would have been to trade the
knights only get the bishop to F4 into
G3 as I told you a long time ago I don't
need the D file I think I don't need the
default I think I prefer Rooks just to
have them
um
I think
my maximum for white would be to just
trade the nines and keep the rules and
as the game is progressing I think they
will trade Rooks I think it only makes
it a little bit more Jewish but still
yeah even if you trade Rooks and the
Knights and get the queen to G3
hard to say even let's say we have to
imagine imagine I win the C7 Pawn
we keep screening the queen and the
bishop we got B5 having C7 Pawn you will
probably go F5 somewhere we probably
trade these two
am I going to win that position
so what are the constraints again you so
we we trade nine okay it was just very
nice
I also wanted to look at Knight D5 which
is a tactical attempt but but let's look
at this first yeah yeah because that's
uh that's an attempt that's an attempt
that sort of is uh oh and A3 has been
played in the meantime yeah yeah because
95 is an accidental thing let's say this
is sort of a more conceptual let's just
say uh okay I'll make some bad moves
just for argument's sake
um
I will just make all these bad moves I
lose the spawn
okay this position are you going to win
it with white
uh
I would call this like a 50 classic 50
50 position yeah maybe even less maybe
70 30 in favor of black yeah I I would
go with that I mean I played enough
games with Hikaru to tell you that this
is not a 50 50 situation I mean I
haven't with why I would be playing for
a drug in sicaro yeah I mean this is a
typical Hikaru position I don't know why
I had like a lot of games with the car
which are like that and he never loses
just never
I don't know why but position is just
very drawish and I think if we
um imagined Rooks here
E2 E1 let's say and black Rook somewhere
here
what that is a winning position for sure
completely yeah you can see five is
possible in attacks
so I think I don't know what the engine
is saying here whether the short term
consideration but I think long-term
considerations uh are such that I think
the trading Rooks probably does not
favor white because of this reasoning
but but by that reasoning black should
take on D1
yeah but I think that will eventually
anyway happen so they are not
Luke he moved the Rook
or not oh no he didn't move no no he's
still there so he played A3 just played
A3 yeah yeah no I I I think as yeah but
the question is of course maybe white
will not trade the second Rook
and then play rookie one or Yvonne chick
style Rook C1 yeah yeah but rookie
yeah because that scenario that we
discussed
one pair of Rooks is enough to make it
the winning position for white
right
two even better one is enough yeah you
keep you have a rook only one I have a
rook on uh E8
yeah I think I'll win this position with
the Rook somehow
because you don't have many more chances
oh yeah yeah but I mean I would estimate
the position
it's technical winning position so yeah
I think black wants to Black
conceptually wants to trade both Rooks
and um
but and then situations is very Jewish
plus something like a6a5 would be
consistent with what ding has been doing
thus far on the king side which is to
basically keep the ball in yon's chord
and say listen if you make these you
know tiny improving moves I'm gonna do
the same uh but the fact that he's
thinking I think if he wanted to play A5
uh if he was set on it he would play it
immediately so he's clearly thinking
about The Rook trade my guess would be
he's either going Rook takes D1 or A5 I
don't know why I'm so set on A5 I don't
think white one's B4 maybe it's a bad
movement it's weakening you know I don't
like A5 because in that position we
discussed remember when I took the
opponents oh it's on a dark Square yeah
you went you could call B5 there and now
you would have to also get A4 in somehow
so I'm like hesitant I'm not sure A5 is
an is an automatic I'm not sure it's
automatic I think you you don't it's far
from given so I agree that you might do
a waiting move but maybe that move is
a move like King age
seven maybe h8 because King H7 there is
some ghost of a check somewhere maybe on
h8 just just to wait or even Rook fe8
you could wait
um not a useful move but just a waiting
move
and maybe just take revenge Knight to
five
yeah so is this Knight D5 thing 95 thing
let's talk about 95 I think is that here
is another thing yeah
yeah here here The Rook is undefended
yeah so I can the worst case can smooth
the queen and it's over here
I was thinking instead of A3 to be
honest and I actually couldn't off the
top of my head figure out how to
equalize after CD Ed
GES required just give back the thing by
the way
but if there is here I can play King h
eight I think
then I take E6 yeah and then I think I
can just oh no system is thinking wait
but there is some move here I think
there's some move here
um yeah yeah there must be some way to
equal by the way ding has played A5 in
the meantime but in a moment maybe Rogue
D6 maybe Rook D6 I don't know okay sorry
let's let's say I'm jumping too much
let's just discuss that because it was
that was actually interesting
Rook D6 Bishop this is Queen D6 that's
brilliant
but King can move eh1 yeah
H1 yeah
but here okay come on this has to be
some place to be clean
Bishop E6
is enough what about
this
Rook which one what about Queen C5 d uh
D6 and 23 doesn't work
doesn't work for white yeah
because I take with the King on F7 yeah
this gets ridiculous why is black not
why is black not winning here because I
have rookies because the Rook takes d8
Queen oh my gosh
but it's not good complicated for okay I
guess Efron D7 is a draw and rook and
rookie seven
yes
just gets tactical over yeah why are we
here instantly
why are we talking about let's go back
to the game because yeah but it's
interesting
forever remain behind the scenes yeah
but actually relevant by the way it
could have happened 95 was relevant
there should be some clean thing let me
think here
I'm just so curious
you suggested moving the king but that
doesn't seem to because this is the
seven Pawn ultimately is a big weakness
yeah yeah and that's not terrible but I
will lose a pawn so I'll have to suffer
there
so the threat is d e Rook D1 EF
check right
yeah solving the problem of that being
check is still not enough because you
know
I'm worried about some move like Queen
C3
because D Bishop is okay I mean it's the
thing is it's anyway very little even if
you win the c-pawn like just for
argument's sake even if I play King h8
which is bad even if I do this
mm-hmm
it's it's little
I mean even though it's Rooks are on the
board Yeah but I
this kind of Pawn structure is somehow
not dangerous for black and
yeah well the king side is super safe
the queen side you just have a one past
phone this this is not the dangerous one
the dangerous one is if white has the
pawn on e4
right no because you're the Rockets to
C2 and black gets really active yeah
this is just nothing so the 95 was
nothing uh anyway and he just played the
slow waiting move and he did play A5 you
play A5 yeah okay I mean the I you could
see like I'm I'm thinking much more sort
of I'm thinking kind of very long term
yeah
the players are a bit more concrete
maybe but some somehow long term I am
both skeptical about the Rook trade and
about this movie A5 maybe I'm reading
too much into the position
um and you know maybe while I'm thinking
about some long-term things short term
there was something concrete will happen
somewhere uh we'll see we'll see I I
mean once you pointed out that the pawn
on A5 imagine a white Bishop on C7 black
might lose a second Pawn I started to
understand the drawbacks of A5 and not
to keep coming back to this Knight D5
idea but all of the lines we just looked
at with Knight T5 that end game that we
ended with maybe is a little bit more
promising for white probably still a
draw but I agree with that pawn on A5
you know it's a little bit more exciting
even a rook trade could potentially be
possible because with two extra pawns on
the queen side even an opposite card
Bishop end game without the Rooks pure
ocbn game might be winning
yeah exactly at the same time I just
realized when you were talking about
that okay the one on A6 it's kind of in
the air so if I ever attacked it with
Queen E2 or something it would probably
have to go to A5
or maybe you could go B5 yeah I don't I
don't know it moved B6 also is not
actually ideal in that sense but B6 I
guess was played to prevent Queen A7
yeah
yeah but he did put two pawns on dark
squares yeah this theme of by the way
these pawns being potentially weak it
plays itself in a Berlin end game
sometimes you have the spawn A7 and you
get this brilliant game structure white
has a point on E5 and black has a
problem F7 and then white plays A4 black
responds naturally with A5
and then white goes E6
gives up the spawn and takes C7 and
collects Pawn here on the queen side
so this A5 being a weakness is actually
an existing theme so
it could really be a weakness yeah we
will we'll see about about this uh
eventually it's one of these moves that
yeah you you make and then okay 92 92
yeah yeah finally so never it gets down
to business 92 is on the board aiming
for the nitrate and choosing this
opportunity to do so clearly trying to
punish ding for A5 right he waited for
that move now he's trying to get as
you're showing the ideal Construction
after Knight F4 Knight F4 Queen F4 I
think the point I just made Anish about
the Queen's coming off the board it
would be an unquestionable draw with a
pawn and A6 now
who knows maybe it's still a draw we
could there's positions down three pawns
where you have a blockade uh unlimited
number of points but here absolutely
impossible to evaluate certain with
certainty I would yeah I mean
yeah because oh the king side pawns are
also on dark squares yeah yeah this this
I'm not be shocked if this is not lost
but uh speaking more Concrete in this
position black can play Move Like A4 and
this is no longer an issue so this A6
Pawn could sort of jump through A5 to A4
and then again it's all fine
this is again right
so could work out all right
I think ding will uh trade Rooks yeah I
mean what else why not let's trade Rooks
now it's as good of a time as any I
think after 92 white obviously
threatening Knight F4 going after the C7
Pawn but trading Rooks is a committal
decision so that probably means a little
bit more time spent for ding who has
burned through over half of his clock
and they still have uh 18 more moves to
make so we will leave ding uh to this
very important moment we might see a
mass trade nepo is pushing for the win
this is basically a tour result game
uh and we will take this opportunity to
go on another short break folks you're
watching the world championship 2023
it's nepo it's ding it's super hype this
is game one and a lot of the action is
still ahead we will be back with more
action from nepoding in just a couple of
moments
hi everybody International Master Danny
wrench here chess.com's Chief chess
officer we are here and excited to be
collaborating and partnering with World
Quant as an official partner of the
champions tour in the year 2023 I'm now
speaking with Chief strategy officer for
World Quant natish mining the people
have met us and now time for the big
questions jumping right into the basics
tell everybody a little more about world
quad and what exactly is it that world
quad does thank you for having me Danny
and you already introduced me I'm the
chief strategy officer at World Quant
World Quant is a global asset management
organization it was founded by Igor
tulsinski in 2007. World quad today has
over 850 employees who are working
towards designing investment strategies
in multiple asset class across Global
markets World Quant believes in
empowering the ideas of the talent
across the globe and we have 23 offices
in 13 countries today amazing amazing
stuff so tell us now a little bit more
about this project called World Quant
brain so worldcoin is built on the
belief that Talent is global but
opportunity is not and we strive to take
this opportunity to everyone around the
globe world Quant brain has been
designed as a tool which empowers us to
take that opportunity to anyone that's
fantastic seriously that's amazing I I
had no idea about that learning about
this along with our viewers and
obviously as a as a website and a
company with a mission to also connect
Global communities and increase the
opportunity for chess that makes it even
more of a natural partnership tell me a
little bit more from World quads
perspective why you guys run the ITC so
World Quant has this mission of
democratizing quantitative finance and
international Quant Championship is one
of the tools we have to spread the
message about this operator opportunity
which World point is offering to
everyone to be a Quant in the world of
in the quantitative space and
international Quant Championship
empowers the individuals to utilize
their ideas and show that they can do it
and gives us an opportunity to take this
message to them wherever they are that's
great now you said the finals will be in
person was I right that it'll be in the
Bahamas that sounds like a pretty great
location can I come yeah absolutely
absolutely and I can okay so I don't
know that I'm qualified to be in the iqc
but uh tell everybody a little more so
the finals are going to be in the
Bahamas what will that be like for those
who make it yes so the finals as you
said is planned to be in Bahamas for the
iqc so worldcoin celebrated its 15th
anniversary last year in 2022 to
celebrate that occasion we are getting
the whole world Quant organization
together in Bahamas this year and we
decided that we will organize the finals
of iqc at that event so this will give
an opportunity to our finalists to meet
the world quantity in person it will
give them an opportunity to watch the
culture and rigor of the organization
and we are very excited that everybody
will be able to get together at that
event in Bahamas well this has been
awesome nitish thank you so much this is
where I remind everybody it's their
chance to get involved in the iqc the
international quad Championship you can
use the command iqc you can visit the
world Quant brain website we encourage
you to do so ASAP registration is open
until May so it's time to jump in and
maybe you'll get to meet the CSO and
others in the Bahamas maybe I'll be
there I don't if I'm lucky I don't know
but it sounds like a great time either
way and the Tish uh the Chess World and
the Champions chess tour thanks World
Quant for their partnership and we're
looking forward to the rest of the year
together thank you Denny and good luck
to the community for participating in
iqc
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 fide World
Championship World Quant is an official
partner of the chess.com broadcast of
the feed a world championship that you
are currently watching they are a global
firm that builds complex mathematical
models to identify market inefficiencies
now world's Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the chess Community to
hunt down the next generation of Quant
Finance Specialists because nobody knows
how to analyze a position better than a
chess player right if you think you have
what it takes register for the
international quad Championship head to
go.chess.com
iqc or use x Glam iqc in chat thank you
to World Quant for being an official
partner of this broadcast we are
Grandmaster Anish giri and Grandmaster
Daniel naritzki bringing you coverage of
game one of the world championship
between nepo and ding the game has
slowed down considerably and you that
has given us the space to talk about a
lot of different things to really look
at the position uh for many many
different perspectives
but I feel like things are finally
beginning to head in a somewhat shall we
say more concrete Direction
yeah possibly possibly because um now as
the trade of nice is uh on the menu at
some point things get get concrete and
uh you want to not lose the C7 Pawn
under bad circumstances black
and I was thinking actually
um a little bit about what I said before
because I was sort of making a point of
not trading Rooks
but then I and I was thinking okay why
did Jan not do it and I realized that
it was not so simple so just perhaps
it's interesting because it is a big
decision so maybe we could sort of
discuss what would happen if that
wouldn't be the case so let's say I go
HD first
B6 and now 92.
now black has the opportunity here to
double on the D file which uh does
two things first of all is just nice
because then Rook maybe one day can
penetrate but the other thing is that
after Knight F4
if we do get this kind of position I was
talking about which is nice and I'm not
I'm not going to lose the C7 Pawn any
longer simply
so I'm just never losing mentally
defended yeah exactly so that that was
like a dream scenario I was talking
about it I would not trade Rooks anyway
in the pawn but it just doesn't happen
so that was one thing the other thing I
realized that is that with the Rook
controlling the D file black has this
idea of Knight D4
which uh
you wouldn't have if the Rooks are gone
so
while uh it was sort of idealistic uh to
to try not trade Rooks I do understand
why Young
was open for that
and uh
yeah to be honest I do like his position
but I do think now the draw is sort of a
more likely outcome because
if we speak about concrete lines
let's say I don't know what is your
thoughts here Knight D4 or Rook date
what is the idea
I think it's sort of kind of
stock execution of the idea is to play
Rook takes d8 uh Queen takes the eight
Knight F4 but there actually might be
something like Queen D4 and White's
initiative ends before it even begins I
think I mean you're not even getting to
the C7 Pawn
yeah if you indeed if we look at it from
concrete sense that was the case and
also just taking honestly I your idea A4
yeah yeah probably you should take with
the bishop here in fact and then do this
and probably I will lose that pawn so
let's say A4 enough two let's say queen
D7
by taking inches down and we've got this
situation that I was talking about the
pawn A6 even better on A4 actually yeah
this spawn chain now only has one
weakness the C6 Pawn I think this is uh
nice for white I will play this forever
but I think Joe is more likely here so
ding indeed um does take on D1
here they go and Rook to d8 is the
immediate follow-up offering a trade of
the second pair of Rooks and my guess is
that Jan he's gonna invest a little bit
of time thinking about you know Yvonne
chick's name really stuck in my head uh
as an example of moving a rook away from
an open file I remember my uh former
coach Gregory kaidanov at a U.S chess
School actor he he told an entire
lecture on moves that involved forcibly
moving a rug voluntarily away from an
open file very hard thing to do
psychologically but could allow for more
winning chances there's that collinear
move though that we had mentioned
earlier it seems to make more sense here
Rook D3 on the board yeah very
interesting I I noticed it as well I was
actually thinking about it uh I am
wondering after three is the point to
just grab the file which is like very
little very little relevance here but is
that the point or does he want to change
the pawn structure I see yeah spicy as
things get in this position C5 to clamp
down on the DeForest is why this was bad
earlier but now there's a knight on E2
which maybe makes this more palatable
for white maybe F4 yeah
I'm not impressed with with uh this for
for white F4 maybe because you got a
five yeah I just need to somehow defend
this
on because you're threatening F5 and
couldn't F4 I need to reroute my knight
to some Square
maybe it's that's like 65 something like
this like positionally positionally
Bishop H5 made sense but actually oh
even though the Knight gets to D4 I feel
like white might be able to attack C7
yeah it's a beautiful move I think
that's good I didn't see it F5 yeah
but and then no it's fine for Black
Knight I think more or less
you mean you mean here and then back to
but at some point I can also push the
pawns a little bit c65 Yeah Yeah whoops
here
also I've got nine to maybe A4
we know yeah it was such a knight you
shouldn't be losing the seven kind of
492 idea
um yeah I just I it just it looks like
black solution has improved tremendously
I don't think that's going to happen I'm
thinking maybe he just wants to
recapture with her with a queen actually
maybe that's that thought
and kind of make it hard for black to to
make a move obviously Queen d8 is
impossible because you lose all of your
queen side Pawns
yeah that Queen infiltration of the
queen side right the queen used to be on
E3 threatening to go to A7 black played
B6 now it's on D3 maybe black plays B5 I
don't think so I'm just you know drawing
a parallel yeah yeah no it's it's
possible I mean A6 is a is not near as
annoying as Queen S7 because quinnesson
was targeting the pawn now the pawns are
protected but there is this idea of
going Queen A8 and then maybe Queen C8
and then maybe trading the knights like
that or after c39 D4 and then getting to
the C7 Pawn under more favorable
circumstances with the queen on C8
instead of G3 so this is all possible I
think
um
Jan has sort of taken a very
stable route to a very small advantage
and it's understandable it's first game
he doesn't want to do anything crazy he
won't he just wants this very small Edge
that he got I think he's happy with the
Rook trade as well and he will try to
milk it a little bit yeah I I do like
that
we haven't talked about you know the
time situation all game we remind you
that the time control the world
championship is very expansive you've
got two hours for 40 40 moves then
another hour is out of two o'clock uh
then another 30 minutes after uh move 60
but 34 minutes right now uh it's only
moved 24. black hasn't made his 24th
move yet do you think the time situation
is going to play role or is the position
too simplified uh for that to happen
I think it's uh it might play a role
because we have we have no increment
right and no increment that is always
very stressful as you as you know better
than anybody playing so much no no
increment chess online
you can just lose on time so that always
brings that extra element something to
worry about and you know he doesn't have
again he doesn't have much questions to
answer right now but by the time we
approach move 30 35 and by the time his
clock approaches 10 minutes maybe that's
when he will have to perhaps
take a certain decision with black he
will be asked a question C7 Pawn will
get attacked and yeah time situation
could play could play some role here but
as things go I um I was very
enthusiastic at first because white got
an advantage but now that I've sort of
calmed down a little bit and I look at
uh you know how big is the damage that
black has uh the black has endured I
think I have
uh I've liked White's position probably
a little too much and now I would fine
tune my evaluation to just better for
white but I think black is very solid
and that Prospect of uh losing the C7
Pawn uh yet keeping up his color Bishops
and the Queens on the board I think that
is just still quite solid and I think
yeah with accurate play ding should
eventually make it but uh time is one of
the factors potentially
uh quick correction I misspoke uh I said
30 minutes it's 15 minutes added after
move 60 and the increment only starts on
move 60. so from move 60 onwards there
is a um an increment and that is done in
order to avoid flat out crazy flagging
uh the 30 second increment is
implemented past move 60 but lagging
very possible you can't do what you do
with an increment which is you can leave
yourself you know with 30 seconds to
make the last five or six moves if you
believe the position is simple enough
very commonly happens here can't do that
and will we see any crazy flagging fests
uh in any of these games I mean I won't
complain but you already know that
yeah I mean I I don't think that that's
what's going to happen in this game but
uh it is likely to happen eventually and
uh one other thing I wanted to mention
uh just sort of why we are here and why
the game got kind of unbalanced why
young got an advantage and I think
compared to his match against Magnus his
approach is just very different
I think he's just much more confident
um
because they're deep inside he and his
team they knew that if they get a
playable position that is roughly
balanced
yeah the odds are not in his favor
because Magnus is a better player
but here
he was much more comfortable going for a
position that is little explored and
full of life
I think he allows himself more risk in
the opening in this tournament because
in this match because this is just game
one and already he allowed all these
options you know went for this position
that is far from being forced and uh I
think that that is a good sign for us uh
looking ahead in the match in general I
think we're going to see Yan taking more
risks than I guess Magnus and I think
that is correct both what he did there
and what he did here
um and another thing that just it's just
a one extra reason to look forward to
the rest of the matchup I think we'll
see a lot of very interesting games as
Giannis
Sian is ready to go for more open fights
uh after the opening and doesn't feel
the need to be so as constrained as he
was against Magnus
we talked a little bit at the start of
the show about uh ding's uh choice to
bring her report uh with him as a second
a very who would have guessed right but
we haven't talked as much about nepo's
team nepo's team uh is known to be vast
it's expansive uh he's worked with
Grandmaster Vladimir putkin uh he's
worked with a lot of different
Grandmasters in various capacities and
he's been open about it some of them
more moral support like gildar hyrulin
his close friend uh others more you know
serviceable they they do the work they
do the opening work and they analyze
with him I've also heard uh
was one of the strongest Russian GM's
recently joined nepo's team uh what do
you think about nepo's choice to have as
expansive of a team of seconds as he
does does that impact uh directly his
decisions in the early going of this
match
well yeah it's definitely a well it's a
positive sign that you can afford to
have a big team with a a lot of
knowledgeable players you mentioned
indeed uh so let's name them name the
names of the people that we sort of know
that have uh have been spotted as part
of his team throughout the year so there
was of course potskin his head coach
match against magnos musicoff is here as
well I really mentioned I saw him at the
tournament with Jan
um there was you gave it to machovsky
and some picture a strong Russian
Grandmaster I saw Maxima matlakov it's a
tournament as well with Yan and uh the
Peter liko has been involved in the team
as well so that is already a lot of
names I guess not all of them are with
him now but certainly some of them
remain some are new as he said himself
in the press conference said okay things
change so definitely some some changes
to his team but um yeah it's of course
if you have one training camp
and you've got this many people uh it
might be a challenge to manage all of
that
um also the social aspect of it becomes
like very loose it might start to
resembling a party more than a working
environment yeah you know what I mean
especially if everybody's friendly with
each other
so so that is there but I think if you
manage that well uh quality can quantity
can turn into quality and I think having
more people just means more hands on
deck more input a different input and I
think Giannis uh yeah definitely done a
great job so far as assembling
um such a big team and having worked
with so many different players and they
all bring something different to his
game you know he worked maybe half a
year
um with Matlock of I don't know if he
did but let's say you only were half
years still he's got Matlock of Vision
on the different openings and he has BT
ghost Vision on different openings he's
got so much vision and all these people
they have different inputs maybe
somebody told them there's something
interesting in the Italians but there's
some interesting in Spanish somebody
told them all you know there's an idea
in the Catalan so all these different
people bringing something new to the to
him and and I think his his team is one
of his main strengths
um and with Dean we don't know as much
we only know a report
which was as I mentioned it's really
very surprising uh like not nothing like
it's great but nothing wrong with just
surprising as I didn't know where that
came from but uh the thing we don't know
um I there might be also many people who
know
yeah I mean I think uh it'll be
demystified as as time goes on
particularly if he wins it's a kind of
traditional uh to reveal at least part
of your team in the meantime C5 has been
played a move that we considered after
Rook takes D3 ding decided to play it
immediately and nepo responds with
queenie2 which I think confirms Anish
your theory about which piece he was
planning to capture with now obviously
after Rook takes D3 it doesn't make any
sense to recapture with the pawn then
why did you tuck your queen away behind
the pawns he's gonna take back with the
queen what do you make of this early C5
by ding is this possibly overly
committal are there any I mean it
weakens the D5 square and whitesnite can
decide to change its mind I mean maybe
Knight E2 to C3 is conceivable
especially if black plays A4 so I think
A4 is inadvisable because the Knight
hasn't committed to F4 just yet
yeah uh I mean again another Pawn on the
dark Square we could start seeing
disadvantages of that
um but I think we should
you know not not exaggerate these
long-term factors and okay short term
white is yet to trade the Knight and
white is yet to attack the C7 Pawn
anyone comes to D5 Square I mean if you
go by sc3 you allow me to plant an item
D4
so all that is quite abstract and um
and if ever White NOW attacks the C7
Pawn so in a hypothetical scenario let's
just make the moves just to illustrate
the point I want to make if this kind of
thing happens
okay let's just for argument's sake I'll
just make all the moves that I want to
show if this thing happens I actually
have a opportunity to save the pawn for
now with C6
I mean I might lose one later anyway but
I could let's say okay just to
illustrate even better I could play A4
here and here goes C6 and uh
if I had my queen already on E8 I would
be able to save all of my pawns you know
it's the point I'm trying to make so uh
nothing wrong with putting a Pawn on C5
if anything it could even save you that
c Pawn not that it changes much anyway
it's doubled useless Pawn but okay it's
uh it just shows that C5 is a it's a
very solid move I think it's all right
yeah and I think that the point of Rook
B3 was yeah never to take with a c Pawn
the point was just to get this sort of
defile and Force black to to take
because if you wait now I will take you
can no longer take with the queen
so I do get access to to some squares
let's say
and if you have to take with a knight
that's a huge concession then whitesnite
you know the world opens up to why it's
night night at fortnite C3 both moves
are now possible and again nothing
happens too fast in a position like this
but this is how things start to go wrong
for black right and I get to D5 it's
clear that white has made progress
compared to the position three or four
moves ago I think that's how you judge
the trend of the game when you talk
about tiny advantages it's not okay
White's still probably not much better
but White's better than he was you know
two or three moves ago yeah I have I
have a lot of experience playing games
where my position keeps improving and
then intends in the draw anyway but uh
yeah yeah yeah
I totally get what you're saying yeah
yeah but getting better better yeah yeah
no I have that a lot like my position it
keeps improving and everything is great
and at some point I realize okay so now
it's we reach the its peak now let's
Converse and then I see okay well
there's nothing more to improve and I've
reached them you know I've reached my
Peak that's it's my position picked so
that that is a danger here for Wyatt but
I shouldn't short term yeah I don't I
don't think Knight takes d8 is what you
want I think you want to take on D3 here
actually and so what now
nothing exciting I mean
I don't know some moves some random move
I mean I have to react as black I don't
need to do much I can okay what is my
waiting move let's say it's King h8 what
is what is your move
yeah so here I was flirting briefly with
the idea of E5 but it doesn't feel that
dangerous maybe just to generate some
attacking chances because because black
doesn't have F5 right earlier black
could play F5 and keep the blockade here
he doesn't have it maybe
yeah I like that I didn't see this
actually and uh just because I was used
to the idea of F5 and now it's no longer
is possible and this could be a yeah
this is a welcome change for white
because you you get access to the spawn
it's a very long way to go I mean you
still never beat Hikaru from this
position from my experience but
absolutely but so it's it's nice it's
nice
I could prevent that by the way if I if
I wanted let me think how so King it's
counter-intuitive oh I see what you want
I didn't like that square but
surprisingly after if I've checked now I
have Bishop G6
mm-hmm
or even no I think I stick to that
and EF Queen takes FC yeah yeah but but
at least I I activated my Bishop so I
just slightly better version of that I
could also prevent it entirely if you
want let's let's go black Bishop G6 then
I prevent D5 entirely
okay 25 yeah I didn't like that you get
some Queens somewhere I mean maybe it's
okay Queen C6 maybe I'm okay there's not
red but
it feels like the trend of the game is
just a tiny bit starting to favor white
here 24 minutes by the way on on ding's
clock and you know with every minute
we're starting to get into more
concerning territory he's got a lot of
decisions to make
first of all on this move does he take
on D3 or not and then suddenly we're
having a hard time finding a move that
checks all the boxes exactly now imagine
that we land here somewhere and 93 is
coming
exactly this is becoming problematic for
ding yeah and now suddenly there is a
question because I see 95 is a question
there is no answer and there are only 10
minutes and there are 12 moves suddenly
it all comes and that's how you lose
games when somehow the question is asked
at the wrong time it's exactly how you
lose this kind of games
because I've lost some of those like not
not many I've won some not many but when
you win or lose that's how it happens
somehow you get lucky that the question
is us at the right time there is little
time on the opponent's clock and it all
comes together you get nervous because
you see the clock you see the position
and that's when you can um yeah you can
struggle but we are not there yet uh
maybe ding will find a way to make a
more favorable
get them a favorable version I think
maybe E5 is not a big deal maybe maybe
we should have allowed E5 rather than
allow the queen to be seven maybe
what is he thinking about because that's
exactly what I was going to bring up
because all of what we were considering
is after Rook takes D3
we have established that white has a
positional threat of Rook takes d8 which
would force black to compromise the
position of his Knight
is there a way to circumvent that I mean
C6 looks I'm not sure about uh
about that actually so is that really
such a big deal because I'm thinking
maybe I want to reroute the Knight to
c6e5 what do you play here um
so let's say first of all the bishop
versus knight
end game has to be about so let's say I
go Knight F4 and I I try to force you
into that 95.
out Knight D5 I don't have to I kind of
have to because if I play Queen to seven
there is this there's not absolutely
yeah yeah so if I'm looking at you take
with the temple so yeah I have to I have
to take you take me then I thought maybe
Queen D5 and I try to go for F4 E5 try
to get the passer yeah this changes the
position a little bit okay I'll start
with Knight D4
and then this is one of the ways one of
the ways from Hikaru draws these games
by the way
one of the menu is the C3 and he wins he
gets his Knight to E2 and his queen of
G1 and then it's basis yes so let's say
C3
yeah C3
um
I'm thinking um if I switch to passive
defense okay you'll definitely massage
me here no I'm I'm not sure I'm not
thrilled by the way I'm not thrilled
with this I I never thought I'm uh
equalizing here and I don't like the
look of it and in fact this drawing
tendency is kind of gone because of the
opposite color Bishops being gone not a
fan not a fan yeah uh-oh C5 so ding's
24th move
um rather than taking on D3 He
procrastinated one move why why does C5
make things so much is it because of the
D5 Square why do I feel like with the
pawn on C6 everything was fine and now
suddenly
all of the lines are problematic what
what is the nature of the difference by
the way just to because I was trying to
go back indeed as you mentioned C5 and I
realized that the reason he played A5 is
actually that after takes takes through
date Jan of course wanted to go to D3
and now uh in case of the same thing
happening
bonus hanging although I realized now I
can play that C5 and back maybe that
would be the maybe that is kind of the
most solid way to defend
yeah he tried to eliminate all of the
problems but you look when you're
defending you close some doors others
open yeah it's always very hard we need
to I'm pleasing before B5 is also
committal maybe after all you go A5
anyway yeah okay not sure not sure all
this these are such this is the thing
about these positions it's all so little
but C5 yeah it's one thing is a plus
another thing is a minus you regret each
of your smallest decisions and it's
tough it's tough that's why it's it's uh
that's why suffering is no fun
and okay this is the position on the
board
and uh yeah some questions
um to be answered just one thing I
wanted to point out by the way
uh just how terrible is this
that has to be decided under 20 minutes
by the way now for for Ding and it's I
think it's the reason it's terrible is
because my pawns are on the dark uh
color here and I cannot get them to the
light squares so so easily because if I
did I think I would be happy to just
give you this I mean with black at some
point just okay to
you know to not not have these dangers
between the sequences 695 like all the
stuff just to give you this and say okay
let's compromise you get your Pawn I get
my uh obviously Bishop drawing chances
and let's just play this out I get my
defensive Clarity but exactly no B5 but
Queen A7 it's like yeah it's all
sacrifices like you can only take one
piece at one time here you can only push
one Pawn at a time and you can't push
them all to the right squares fast
enough exactly so it does doesn't
achieve the desired goal it just gives
the pump but it doesn't give me that
Clarity it's 94 is not not the move yet
but it's an idea
mind so I think allowing E5 might be the
the way Queenie I like this I don't know
just you know nice move maybe so ding
has finally made a move he he it took me
a second to realize Anish what happened
he was not at the board again he was
thinking from his rest area and C6 which
I dismissed because in my mind it
weakened the D6 Square
yeah I'm not sure it's bad probably and
we know why we know why he got there he
had these issues with the D5 square but
it's just a move that is a little bit
ugly so you just sometimes not not see
it uh not see it happen it
so Bishop D6 is possible but yeah but
then the Rook is a bit uh lacking
squares right so after maybe becomes
annoying yeah yeah after I move the
Queen the C4 these pieces are all
cramped here and somehow The Rook will
lacks a little bit of space you could go
Queen D1 though you could do something
like this
and uh before you have Rook do two it's
possible by the way not not stupid at
all
really nice
56 is not stupid at all extra
maybe I have Knight D4 there
but I don't know so let's say
Queen two I don't know E8 or B7 E8 may
be a bit more normal yeah
so what's a queen e81
for instance
yeah Knight D4
yes
probably yes suddenly everything's
collapsing like ding has tried to put
his pawns on the best squares he's put
his pawns on the worst squares
but it was not easy for him I mean like
what do you want it to do no no no I I
would it was not easy yeah long time ago
when a seven was coming then after B6
the A5 A6 spawn was hanging with Queen
being on D3 so it was not obvious and
then after this
now he's worried that after Knight F4 he
will lose these pawns you know and this
will fall he doesn't want to go A4
because it's soft as well so then he
went C5 to be able to go C6 then he won
C6 and now he has uh he has a hole on
D600 so it was all It All Happened
naturally and I think it's just a
consequence of having a unpleasant
position that yeah it eventually gets
unpleasant I'm not even sure we needed
uh to go Bishop D6
if you take by the way Queen D it's
still not possible we don't lose the
pawn directly but we lose it after 67.
yeah that's
the problem and and to Bar your
terminology now is the time to ask
questions because just to quickly
clarify for those just joining ding has
18 minutes to make 14 moves that's less
than a little bit smidge over one minute
per move which is nothing at this level
please continue
yeah nepo takes the Rook okay he
queen of four very attempting queen of
four can be eight by the way
um I like the screen informal
very nice he's going to play yeah
infiltration with the queen that's
Young's favorite uh topic
he loves this queen infiltrations and
trying to be annoying from behind you
know because his his kind of style
yeah I'm just liking this at all
I love what you said about the uh
questions being asked at the right time
and ding does not have the time to
answer them 18 minutes Queen B8 is
threatened you could end up losing two
or even three pawns on the queen side
and the blink of an eye does black have
a move here or are we now talking are we
in the territory of having to give up
material
um I I think not just yet I think uh
also we should not over dramatize the
situation 18 minutes that's still
something and the question is not yet
not yet like unanswerable but we are
getting there let's say I think between
the seven
oh yeah I'm collapsing here what about
that completely wow okay so wait
queenstone is a thread actually
wow that has actually been a threat
stronger than Queen B8 yeah I didn't
realize the idea was not conveyed by
Queen C7 okay so maybe it's a B5 only
move yeah
give up on
but white does not wanna I think white
does not want to take A5 and allow
Knight D4
yeah I think we both won we both assumed
that Knight B7 is not going to happen
yeah because that's awful oh I missed it
but yes I'm assuming it didn't happen
yeah I don't know like you're you miss
it or you're just such a high I mean you
don't even see such horrible moves okay
right it doesn't even occur to me to put
the night on this you know you'd get
kicked out of a Soviet Schoolboy camp
for putting a knight on such a square
yeah yeah no that's the famous like
yantiman also whenever he would miss a
move and it would not because he would
just say that yeah it's just my
subconscious just sees that this is
wrong rejects moves of this of this love
no I guess not not the end of the world
because I'll go C4 and the night will
would eventually come out
it's a very ugly endgame but that said
it's an end game it remains somewhat
Jewish
what are other okay B5 I think is the
only move here simply the only move not
to lose material on the spot
and it's a young thing to do to go Queen
ba quickly to just keep as much tension
on the board as possible yeah that was
an actual intexual threat and okay I
have
Bishop D6 next Bishop 7 is the bigger
thread so I guess you have to move the
king now I can infiltrate here am I just
am I not just winning a pawn
I believe you are keeping up
or some counter play but like this but
yes
or queen D2 maybe is more of what you
meant yeah
that's yeah Queen D2 but I don't believe
in it because the dark squares are under
White's control maybe 94 but then 96.
yeah but that's another way how hikara
holds these kind of positions so we're
we're back to you know the
there are resources there if you're
resourceful you have time there are
resources in these kind of positions
such as this one but it is uh very dicey
because okay you lost the pawn without
trading having traded the knights so
it is not as drawish as it was well
luckily you have the screen to two thing
and you probably forced trade of the
knights but
maybe white could improve on this line
and we could delay Bishop D6
yeah
and imperceptibly I mean as we're
talking bang another three minutes off
the clock
now you basically have one minute per
move
and uh ding is gonna have to take some
more time because at this point we're in
the territory of high value of a mistake
if you make one mistake you're dead on
the spot that was not the case for ding
just a little while ago and so folks we
will likely get a Time scramble at least
a one-sided time scramble as we head to
move 30. so we're going to take this
opportunity to take one more very quick
break folks we promise we will be back
very soon uh with ding's attempt to save
a position that has been getting worse
and worse will we see a decisive game in
round one of the feed 8 World
Championship that remains to be seen and
we will continue to bring the action for
you in just a couple of short minutes
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kit is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking chess kid features a
comprehensive training program that
guides kids to level up on their way to
Mastery there are more than fifty
thousand chest bustles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world championship game one between Ding
and nepo is heating up in a very very
big way it's a Deja Vu moment for
dingler and because at the candidates
tournament round one there was a similar
game Arc where his position got worse
and worse and nepo ended up grinding him
down will we see this happen again
Master nishkiri we called it Queen to B8
has been played almost instantly by nepo
He Is accelerating the pace of his play
he is going to win a Pawn on the queen
side I feel like that's not up for
debate the question is how many is he
going to win which one is he going to
win and will ding be able to produce any
kind of counter play with this queen at
night
yeah it's a good point and actually I'm
getting quite excited here because uh
the bishop did six line we looked at
um seem to give like enough counter play
after Queen D7 and queen to D2 followed
by 96 this I felt is
kind of reasonable for black but this
move Bishop's seven that we didn't cover
yet that looks a lot more promising now
it's 96 Bishop A5 your queen is not
active at all the only question I have
is whether or Knight D4 perhaps
is good enough
and it is very very close now
first of all Queenie 5 is never going to
happen because one will afterwards be
collected maybe if black is in time to
trade the d-pawn
then I think it's
drawish although it changed from how it
was there is symmetry gone here a little
bit there is a potential for
fast Pawn now
the other thing is yeah long term and
the other thing is maybe I can even
prevent D3 from happening somehow I
don't quite see how but
but yeah maybe I can like no not easy
Bishop D3 in which situation yeah yeah
well you could try to trade Queens but I
think their black as Bishop A2 but
should be one
yeah but even that so just to uh to to
show uh that okay I assume that is a
draw but even that it is not no longer
trivial because
I have a potential to Let's hypothetical
let's say I bring my king here I go B3
A4 I have a past one here then I have a
passport here and then I win it's not
trousers because you do like Bishop F1
you start bothering me everywhere
but it is possible so I think situation
is a very
uh very dangerous for Ding and I I think
blundered you know I think you blundered
I think what he missed is that I think
he missed Queen C7 as a threat it's what
I missed I saw Queen V8 I didn't
sequence the seven I think he might have
basically sound because that explains
why he thought so long here he's
probably planned something like Queen B7
2696 which would have fully defended if
it were not for Queen C7 because Queen
B8 is completely innocuous obviously
black has the time to defend his pawns
yeah I think q87 is over I think he when
he played C6
somehow I also missed it because usually
you think a queen trade without even
winning a pawn is okay but suddenly you
win the B6 spawn which is crucial
and so that's why he started thinking so
long about the only moves that are B5
um yep and then King H7 which is also
absolutely obviously the only move but
he spent time because it wasn't planned
and he's thinking like okay how how big
is the damage like what have I done am I
still okay uh is there Plan B like I
think I think he's in a very bad spot
being uh
a serious serious problem and as you
pointed out there have been games before
that Ding lost to Young in this kind of
fashion
not not feeling optimistic for him at
all
I mean you're confident yarn who smells
blood or as the time Advantage I mean it
is a it's a yawn to be reckoned with and
I don't mean to keep harping on this but
ding you know still not at the board is
sticking to his guns he is staying in
that rest area section you know whatever
it is about that spot that's conducive
to thinking but you might have to change
up his routine soon enough so the choice
here on each is between Bishop D6 and
Bishop C7 We Believe those to be the
only two feasible candidate moves but
we're leaning toward Bishop C7
yeah I think there's Queen D2
infiltration was an issue
um
white maybe has other moves but I I
don't think they're as good I think you
do want to take the pawn
a question is which one
yeah I
I think that position we discussed is
extremely important Bishop C7 96
takes
I think if you don't go Knight D4 you
just lost the pawn we keep the knights
on the board and you just lost the pawn
you didn't get any closer to the draw
and you'll have to suffer and long term
there is not only you lost the pawn you
lost the wrong Pawn because I have the
potential to create a past a pawn here
right
could I try Queen D7 or is that I mean
obviously that's I'm not hiding my
intentions here but Queen D1 is not that
easy to stop even Tempo down there in
that line you could not even a Tempo
down you still try to actuate the queen
that's actually super annoying actually
it's super annoying Windows 7 is very
good yeah thank you
and why would want to play Queen d8
unfortunately that's not possible
yeah
um
so do we have to trade Knights like that
or
Auto or maybe another four years what I
do
right and everything's nicely
coordinated here Black's Queen doesn't
have as much to attack with the Knight
on an invulnerable square and when the
knights off the board
now we enter a situation where I would
say
oh or you know reverse of what it was
before so I wouldn't say it's a 30 70
draw
um sorry 370 being white win 17 drone
but I would say it's like a 70 30 I
think it's it's more likely white wins
and black rose because of the way the
pawn structure on the inside is if the
pawn on C5 was on A6 as in some lines we
demonstrated earlier I think it would be
much more likely to be a draw now
because of the potential to create a
past one here and here very long term of
course better
even the simplest Bishop end games are
no longer obvious and they could even be
lost already so
definitely
definitely unpleasant and the screen
designer doesn't solve all the issues
nor does Knight D4 I think
I think Young just
should go for this one yeah I don't and
I think he will because
this other one's much less tempting
right between the two that that's that's
also it's a wrong Pawn to take because
now uh it's a fighter here it's just
it's just post position it's just a
wrong Point positionally yeah it's just
it's just a wrong point to take not even
even if uh black played the move like A4
um
it's still a wrong Point although bar
somehow shoots up but I mean
conceptually speaking I would still
think that um black is happier having
this pawns than having the doubled C
pawns because white cannot create a
password Here
so I think Giannis taking his time but
the A5 Pawn should eventually be
the one captured and there's no chance
that he's he there's some third
candidate movies contemplating stuff
briefly yeah
will never be able to trade the knights
yeah I think this is the alternative
yeah I think that he's weighing his
options because this end game is very
juicy I have to say
wow and then you can yeah
no it is Juicy but how it it this is
some of the hardest hardest decisions to
make not just on the defensive end but
from Jan's perspective it's just as
agonizing to have to decide personally
in these types of situations the moment
I decide on one thing I immediately
start regretting it the second hand is
released from the piece
yeah it's the same the same it's it's a
it's a I think it's our problem more
than the problem of the game we should
it's just not regretting but I also have
that a lot I mean uh whenever you
haven't choose between two seemingly
equal options it's very easy to regret
though the move you made and that's the
wrong approach
but you know that said look if we zoom
out it's game one and uh it's a risk
reposition it's I mean I think agonizing
is a uh is a big word overstating it a
little bit Yeah
much more comfortable yeah I mean it's
okay draw will be fine it's okay you'll
afterwards he will say press conference
yeah I was better pressing this Choice
okay while for ding I mean it's losing
it first game it's a big big big uh big
disaster he's yeah he's down on the
clock as well so
wow I mean
big disaster indeed and Grandmaster nake
sons in the chat made a good point that
you know if he does lose the first game
we might see some you know early blood
being spilled we might see ding uh kind
of drastically change his uh routine his
openings but we should point out that
losing the first game of a world
championship match that's not obviously
not necessarily a death sentence the
first world championship match ever held
uh in Havana in 1889 when steinerts
defeated chigoran to become world
champion Wilhelm Stein has got destroyed
in the first game then he won the second
okay then he lost the third there was
only one draw in that entire match the
first 16 games were all decisive
I mean you bring up that match uh I mean
that was an entirely different time if
you if you look up the games between
Chicago and Stannis this was some wild
stuff I mean
it's different game they played it was
such a different time the blundering
left and right now is is staggering
honestly but it's yeah they were making
the first steps you know yeah yeah
exactly exactly exactly and they were
discovering the game pretty much
um at its like initial stages
it was a completely different time I
I the example that came to my mind as
well was the one
the one in topalov that's the match that
I already followed slightly more
yeah 2010 we speak here I think 10
probably
9 2010 nine nine out of ten I think ten
yeah yeah and there uh was a crushing
diff
opening defeat
um
topalov crushed wishing in game one I
wish it came back in game two and which
eventually ended up winning the match it
was a 10th match he won because he won
in the last last game and he aged uh
hashed out there
um
but
I think a lot depends on dink's um
how how much uh how much prep he's done
with the white pieces or rather not how
much but how successful it has been has
he found certain interesting ideas with
white because when you are down after
game one I think what you want is you
want to go back to your hotel room and
feel like you have something ready
you want to have something ready for the
next game because if you don't uh you're
already in a bad mood that you lost any
there's nothing improving that mode
but if you have something to look
forward to you know some idea opening
idea it's okay you'll think okay I'll
come back tomorrow maybe and a feeling
of comfort that you know you know what
you're playing you have to get excited
about uh the ideas that you that you
come up with you just keep can't be
impartial
to what you're playing you've got to
bring your absolute best what makes you
happiest to the world championship and
yes I need to correct myself Stein at
sugar and was not the first world
championship match that was signed at
supertort thank you Hikaru in 1886. uh
this was the first signage chagoran
match and there would be several as
Mikhail chigorn never managed to take
away the throne from steinus despite
some incredibly agonizing defeats
did Hikaru correct you on that he did
so Hikaru Hikaru is there back sitting
here and uh fact checking our stream
okay it's good to know good to have you
know personal fact Checker in the chat
um yes speaking of facts uh nepo was
spitting some facts in an interview that
I conducted with him uh a couple of
months ago let's listen into uh some of
nepo's amazing insights
here and there but they're like four
games six games it's it's not quite the
same it's not the same level of
excitement involvement and preparation
so probably probably this will favor me
about
um talking about the format of the match
he
he's confident and his confidence uh
Anish is something that I've noticed I
think has increased since his match with
Carlson when everybody was shoveling
dirt on him that's it he's broken he
doesn't believe he can win a world
championship patch suddenly all of those
people are gone
yeah I think Jan uh one thing I we have
to give him I think his confidence is an
unshattered and he he's always been very
confident in himself
and for good reasons obviously a
tremendous talent and the great player
and I think
nothing can break him if that match
didn't break him then nothing will he is
unbroken and he knows that things could
have gone differently
he attributes the all the bad results or
individual mistakes you think there's
nothing wrong with him he uh even even
though in the interviews afterwards he
he said there's nothing wrong with his
mindset
um nothing wrong with his psychology
at times maybe he's even too confident
and maybe he's even uh somewhat wrong
with with that but that doesn't mean you
know it doesn't change the reality that
he is very good and very confident and
confidence you know I think in chess
they say it's better to be overconfident
than under confident and I think that is
true
and we apologize for that uh the the
little segment cut off we promise that's
not all nepo had to say about uh his
level of experience and how the Magnus
match impacts uh his state of mind let's
try that again here's nepo
I mean every unsuccessful game is a
lesson and of course
uh the main the main thing I I took away
from this match was my experience and
experience was quite quite sad uh but uh
maybe it was that's why it was quite
useful yeah I mean even like in the
middle of the match I would say even
until I started let's say like
blundering everything in one move uh I
would say that
I came to sort of a conclusion that okay
it's pretty much different uh comparing
to what I have you know to what I have
expected so now I'm like in in a way can
can model uh let's say uh the match how
it goes how it might go so for example
uh a general idea all right so between
candidates you should like win like
three or four games to win match you
should do in one game and lose zero yes
I mean it's also quite quite a childish
approach I think yeah so speaking of the
upcoming match it's
um I mean surely I think it's I wouldn't
say it's like my only Advantage
comparing to Dean but uh it's one of
like very important things that uh
already okay I have like uh more or less
a bitter experience but nevertheless
that's an experience I'm not sure if
he's like pretty much used to you know
this type of Chess of course he's
playing some matches like here and there
but they're like four games six games
it's it's not quite the same it's not
the same level of excitement involvement
and preparation so probably probably
this will favor me
it's a little bit more context uh about
that what four or six games refer to so
nepo he believes that is a experience
isn't that positive right now the way
that the first game is going his words
have aged pretty well and each Bishop D6
though is on the board big decision
there which is a move that we looked
coldly upon compared to Bishop C7 but
you could double back after Queen D7 you
do have the option to play Queen C7 and
go back to that end game which you call
juicy
yeah though when you play with 56 you
probably don't intend to follow it up
with Queen C7 because if anything you
give black maybe a little well more
options so to speak I'm in Quincy seven
7 right Bishop D6 27 27 there is an
option of Bishop E8 or Bishop E6 so
either and once you decide on Bishop D6
also you get one step move closer to
time control which is not beneficial to
you who has more time and better
position so he doesn't intently he will
not do it unless he here really changes
his mind which he might now do because
he probably will realize Bishop C5 Queen
D2 is an issue so I have to say that yes
I liked um
both Bishop C7 and queen C7
Bishop D6 is my least favorite of all
three
because I did not see a good follow-up
after Queen the two I do not say good
good follow-up here um I I mean I do D4
Knight E6
[Music]
just briefly thinking of some weird
tactics but I don't think they work some
97 but you can even move the bishop
probably like so this Motif occurred to
me I don't know if it makes sense
yeah this is a draw because you can go
to the phone
um yep
but maybe bishop B6
wow and then I guess C5 doesn't do
anything because yeah defends F4
yeah no this is just pretty but I guess
96 yeah is the
I mean this position I think is
acceptable for black I think this at
this point ding is happy with us I mean
very limited damage here you put the
spawn to A4
um you bring okay even if you were
forced to bring the queen back
because uh White somehow you know scared
you with Bishop of fate or something
it's okay like uh it's very Jewish and
it's very safe and you are worse you
have suffered but but it's okay draw is
still Within Reach but um yeah the same
couldn't have been said about Bishop C7
or queen C7 so I'm not sure I'm not sure
what the unmissed he definitely missed
something because queenison is the most
thinking his only move and he realized
that he missed I think from afar he
might have thought about 96
uh once he wanted to do let's say
I'm not 26 let's say he planned and now
he's really awesome yeah his son
realized there's 22 and he maybe missed
some detail somewhere down the road here
and he missed some detail and uh
um
and that's why he's thinking because of
course this makes no sense to play Queen
to Play Bishop D6 after the only move
Queen the seven to then think to start
thinking because where did you expect
him to go would you expect him to know
you know Queen E8 so it's clear it's a
clear tell when you make a move your
opponent responds in an only move
fashion and then you you know you adjust
your sitting position you go into a deep
think
clearly he knows Queen C7 is an option
it's very hard to evaluate that end game
incredibly hard to evaluate whether it's
winning technically or is it a technical
draw so very difficult decision now for
Napo and Anish correct me if I'm wrong
but psychologically I think it's also
hard to course correct well you've we're
saying that right especially because
then you're regretting not playing them
in the previous move maybe that extra
move would have been the difference
between ding making time control and
drawing and making a mistake on move 40.
yeah uh although uh
we should also not exaggerate the
importance of this one move especially
in an end game like Queen C7 but I do
think
uh it is a small setback small negative
emotion there because young probably
anyway regrets even Queen C7 he probably
thinks now the bishop C7 was the best
option that's what pre probably thinks
maybe that is also the case and so now
he realizes okay Gypsy five is bad but
plan B27 is a compromise but it's not
what he had one I'm not sure he regrets
that mean that uh extra move
to the time control I think he probably
regrets not having gone Bishop C7
and in when you are pressing like that
and I um I don't know if you have the
same but I definitely have that as well
in classical chess especially each time
you you have this negative emotion you
are upset that you've done something
slightly wrong somehow
it it just ruins it ruins the vibe and
somehow
you want to play a perfect game you
understand and so far he thinks he
thinks so far he maybe played the
perfect game
and now he knows okay this was imperfect
he knows it's imperfect
and the first imperfection you know that
that's a small psychological blow there
to your winning chances as well I think
I experienced that I think in a slightly
different way in the sense that I will
replay it constantly it's like your
tongue searching for you know that that
space or the tooth fella it's like I'm
constantly replay the scenario where I
do go Bishop C7 and I would have won the
game and I would have been happy and
then you keep adding on to that
narrative uh and it's sometimes hard to
get that out of your mind because you
just keep telling yourself all I had to
do was trust my instincts and play that
one move whereas you still have a game
to play and you still have winning
chances but you're too busy exploring
the alternate scenario and obviously the
regret just increases uh when you flesh
that scenario out
yeah yeah I think what you mentioned is
even worse because luckily I don't do
that much I don't go for alternative
reality because that is really really
harmful but even that just the negative
feeling I mean I try to brush it away
but deep inside I know that it was there
okay something entirely different has
been played tonight I just agree
okay that's very interesting just
keeping the tension all together doesn't
want to go for the pawn at all
I actually like that concept A lot
yeah not what we thought about because
we were kind of more we were thinking
more short-term regarding some porn you
know going forcing Something game but uh
also this move actually
somewhat justifies the previous move
because crazy 7 is an admission of being
wrong or having a different intent and
Knight G3 is kind of the principled way
forward he's like no no this was the
plan
I wanted to get the bishop 36 and Knight
to G3 yep who needs how good is this yes
how good is this so Knight 26 I guess
is that D4
possible
and then looks fine I was gonna suggest
I always want to suggest 97 because I'm
used to that pattern but there's a
bishop guarding G8 so it's not effective
I don't know there's no also couldn't
Affairs let's say I take you take you go
here there oh sorry this thing this
thing everything okay oh a check wow
yeah anyway let's say you would go
Bishop's five first it just this doesn't
work so there's no point tonight clunky
oh maybe 60 first maybe C3 just protect
profile
but then black can take the tempo and
improve question is how maybe
I was thinking Bishop G6 just take this
thing out of Knight F5 and maybe it has
the opposite effect it's coming anyway
yeah but that maybe takes takes a night
ooh nightwear it doesn't have too many
options jeeps and G5
okay it's rerouting Queens coming out
yeah I didn't realize the night at F7
maybe Knight d8 also
oh yeah yeah same same effect I'm not
sure Knight to five was needed
um
is that four is a four I think
F4
it absolutely is a thing I mean black is
almost out of squares for his minor
pieces yeah you got to go back I think
or no no the engine shoots up not happy
first of all is it F5 and you trap the
Knight
Bishop C7
okay I just didn't realize I we just
literally trapped the knife okay now I
understand what I've done I should put a
bishop on E8 and then I would have
um F7 for the night either case yeah I
just completely forgot that somehow the
knights could run out of squares
it's incredible uh 96 has been played uh
in the meantime and also in the meantime
that pose down to 20 minutes himself
which is not time pressure you know
again not exaggerating but listen this
is not uh this is not the 45 minutes he
had just a couple of moves ago we remind
you for those just joining move once
move 40 is made 60 Minutes are added to
the player's clocks then uh after 20
more moves after move 60 an additional
15 minutes at it and that's when the
increment kicks in there is no increment
until move 60.
all right yeah here we go and
psychologically it's a very different
situation so um as you uh probably agree
20 minutes against 11 or 45 against 11
that's like
person uh what's not night and day
person well basically yeah it's just
completely different story and
um now it's sort of a mutual each time
trouble while if you are 10 minutes
against 45 it felt like you're just
getting crushed to be honest on the
clock F4 F4 has been played he didn't
94 could be one thing
90 okay 94 at the very least is uh is
okay is that also why the bar is so
happy should C5 and
Knight F just Knight C2 simply no
another three I was thinking yeah if
they I understand what you mean yeah
some pattern there I don't think it
doesn't work King G1 King G2 and Bishop
F2 yeah yeah yeah everything or this is
the most solid yeah oh yeah can you do
your right because now the phone is
Bishop C4 mm-hmm
but I think it's gonna be nice to do it
and light is not so bad it's yeah wait a
second 291 is Checkmate hello yeah yeah
oh there maybe maybe time for Queen D6
in a draw for there
yeah you mean right here yeah yeah this
is very little this is very little oh
it's nothing actually
yeah
okay you have to be active blind yeah
okay of course no white of course
doesn't run any risk but
but you have to be accurate yeah let's
say queen A7 maybe is the one
oh also that bar doesn't like it also
indeed
ding is up from his chair he's he's
definitely surprised by this move
yes uh clumsy clumsy thing I mean young
clearly
something something's gone wrong here
something's gone wrong there are two
great options and somehow he missed
something and now he is just slightly
lost the thread
now did you I might have zoned out for a
second after Knight D4 fc3
what did we we didn't look at this yet
yeah
where does the Knight
make its home
it's actually hard to decide default
default is B3 of course just the normal
square but I'm wondering if there is
some some resource that we are missing
but I think it's just B3 I guess
and white can't make easy progress
because anytime the bishop moves the
queen and black queen infiltrates and
Bishop on F7 is an amazing Defender it's
just holding all of the key squares
exactly no but the thing when we pushed
F4 in our line after C3 the point was
not to just push affordable
going after the night
s that had no squares
now the knights kind of comfortable on
the other side of the boards and F4 in
itself is just the weakening of the
light squares more than anything else
so I don't think you're like happy to
for although of course you will try to
generate some King side
play that's probably his idea
but whether whether that can work is
then is completely a different question
and also Knight D2 is coming I can
Target your epon it's getting back now
yeah I mean to say that it's getting
double edged and like why it has to
worry about things it's maybe
overstating it but you know
it does it does a little bit it does a
little bit
and Jan could be tempted by by dings
clock he could try to initiate
complications and then it truly will uh
become once again a three result game
F4 F4 a mistake due to Knight D4 and
ding has to find this move I mean this
is on a silver platter this has been
served to him
something else and he hasn't done it
uh but I wanted to mention one thing uh
Daniel maybe bishop c59295 bothered him
but he was bothered by some concrete
business here
ooh maybe this was yes it's easy when
the eval bar shows zeros but this is
made threats circulating again as well
yeah and that is weird and okay
Knight E1
but there's Bishop D6
yeah there is nothing here
no there's nothing
but ding has made a move on the other
side of the board he's gone H5
and probably another seems like that
either
uh yeah he I think what happened is he
trusts what sometimes you do is you try
you have little time you trust the
opponent you think okay obviously he's
on Knight D4 obviously he has some plan
he just spent like 20 minutes in the
last three moves he has some plan uh you
just think okay if it's dangerous what
are my options oh H5 H5 maybe not so bad
and you just you just dismiss the main
move because you just trust the guy you
have little time and you just play the
second move just by the way it decent
the computer doesn't uh doesn't dislike
it yeah H4 is the idea
pushing the knights uh
forward getting some room so how is this
line h495 697
taken King age
yeah I was just thinking can I afford
that or it's just checkmate
that there must be
there's a question oh Queen F7 Knight G
and Knight F6 yeah this is a hard one I
mean this is also not this is also scary
like this also will be scary
you have to just you go back here this
is also barely holding but the screen of
seven move you mentioned that's just a
killer
you threatened this Knight G8 deep deep
puzzle Russia
style Checkmate here
yeah that is you know Ray Robson would
find that in you know one million yes
but anybody uh
and everybody less talented then Rey
would also realize Bishop before it's
too dangerous anyway Bishop F7 or Bishop
V8 even yeah the computer likes both
ones yeah and Bishop he had a shutdown
move just shut down White's pieces
completely and they're actually in fact
they're all defending each other but
it's very clumsy construction there's
nothing that they're not attacking
anything they're just defending each
other young instead plays a young Place
C3 and now we are heading for this
variation after H4
now the Knight doesn't have to jump to
F5 it Paradox Knight H1 Knight F2 could
be this positional idea to play
prophylactically make it hard for black
to find useful moves
yeah of course you can do that but let's
just establish uh one thing if things
sort of have gone out to Beyonce control
somewhat anyway like this was not the
plan and it looks really good uh here he
had a choice between a very beautiful
end game or uh winning a pawn
instead he wanted to win a pawn then he
realized that this is a wrong Pawn to
win there's Queen D2 and then I think
it's just uh sort of spiraled slightly
out of control and now it's just uh and
you're not gonna win any problems yeah
he's just making money you're not
winning any pawn the pawn structure has
become no longer this clear-cut uh the
White's E4 Pawn is potentially weak
things just spiraled out of control and
I I guess uh
it's just it's just okay for for black
somehow
ding has not gone H4 and said he has
pushed upon on the other side of the
board he's gone C4
trying to fix the problem of that weak
Pawn obviously we see that the developer
is not a fan of that move but wait we
talked about this is blundering in a
different oh no it's a different
position F5 I have H4 Intermezzo oh
but it's a noise and wait a second yeah
if we continue this line Knight
e25 is that okay for black
oh and maybe maybe Knight H1 Knight F2
maybe it's time for that reflecting but
still it's
it's lackluster it's lackluster Queen E8
even
yeah H4 is nice like compared to the
line we had just before well on H6 this
was losing a piece remember
but now yeah this H4 is an important
resource so ding reserves the move H4 uh
for desperate desperate times and of
course white can go H4 but that weakens
creates this huge hole on G4
yeah I was uh I was thinking about that
yeah
but you cannot really use this though at
the moment and F5 is a threat
so if you drop the Knight away
yeah you can either you could give the
Knight the space as we know with Bishop
E8 idea or you could you could also
trade Queens
and go for this uh end game after all
which is which is nice for white yeah
it's a nice end game even at five so
I don't know how much it is but it's
nice
yeah maybe this bishop yada is here
maybe that now I have this clips and
before you know it my knight is actually
approaching a juicy Square here
we try things though
h564
looks like enough control for black
somehow
getting absolutely crazy here night of
wait Knight F4
yeah it's concrete yeah you'll attack my
knight the king will protect itself
and maybe there is no Checkmate yeah
wow maybe bishop D6
yeah and just there's no place Bishop D6
and suddenly you realize there's just no
play in your deadlost
oh you got excited with it before but
it's just just not happening
if things can get concrete and the time
situation is uh
is becoming you're banking mostly on the
time situation at this point H4 I like
them of H4 from a practical perspective
the The Wider the decision tree is for
Black
obviously the bigger the chance that a
mistake happens before move 40 and H4 is
played
how is this G6 move
how bad is this move G6 play Queen d8
instantly
okay he believes that this is a
salvageable end game he feels
confidently that that's the case Queen
trade is forced yeah well either that or
he thinks that this is the best he's got
and uh he's lucky that he at least has
an endgame that doesn't lose her
hmm
because
because he might just have been really
worried about this uh this prospects of
the F5 push and now he's just happy to
go into some sort of an end game
and he knows it's an unpleasant game but
he thinks okay first of all the other
end game with Queen 7 was worse
because now he's got a good version of
things he managed to push the queen side
a little bit and white weakened himself
with F4 got a a G4 weakness here so he
is thinking okay if things are not too
bad let's go for that game
and he knows he'll make move 40 in one
piece and then he will have that extra
hour that he can and will use to
ultimately probably hold the draw I
think I think he's over the hump
yeah yeah yeah it's an important uh
important indeed that once the position
clarifies this crazy lens we just looked
at with Knight coming to East E7 or F5
and all the stuff there you need a lot
of time once you take queens of the
boards you don't need time you could
just play things by hand and not much
can go wrong or not much can change in
any case
yeah I I tend to agree with you probably
thinks um things will probably end okay
for ding but he will suffer he will
suffer
but I guess yeah
to you know to continue that thread from
earlier Yana has to put out of his mind
the idea that he could have gotten a
much juicier end game with Queen C7 so
the irony is that in a roundabout manner
they will have reached an endgame and
one that is just incomparably more
defensible for black
yeah I mean I'm wondering uh how big a
difference it is we can just take a
take a look here just to compare briefly
so okay Bishop to 7 is even 96. so we
have this end game let's say
versus
a pathway has a pathway to C5 why did
the Knight not have C5 there
I guess oh I guess because there's a
pawn there yeah that's the answer the
pawns are already here which is
which is commitment by white white white
can keep the pawns much more
fluid and black has already gotten uh C4
and I think A4
C4 there so there's definitely some
differences and the differences favor
Black somewhat
you can tell that for sure and uh
Jan is thinking I guess about which
version of the end game to go for
yeah so whether to play F5
obviously I briefly considered Queen B7
but it's the same here same here also
about Queen B7 there's this queen G7
Knight F5 idea at the end yes yes I
thought about the same
um
you can show that actually wait Knight
F4 there's Knight F5
so surprising
oh maybe there is an option to keep the
Queens on the board yeah very much so
okay you have to defend like King Jade
maybe just okay maybe the king is better
on here because Knight to five is coming
maybe some move with a bishop here
Bishop G
CG GM oh gosh such a hard decision to
make there's also Bishop G6
allowing F5 but it's not the end of the
world
but white can make some intermediate
move like Bishop D7
yeah and then wow
Bishop E8 maybe yeah
and you have Queen the seven of Knight
F5 if needed
and that might be the key idea to sever
the connection between the queen and the
pawn on G7
yeah this looks alright
there's a queen B7 uh a little little
scare there you might have but
probably not a big deal after Bishop E8
I think you don't want to start with a
five because you start with a five I
will trade and I'll activate my knight
by C5 immediately which is very nice so
if you trade you should trade with Queen
d8 Knight d8 and then F5 shutting down
my knight
mm-hmm
no but this is a very hard decision to
make I think I think John should go for
Queen B7
I think and now that I saw this I can't
get it out of my head like the song goes
and he's played it yeah
yeah ding has to ding will take a moment
here how much time does he have and how
many moves does he does he have to make
so this is his 34th move so one two
three four five six seven more moves to
make
and he's finally at the board he doesn't
have a time to run between the rest area
and the board so he's gonna be at the
board for the rest
of this segment
Bishop G6 Bishop B8 Bishop G8
Bishop G6 of course drops C6 yes first
you establish 26 okay he's very quickly
as part of Bishop eighth
okay yeah can't can't be uh
great news for young I guess he will
just switch to another game after all 95
Queen D7 and then just trade
trade and just bring the king and just
play this end game slightly better still
because of Black's double Pawns
can white insist on keeping the Queens
with Queen D7 Queen B8
okay yeah you can yes probably you can
but I can also insist although idiot
yeah but then I probably have a worse
version with black
although again the Knight gets around to
B7 and then through C5
which is the annoying part there used to
be a pawn there now the Knight is a
pathway out of B7
well I mean if the night ever gets to B7
I could reestablish my Bishop on B6 just
to be sure that you are not going
anywhere far
I I don't think you will
get too active
but the question is yeah if it's enough
for white to win or not
yeah Queen D7 uh he's Bishop G6 salsa
or six point is hanging
yeah yeah
Queen to seven played we need seven
played
and now it's a big mini decision
so Queen B6 would be a blunder because
of G6
yeah you need to guard this bishop
somewhat so either Queen B8 or you're
okay with the end game
what if you zigzag Queen B8 queen d8
queen A7
Queen D7 though because you can't take
A5 again because of this G6 resource
but you can pretend and then so after
Queen V8 uh but is there a threat like
can I make a move like maybe C5 or
something or or is that just weakening
or can I and then try to activate
somehow someday
it's a very foggy position it's like
hard to
grasp C5 maybe Queen B6 but then Queen
C6
yeah but like what are you exactly why
why do you want to avoid the trade of
Queens with white right now because I'm
what is your why do you want to keep the
Queens what is your attack I don't I
don't think you have so much no I agree
the pieces are I think you should just
go for an endgame and just and just be
happy that you still have something
because of the better Pawn structure oh
no it keeps keep the tension okay
yeah Queen d8
is very likely to happen quickly
didn't get any closer to the time
control
you think Queen did yeah
and then perhaps he will trade and
allegedly get a better version although
it's not a given the Knight on B7 is a
bad piece at all yeah you're right maybe
maybe it's not
yeah Queen dates probably a
logical I mean again I think I can make
a move here like an A4 or C5 I can make
a move but
not sure what for ding is checking if
this is not the same position but it's
not
95 Bishop E8 have been included
or is also confirming just the amount of
moves he needs to make yeah which is
probably uh which probably the the case
we've seen a couple of incidents
throughout top level chess tournaments
uh Magnus or whistle and Apollo I think
I don't remember was the Magnus or
vessel in the last lost a game like that
and round one of Norway chess I think
just yeah Magnus a clerical error you
know you skip a move on your score sheet
everybody does that from time to time
and with three and a half minutes left
trying to get the Queens off the board
is dingler and queen d8 is the most
straightforward option but you're
pointing out that black is under no
obligation to
Force anything and can play a move like
A4
but Queen D displayed yeah you are first
full of profit but also you're extremely
good at predicting opponents moves in
the time scramble so you guessed it
correctly it's indeed Queen d8
I have to add by the way that the point
you made about the move move counter so
you know some some opponents sometimes I
I heard that they do it sometimes so
very rarely they mislead you by not
writing down the move I think it's not
allowed but you sometimes you check your
own scores you check opponent's question
you check your opponents yeah but they
can they can sometimes not write down
the move and that's safety numbers and
then claim that they made a mistake yeah
of course of course uh that that has
happened in the past as well I heard
some stories
but for now yeah the ding is chasing
that Queen he wants that end game he
wants his end game which is slightly
worse but it's at least safe he knows
there is limit to how bad this end game
can be it has to still be a draw he will
make his time control and then he
probably will defend
um the game eventually
so
yeah he's uh apparently they had made
clear that there was no additional time
of 60 Magnus arrived late so the lesson
don't arrive late to you around Queen A7
Queen D7 I think is what nepo's in the
process of realizing nothing there
You're Gonna Lose A minor piece if you
grab on A5
you just gotta he has to accept it I
feel like he
maybe he's having a hard time accepting
that
the likeliest outcome in this end game
is going to be a draw but you really
have no way to keep the Queens on the
board
yeah he's trying to keep the tension of
course in the pressure and so on but see
as you said there's just no no option I
just want to point out that I think he
has got this uh 3.14 yeah it's like a
pie on his on his clock this is quite
quite a nice ah nice new ones there long
day long day nice
yeah I'm sure that's what's on his mind
right now I mean playing the first game
of the World Championship Match being
under pressure for so long oh of course
yeah he's he's rehearsing the amount of
digits that he knows like
3.14
159 that's all I know
hey yeah if Yan drops down to one one
minute 59 seconds we will have uh quite
a lot of pie ditches on on the score on
on the camera there oh yeah nothing is
going to happen though yeah
yes
is there yeah any chance he leaves the
queen up V8 no that doesn't make any
sense
yeah I think you should be aware of
Knight C5 Knight D3 I mean uh it's all
the same until the Night comes in uh
y6523 that's not going to be the same
then suddenly B2 is hanging and uh it's
a time to take over so I think all the
end games they look to be similar as
long as the Knight stays passive inside
uh Black's territory
mm-hmm
he's choosing the version yeah I it's
it's to me it feels like I don't know
anymore actually I you I thought first
night on B7 is bad but now I'm thinking
maybe it's not it's it's just as good
there is anywhere else
yeah I mean there is a chance of a seven
hour game here if the Queens are traded
Jan's not gonna get let didn't get away
that easy
and he's going to use a lot of that hour
that he's gonna get on move 40. so
what is the likelihood that we get
Marathon game one a niche like how
insistent is Yan going to be on
squeezing every last chance I think
pretty insistent given
that he knows earlier in this game he
had excellent winning chances
that is a good point uh if you had
nothing the entire game you you sort of
were never never excited but if you had
a big Advantage at some point it's hard
for you to resign yourself to the
thought that the game is going to be a
draw and I remember in the last
tournament that young played where I
play as well he was he was fine with
grinding things out to the very end he
played long games and I remember the
game with he had with the acipenko it
was lasting
he was pushing it that was it was a draw
for already for a long long time but he
kept trying and trying and trying so
yeah I think Jan might might just keep
grinding this one out but it's very
solid for black very solid
yeah and now black snacks move probably
Knight B7
on his own volition I mean the Knight
actually wants to go to B7 which is a
polar opposite from
the initial end game that Yan could have
gone into and the difference is made
entirely by the placement of
Lex Pawn which is now on C4
yeah uh
I think Jan he should oh he went for 94.
wait so what if Knight B7 I think you
want to stop Knight survive so you go
Bishop to E7 and then would have came to
G8 right so we go Knight B7 Bishop I
think to E7 a bishop is almost trapped
after King it is trapped in freaking F7
yeah so wait what is the idea what is
it couldn't be E5 could it
because then I think take taken Bishop
D7 even might be some sort of a fortress
okay we're about to find out yeah yeah
let's see what's the point
E5 is
it's possible I guess it's not what I
expected
you can become very concrete right here
this is a dumb question but after Bishop
E7 King G8
that was the point yes now if you uh
take everything the Deep one is kind of
weak but maybe 96 and then night
C5 I'll move the bishop I have Knights
example Bishop to G6
Knight D7
yeah one more time control I think
taking the bishop on the six is just
very risky
black
trying to follow your advice pose
questions at the most inconvenient
moment this is the last chance you have
to pose questions that's why he did this
to make two moves yep that's why he did
it and that's why he went to 1945
because this is the only way to actually
make ding take a decision
mm-hmm
nice nice I think white doesn't risk
here anything I would guess I mean I'm
certain about that even in a position
like that even if you lose the e-pawn
with the Knight against Bishop you can
build a fortress you can bring the king
to F4 put a knight on E3 and just uh
wait forever so young doesn't risk
anything
and he's asking ding the final question
he's saying ding this is my only
question to you the best question I got
I hope for a better one but this is all
I got so answer it now
and he's got now one minute and 20
seconds to answer that question he's
definitely calculating 1966 Ed Bishop D7
trying to figure out does he have a
fortress there white even has the move
before in that position very tricky
can't take on Passat
that's a good one I didn't realize you
you were talking about 9680 Bishop G7
without taking fe5 that makes sense
because the kingdom doesn't have this
path towards F4 the white as F5 and 96
oh that's scary
maybe I don't know it doesn't take
which is probably the simplest option
yeah I think I wouldn't take
um such high pressure situation so much
at stake so little like you're not gonna
win anyway so why why it's a huge risk
to take you don't need to take skip the
status quo
enjoy this classic
very classy
this is why I have one more question to
pose this is White's 40th move but
remember black has to make his 40th move
folks for that time to add you can see
White's clock has been adjusted
ding with one more move to make Mission
D7 I think is that move now
if the sound looks
pretty neat to me it was king of seven
you allow it to check Bishop D7 E6 you
can take and then you take here you go
Bishop design first then you go king of
seven should decide the only question I
have is what about F5 but then you can
take a knight C5 Knight D3 episode 7
played I like it right call
wow and it looks like it's time control
and this is the opposite of what you're
talking about now it happened that he
just reached time control and he just
solves his last problem and everything
worked out for ding so this can also
happen and this is actually what
happened
should be a draw now
what defense for dangan
just crazy I mean
nepo with zero Advantage here White's
not better in this end game it's not
it's not even that you can nominally
torture your opponent correct me if I'm
wrong I think this is just this is draw
for territory and now you actually can't
offer a draw because move 40 has been
made
yeah but this is the right consequence
of what Young has tried to put maximum
pressure and ask that last question but
the problem with that is if the question
gets the right answer then that's it so
um Jan of course he definitely um
definitely did exploit his Advantage
here
it was back and move
29 here where he had lots of very
interesting options in particular I
think grabbing the spawn was very
promising I don't know if it's winning
probably not but it's definitely a good
opportunity and what he has now um the
question he asked with this 1945 that's
not too difficult for a player like
thing he basically just brings the king
back to the center and
um yeah it's it's very little left here
white one structure is ugly now we'll
put this hole on G4 you cannot create a
past Pawn if iPhone is is a past one but
it just copy the blocks and light Square
blockade here 19 B7 ready to jump by sc5
whenever the bishop leaves
simply very comfortable position I think
it's just uh it's just a draw indeed I
don't think he'll offer it he'll
probably make a few moves but
but yeah it's it's I don't see a
any other outcome here being likely
and as you pointed out E6 fails
tactically black plays Bishop takes E6
and the bishop on D6 loses its supporter
so an item B7 goes from you know villain
to Hero it is now a key cog in Black's
defensive machine and we are very
confident that the first game is going
to end in peace but the game is not over
and Jan is going to take some time and
see if he can figure out some way to
keep the uh now very small flame of his
initiative alive and that affords us a
good opportunity uh to take our post
time control break before we do that uh
we wanted to remind you that if you
dream of playing in the fide world
championship and well who doesn't well
chess.com is going to make your dreams
come true kind of you can now challenge
both world champion contenders in bot
form dingly run and Jana pomnia Bots are
available right now at chess.com play
slash computer so head over there and
let us know if you can beat nepo and
ding the computer version use x Glam f
WC Bots all one word xmfwc bots in the
chat for more information face off
against nepo and Ding and other
chess.com exciting Bots well we will be
back with more exciting action from
round one of the fide World Championship
in just a couple of minutes stay tuned
some of you may remember when puzzle
Rush launched it blew the Chess World up
and it happened literally right in time
for the World Chess Championship in 2018
and all those pieces just came together
of like and it was just awesome to see
of course it was excited it was a new
feature which we hadn't done in years
and it was a really good one and we're
like uh we like grew chess we're done
like how cool is that I remember the
word saying like guys like after I came
down
early early 2019 like we all need to
reset let's think about how we're gonna
add more features what could maybe be
something
close to puzzle Rush again because we
are never going to see growth like that
for chess again in 2018 puzzles because
the other thing that Serendipity was the
world championship our first feature in
three years got to get anxiety it was
our first feature like the those were
the dark years that Eric and I joke
about there were tears during that time
it was hard it was tough but then like
here goes puzzle Rush here comes the
world championship and here comes a
fateful dinner where I had queenies
shout out to you Hikaru take me to that
small restaurant the Isle of Man the
British Isles because hicaro picks it
because the car was a bit of a foodie
for those who don't know and that was
the dinner where I told a car that I
thought he could be the ninja of Chess
and that maybe if he gave streaming a
chance he might be surprised I spent two
and a half hours explaining what was the
online content ecosystem to Hikaru and
Sunil and Hikaru Embraces streamy partly
because puzzle Rush was such a fun
feature to stream sort of not the I
don't want to say the chipping point
because there were so many incredible
streamers who were committing to what
would become the future of what we now
know is like this incredible ecosystem
online the chess bras were like the ogs
of of committing to it you know um at
least as far as having a fully a fully
focused switch brand right and there
were there were so many others but but
we all knew and Eric Hanson I had talked
a lot at the time like we knew like the
category needed a Hikaru and we knew
that it was going to be something that
was going to take us to the next level
but I think partly the reason Hikaru
committed is because it was so easy and
fun because of puzzle rush like that was
it and then the world championship
viewers we were raiding the chess bras
and Hikaru every single day with Peak
viewership for the chess category and it
was like the Chess World peaked yeah it
appeared the end of 2018. that was that
was what you asked about right we're
talking if that's all we're talking
about that was it that was that was the
high point of Chess that was it but I do
remember the first time Magnus played on
our site I remember that feeling and I
remember the Goosebumps going on my arms
of like oh my goodness
that's like yeah okay I mean there's no
better chess player in the world who's
gonna ever play well maybe in the future
one day but
that was like the thing I remember the
moment where I was like oh my gosh we
have a Grand Master on our site he's
like kicking everyone's ass he's just
reading all his games what super strong
Grand Master is this
foreign
it was somebody cheating and we're like
oh my gosh how are we going to deal with
this it's hard to explain the whole
process but immediately right then we're
like this is going to be a make or break
for our future we have to invest here
and immediately started hiring like
statistician built an amazing team
around this and we've invested so much
time money and resources just to protect
this game that we love we immediately
knew how dangerous this could be and
remember that very first cheater was
such a painful experience to see so it's
been at the core of what we've done and
it's challenging because it's not
preventable
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
resignation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time it's
news oh my god did he just block yeah he
did I'm Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
she has methodically done what he needed
to do to get another shot at the title
that's the 2022 feet a can of the
champion and just an absolutely stunning
performance from Young the pressure to
seize the moment this time rests heavily
upon him
dingley Wren knows firsthand with the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame dingly Wren has
secured second place here amazing what a
big last round win for ding the legacy
of this Championship spans across
centuries it reads from the names of
Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 b-day World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
we are four hours into round one of the
fide world championship between
janapanishi and dingliren live from
Astana Kazakhstan where Yana pomdishi is
not looking too thrilled time control
has just been made an hour added to each
player's clock after move 40 has been
carried out Grandmaster nishikiri this
has been a frustrating last 10 12 moves
for Jana pomdishi who has watched his
entire Advantage slip away and turn to
dust
yeah absolutely and um started with a
big missed opportunity at one point and
then yeah this potentially a slightly
better end game but he chose not to try
and stabilize the position not to try
and bring the king to the center and
slowly try to eventually maneuver around
and go for something small instead he
put some pressure with this quick Knight
D4 E5 idea hoping for a dig tour somehow
uh somehow collapse but didn't just
replied to very calm collected way
brought his King back
brought this bishop here
and just uh solve the problems
just a light Square blockade and nepo I
mean his face says it all Levy says nepo
looking at the board the way I look at
the last donut
indeed Yan kind of Coming to Terms of
the inevitable
and he knows that with 56 minutes
there's just no way that I mean ending
is more than one drawing option even
Knight C5 I would imagine solves the
problems concretely
also C5 comes to mind C5 E6 Bishop
C
Bishop
Bishop C8
but yeah you're right that's [__] you
know king of smooth kf7 is the easiest
I'm just king of seven between the king
is they're also of weird Fortress like
Knight C5 Bishop A5 F5
how does white make progress
maybe unnecessary he played that by the
way 95 was played
yeah Fortress you you mean uh you you
want to
because you gotta play 96 yeah just yet
but the question is what is my move
after F5
yeah but I don't think you need that you
just bring the key to F7 uh as well and
then this Knight is going to get active
here and collect the spawn
yeah and droppers by the way they are
allowed after move 40 so at this point
it would probably be Yan who would who
would offer the draw
uh just because of the arc that the game
has taken and nominally he's still the
one pushing
Bishop takes A5 played I guess so
especially now he's collect to the pawn
so he is the one in apple Pawn but I'm
not sure at all if it's uh yeah it is
any better even it just takes in King F7
let's say also I think that's just very
very drawish at this point
I think
yeah definitely a bullet Deutsch there
by uh by Ding and speaking of uh Gotham
chess who showed up in comments I think
he already started recording his recap
to be honest trying to be
to be earlier
yeah the result of the game basically no
longer in question and obviously there's
a psychological battle that will have to
be fought by yawn and this is where your
team of seconds and supporters really
comes in and this is where they prove
their medal this is where they make you
see the positives and there are
positives to take away from Yan I think
his General approach of as you said
taking more risk and perhaps just having
more fun in the opening you know to put
it in a very primitive way
has paid dividends and uh the fact that
he didn't extract the most out of the
winning chances that he had doesn't take
anything away from that
yeah
it is both a positive and a negative I
mean the fact that you gain something
and in the opening is great
um the same time I don't know how many
of these ideas does he have does he have
like five more maybe maybe
uh but maybe that was his best
maybe that was his uh his best idea and
uh
maybe he doesn't have so much more
against the anti-martial maybe now he'll
have to switch to I don't know the
Italian opening and maybe there there's
no more such great ideas so you know
nowadays especially it's so hard to find
this promising ideas like the one that
he played today
maybe he has many maybe he doesn't have
many we'll see uh definitely I I think
definitely if he and it seems like this
game is ending in drive if it will enter
the draw I think ding will be the one
taking all the positives he'd re-dodged
the bullet there for sure
dodged a bullet and Dodge the the
opening bullet and ikara suspects a draw
for coming on the next move very likely
Fe King F7 ding is the speed with which
he's playing demonstrates his total
confidence in uh the fact that the the
the
game will be decided uh very shortly
yeah nepo's next move could even be E6
accompanied to the draw for oh like that
yeah okay I can't take it with a bishop
and then go like can I can I can I tease
you there a bit with black
because you know you're right it's ugly
it's ugly what you've done there so
that's the worst feeling when you have
the draw in your pocket and suddenly you
realize that you have messed it up to
the point where your opponent is now
playing for the win and plenty of games
like that
yeah but I mean if black plays for a win
here it's probably not because you
messed it up just because black can
afford to sort of like it's anyway equal
so black might as well keep making moves
uh I don't know I mean Bishop C7 is a
move as well I guess if Knight D3
then maybe I can push the b-pawns to B4
maybe or maybe Knight A4 first
um
yeah I don't know who has to be more
accurate here I I don't quite understand
it so we can
try to
yeah we can try to see
there's also no there were some ideas
with F5 Fe Knight F3 here yes yes no
longer I think no longer yeah because
the bishop had to be on C7 right you
have to be making contact to the pawn
yeah
so is it yeah I don't know I don't know
like it all happens so fast I'm not sure
who is playing for for what
is yeah what about Bishop let's say
Bishop to B4
and then he's six oh
threatening
398 but of course it's not I mean it's
not big deal you just move the bishop
back
is white running some Danger
well oh the bishop guard I think it must
be a fortress no yeah Knight back to D4
King to F2 yeah yeah it's a fortress
everything is protected no entries
points by both sides this is one way to
make a draw your E6 suggestion is just
um different yeah A6 also gives black a
chance to take with the Knight and just
go home
the move itself could be accompanied
also the dropper just uh you know to
make sure ding doesn't get any thoughts
in his head
um I think that's a question you know
like what gives him the thoughts I think
the draw forgives the thoughts sometimes
better not to offer a draw if you want
to draw because by offering it you show
vulnerability so it's
works both ways
yeah you show that you you're suddenly
you have the tiniest inkling of of worry
in your mind so ding he Dodges the
bullet with black he has white tomorrow
he suffered he struggled with white in
tata steel do you think that that
tournament is going to sit on him or do
you think that because he had to hide
essentially all of his opening
preparation that will not hurt his
confidence with the white pieces at all
no I think he's for I think after this
game he's forgotten about his entire
life and now all he remembers is the
game one championship match like before
the start yes Tata steel everything uh
his uh youth in China or everything that
has happened in his life it was all
there now I think game one's been played
and that's what's impactful and I think
the negative takeaway for ding uh is
that he has seen in this game that got
hit again uh with the black pieces not
only did he get hit with something he
didn't expect he started thinking
earlier but his response was not very
good got worse then he got um he got
outplayed at some point he was in some
quite some serious danger and um he
showed vulnerability so that is of
course a small negative takeaway for
ding but I think much more important is
that he managed to defend and uh diat
gets this half a point but still if
there's something negative to take away
there's definitely that
and I think something that that is easy
to forget this knight c395 uh idea if
nepo had Uncorked that
think probably would have seen it you
know let's not overstate the case and
claim that he would have taken on D4 and
it would have been 1-0 but even without
it the position remained very very
dangerous so this almost feels like a
different reality a different lifetime
but it was in fact the same game yeah
yeah you speak about this nice little
tactic that was there but uh to be fair
it was not a force after H3 black had
this strong reply at Crooked V8 it's
just only slightly worse for black
because but how findable is this move
would find it by elimination I I think
you have also at this at this point in
the game he had more than an hour like
one I guess one and a half hour at the
clock and he's a very good calculator he
will just find the 24 at D5 very quickly
and she would look at 96 Bishop six
which page five realize it's all bad
then look at Alternatives and rookie it
would eventually come it would take him
a long time he would need to verify it
he would have found it in that situation
and the game would have continued so
again even later also Jan didn't have
this
he didn't have like a clear-cut things
but there was definitely more to it than
what he has now because what he has now
is um
yeah it was just now it's just just draw
you should be for first
he's chosen this move Bishop before
Knight D3
and maybe bishop D6
uh oh yeah Knight bit soon
so we speak Knight D3 Bishop D6 tonight
it probably can take up B2 right
yeah there's no threat because I control
and then a five maybe it's forces to
draw even more Fe Knight F3
nah Bishop of five 95 King E6 so it's
I think that E6 line is we showed so
Knight D3 E6 E6 X takes 57 Knight D4 uh
Knight B2
and that was uh nothing king of two King
E3 and G3 that was
just wrong
ironically with digg's habit of not
coming to the board even during his move
he's not allowing nepo to offer a drive
Napo has the mannerism of someone who is
about to
very much so yeah he seems like he's
rated out for the draw ding is he's
snacking away he's opening up some water
he is this is a different ding than the
one who was wearing his hoodie you know
cuddled on that on that chair deep in
thought he knows that this is in the bag
now
it was it was a jacket I believe uh with
a
with a hoodia or is this what's is that
yeah basically I think I I'm like
worried is it cold there maybe it's cold
there yeah
but not cold enough to make him go sit
at the boards
so
I've never seen you know this amount of
I somebody with too much time on their
hands will probably
uh count the percentage of time that
Ding spent away from the board I would
bet a silver dollar is probably you know
among the record setters
uh in terms of world championship games
I think really the the game changer was
last for Championship I think Magnus
mentioned that as well like he was also
surprised like the amount of time nipple
was away from the board that was
unprecedented and now suddenly Dingus
took over that habit of him and that's
uh Gordon just mentioned in Chelsea is
just ghosting he's ghosting Nepal
mm-hmm and nepo himself has been at the
board quite a bit as he gets up from the
board of course and probably to find
ding to offer a draw
this is funny I wonder what are the
options he's going to the bathroom
obviously although if you needed to go
to the bathroom he would have gone after
immediately after he moves I think he's
going to find Dane
yeah sometimes it's a hilarious scene I
I've had this experience okay I think
they have separate bathrooms separate
rusting areas by the way but I've had
this experience sometimes okay so you
you'll um
you make a move so your opponent is
already left to the bathroom then you
make a move you go to the bathroom you
meet the opponent in the bathroom
because it's like the normal tournament
public bathroom and then I feel like
should I tell him what I played like in
the bathroom like washing hands like you
know by the way I played rookie eight or
like should I it's like you know it's
but it's different there because now
they have each separate restroom that's
what you get yeah once you become a
challenger they upgrade you you don't
have to share bathrooms with people you
get your own uh yeah like your own
snacks
it is old school to to share the movie
like I I remember I was playing uh an
old American International Master Joseph
Bradford uh very you know old tip you
know classic old school chessler and I
was walking back from the bathroom and
he he just was he was going to the
bathroom and he just said F4
and I'm like whoa and then I quickly
understood that you know this is what
they I guess what they used to do in the
old days because a few times
maybe this is just me but I would come
back from the board I would actually
have a hard time it would be my move and
I would have a hard time actually for a
second determining what move my opponent
made especially if it's like H3 or like
was the pawn always there
yeah the topic of returning to find a
move like that was the most epic story
was uh taught to me by a swiddler I
think he played against the antimon I
think it's a team championship and at
some point the rich move forces so
swedler leaves away from the board he is
up an exchange of a position is dead
drone
so he goes to the bathroom
he comes back to the board position was
drawn before and he finds himself with
no opponent jantime has already left
the score sheet is signed yantiman has
lost so Sweden has won and he's
wondering what has happened
basically my opponent has resigned in a
drone position and left before I even
came back now what happened was that
yantiman he touched the wrong piece
after moving which he would lose without
even making that move
he resigned wow there's like made on the
board and so he didn't know that he had
touched he has no way of knowing that he
had touched the wrong piece there is no
way the Sweden could have known but some
people had okay also honorable uh
Legendary player he he's not going to
take the move he's not going to play a
move with the difference he already
attached the piece let alone maybe there
are other people who've seen it but
still didn't see it so there was a
remarkable case like a drum position
but he he was so like he would have
resigned and he was probably so
miserable uh that he just wanted to
leave and not even um you know not not
even uh see himself lose the game and
see his opponent so it was kind of a
remarkable Story by Peter you know just
you go to the bathroom with the
afternoon 40 it's a draw you come back
and the punt is gone you won
congratulations like remarkable
insane I mean the uh
there's obviously a lot of stories of
premature resignation and there's
stories of uh you know uh touching the
wrong piece but for those to be put
together it's uh and and while somebody
else somebody is in the bathroom that
Confluence of events is uh is quite the
Rarity that's yeah you can't make that
up I mean I yeah yeah I heard it from
Peter himself so if I'm not mistaken I'm
pretty sure it was Peter swedler so yeah
it is he probably didn't make that one
up it's a crazy story yeah
it is frustrating when you're trying to
resign you know your opponent is walking
you just want to end the game
um but this match of course is is not
going to end anytime soon uh we wanted
to remind you folks that this is a
marathon uh not not a Sprint um there's
a couple of uh rule changes compared to
the Carlson Apple match in particular
there are no consecutive colors colors
always will alternate nobody will have
uh two white games or two black games in
a row and the second uh big change is
that there are more rest days there will
be seven res days over two weeks of play
that is there will be no more than two
days of Chess in a row the final game if
necessary remember this is the best of
seven uh best of 14 so uh technically
all you really need are paid games but
if this goes down to the last game it
will be played on April 29th if that
last game ends in a draw and the match
ends seven seven then a tiebreaker
consisting of rapid and then Blitz and
Armageddon
um if those are tied will be played the
following day on April 30th April 30th
21 days from now
this is
what is the longest event you've played
just sort of off the top
must be if I can say
mm-hmm oh no but I'm thinking if I can
say it's 13 days the candidates is 14
rounds so must be the candidates
and in this tournament because I played
two of them
that must be the longest but you know
back in the day like the Soviet uh
the Soviet Union uh you know back back
in those days they are playing some
crazy stuff also these candidates
tournaments yup candles with four like
they play each other four times that was
also the case
Robin yeah so like what else was that I
mean multiplication of four is really
difficult so yeah a lot of rounds and um
also Soviets I think some Soviet
championships were also lasting also
they had the adjournments that they
would stop the game by move 40 and
resume it on the special day uh later on
you had to schedule that in as well
and of course a lot of rest days because
it's inspiring so these events they
lasted months I think and okay carbo
that you mentioned at the start of the
show as well so those are pulling an
all-nighter to analyze was totally
because not everybody had the luxury of
having Petrosian and Tall on call to
analyze your games that's you know when
the Soviets were playing World
Championship matches they had an army of
GMS ready to analyze your game while you
slept if you were a BNG I'm like my
coach lapsakis uh he was telling me that
countless all-nighters were pulled
trying to pull out a draw out of some
end game then you have to resume the
game and then play another game so you
know we think the good old days we're
relaxed with you know the GMS with
cigars dangling out of their mouths and
you know just kind of waving their arms
around no they're with the schedule in
those tournaments was absolutely
grueling speaking of grilling I mean
ding still has not arrived at his board
is he deciding between Knight T3 and
Knight A4
is he contemplating the meaning of life
is he choosing his open is he choosing
his restaurant for dinner there we go
yeah I think the 1994 is the option I
selects here
um if I have to bet on something
yeah
and usually him coming back to the board
means he's ready to make a move because
he's done his thinking
in the rest area
well I can do a little bit more thinking
there a lot plenty of time on the clock
uh oh yeah it's not sure there's a
difference I think Knight D3 feels more
normal uh
but it's the same thing just a more
normal route yeah D3 is kind of a
Central Square nice one
speaking of I chose the restaurant
example for a reason one of my favorite
favorite is the wrong word because I I
don't mean to imply that it's you know
funny Vichy uh during the Vichy Carlson
match
um one of you probably know exactly what
I'm about to say uh vishi got a slightly
annoying question uh that resembled like
were you actually trying to calculate
you know a certain variation at a
certain time and this is just very
classy it's very Vichy because it's not
you know it wasn't angry it's just the
most Vichy thing ever he says no I was
thinking what to eat tonight
very good passive aggressive press
conference there yes
because I think he lost as well the
journalist was like so issue you spend
here one hour uh what were you thinking
about
what does one think about in a position
where black has two queens and that was
that nimzo Indian game where Carlson
promoted on like move 21 or something
yeah and then I was just thinking about
that for dinner no it was uh
yeah some press conferences are quite
legendary I I don't know if you're gonna
have we're probably gonna have one today
as well after the after this game and
we'll see the we'll see what is in store
for us but a lot of the stuff is really
hilarious we've got all sorts of
different journalists from the chess
worlds from the outside the players are
in all kinds of different moods
sometimes and oh yes all the all kind of
stuff happens there
so it's a competition of of its own the
press conferences
how hard is it and you've you know I've
had by share of press conferences in the
US Championship but that's it you've had
press conferences all throughout your
career how hard is it to especially
after a very painful game to get
yourself together and you know explain
your thoughts is that just
is that just annoying beyond words or do
you get used to that
no but it's actually an interesting
question because uh
I think for many people it's like
therapeutical to uh to discuss the game
that they've lost because uh and I think
I I'm also the kind of player who wants
to take a good look at that game and to
put it behind me and in order to put it
behind me I need to really look at
exactly what happened and where I lost
why I lost what I lost and uh talking
about it is I don't think the press
conference is the part that hurts you
the party hurts you that you lost and I
think a press conference in my case
could only be
of help because you you want to withdraw
uh and hide yourself under a
under a rock or whatever and not show up
for breakfast you don't want to look at
anybody you want to be kind of
self-destructive after you lose but uh
going out to to see people and uh
confronting
confronting you know your loss and
talking about it with other people
listening I think that um I think for me
has would have a positive effect
um on my well-being sort of
so I I don't mind the press conference
after I lose I just mind losing so it's
a different thing that's the that's the
root problem I agree exactly you
shouldn't you shouldn't you know
you shouldn't blame the press conference
for for the bad mood it was the lost I
mean that was misappropriation of blame
I think is there's a term for it
um and of course uh Kasparov and karpov
as sikar reminds us uh played their
share of uh well they played hundreds of
games across their careers against each
other most famously the 1984-85 match we
mentioned it earlier it was postponed uh
but that isn't even the most famous
thing about the match the most famous
thing is that uh Gary Kasparov was down
this was a first to six wins and that
match is a big reason why this system
was eliminated because after having five
wins to zero Gary Kasparov threw a
series of draws game three wins and
ultimately the match lasted five months
and was canceled because uh there was a
you could read about it for hours and
let's watch the game because I think
we're gonna get a draw for literally any
second
unless ding plays Knight takes B2 here
and there will be no drop no but then
the game was also not last very long I
think that's an idea no either way yeah
no no no of course yeah he spent enough
time now to notice that threat of 98
check and I think Bishop D7 is uh
is coming and yeah judging especially
from the body language uh it's clear
guys yeah Ian has no hope uh for
anything here he doesn't have any
intention
I hear uh
either
yeah and the body language is as
advanced a desired offer a drop for a
long time but the driver isn't actually
it's not actually come from either
player
yeah but I think again it's it's a
psychological uh so first of all even if
you want to draw if you offer it and
your opponent will now let's say refuse
you still didn't get the draw and uh
then you've showed to your opponent that
okay you're I don't know you thought you
because the only reason you offer a draw
is you think that there is a chance you
can lose right or okay or it's a dead
dead because or you're hungry yeah okay
but uh
I think
this offering a draw
is just something you just don't want to
do very often and the same with um for
both players so they just they're just
not offering it and what should happen
is either a move repetition or a trade
of knights
I mean we could see a blue repetition
somehow a country construct one just yet
but the players are really good at this
uh they might oh yeah
I always like to share the story I mean
I played a tournament where droppers
were forbidden uh in Corsica there's a
famous open tournament and you know you
just kind of exchange eye contact I was
playing game of book Crow and exchange
eye contact and we started playing
Bishop B7 to A8 and he plays Bishop B2
to C3 and we kind of smile and that
means okay let's
let's finish this thing up
yeah except for these two players they
don't want to smile to each other very
much as they no no the upcoming month
the other one is trying to destroy their
uh their entire live stream so you're
not going to be like let's you know very
nice very funny yeah I missed the
winning chances that yeah of me I had in
the world championship match
sure sure exactly so it's a little less
friendly there but uh I think both
players are
both players are right here I mean I
honestly I was just thinking about one
thing here
the white king could kind of leak in
through these squares potentially and
that could potentially be
an issue
but there are multiple ways of
preventing it I mean F5 is a bit ugly
but it's possible can I show you a funny
line getting F3 Bishop C8 King E4
Bishop B7 King F5 G6
yeah no I mean this is what's possible
um I was thinking of a more productive
infiltration than that but see this is
what I occupy my mind with you know yeah
you you have this you are all these
bullet scenarios are in your mind and
the probably the whole game of yours
would end with the black pieces
possibly against me uh
but yeah this uh
yeah how do you stop it I think I mean
F5 is possible uh and if King E3 you got
this Knight do one this is a repetition
I saw 91 and then
right back and I would but what if I try
Knight D4 to F3 I play King E2 and the
Knight F3
yeah I mean I'm not I don't like the
look of F5 it's very ugly move because
I'm controlling these squares and these
squares as well and after the five hour
week in the dark Square I don't like a
five
is there another way to stop it in a
more uh more elegant one perhaps
well and Nepal has the same question
we'll find out I think we'll find out
after it's just been played
ding
seems like he's a
checking his score sheets like when can
I offer a draw again
yeah because that is even even after you
do all that I put a knight here it's not
like it's the end of the world right I
mean I have G3 I have Knight F2 and I'll
have counter plays I'm not saying that
this is decided this is like you know if
we talk about
uh all kinds of random things I mean
there's still one thing to talk about in
this position left and that is this
potential King infiltration
um I've you said kinky too yeah
but still even there like once white
plays Knight F3 black can meet that with
Knight D3 I think yeah absolutely I mean
I can
start with Knight D3 after King U2
I'm going to give you three you want and
then I have night one probably no I mean
I think the margin is enormous here uh
to be honest
you need about eight moves in a row
that's it you can't even construct it's
hard to even construct a winning
position like maybe with the King on B6
here would this be winning probably with
the King on B6 it's winning probably not
so still not I mean probably not no I
mean you don't think so I don't think
it's winning uh okay maybe but I would I
would have control 93 then Knight F2 the
94. I'll go G5 somewhere okay I mean
anyway that's a hypothetical that is
completely irrelevant how do you get the
king to B6 in one go no it's it it's
like that famous story this is
apocryphal
um I don't think it's a real story but
supposedly it's like tarash and chagoran
were playing and uh one of them was
known for refusing drafers in dead drawn
positions so they got a completely
locked position and one of them like
removes his own Bishop from the board
and the point is that it's still a draw
and you know that proves the point and
then they left happily ever after yeah
yeah it was a nice story I heard about
it as well some kind of a locked
position with a bishop and the guy
offers a draw the Terrace refused or the
way around uh draw and then so the guy
refused and then he removes the bishop
and says out for it again right
but it's Yeah it's you're not there yet
it's not that close we have we have
these two um
the you know some space here through
which the king can pass but at the same
time yeah I wonder if F5 is the best or
not
I don't want to make this move but
the if I look at the position
I think logically that seems to be the
easiest way
but it feels a bit wrong but maybe it's
the easiest way I don't know
yeah what can happen
what can happen what's a king king
I thought maybe King E3 to try it again
at Tempo but yeah oh yeah yeah sorry
you're correct
that was the idea and that's so now
ultimate yeah now uh you will get it now
and Knight F3
yeah do we connect D3
King E3
ships
starts to get a bit nice
oh yeah
94.73 you take
before
yeah
shoot back exactly
I mean this has to be the
um this is quite clean now I guess
yeah I'm thinking about a crazy winning
attempt no it's not even worse
oh no for for black women after Knight
D4 I was thinking Bishop takes G2 that'd
be fine takes b5g G5 but
it's actually not the easiest thing to
prevent by the way nice
yeah I mean guys suddenly we you know we
created so much life in this lifeless
position
creativity is the mother of invent or
invention I think is that how it goes
you know we we have to manufacture
interesting ideas so we really scraped
the bottom of the barrel for
whatever we can find I'm getting paid
for this stuff so we have to yeah
absolutely so do the players but they
don't have to you know that's the
difference
the players can just uh
just do the uncreative stuff
ding has taken half of his extra time
yeah because you've got another 15
minutes on move 60. the engine because I
okay I had enough I turn on the engine
the engine actually agrees that uh F5 is
actually the zeros and the other stuff
is the zero zero five slash small list
of advantages for white so this is the
easiest way to go
indeed
even though it's a little bit ugly
but even like the point is that yeah
even even King E4 like this this is also
nothing of course you do and if you go
G3 I will uh
I will Target that pawn as well in some
way instead of two Knight H1 yeah I was
thinking about that exactly I was just
thinking about Knight H1 here
yeah gmta reminds
wow yeah it's a matter of it's a matter
of a taste here at this point I think
yeah I mean ding
he doesn't want to take another 30
minutes on this move I mean you know
vanyan will legitimately start playing
for a win
yeah it's an interesting question you
know when you have the position that uh
it is kind of drawn pretty obviously
your opponent also looks like he wants
to draw
and then you have some doubts now the
question is
um how do you deal with it do you play
quickly or do you type try to take your
time because both are a little dangerous
if you play too fast you run the risk of
making an inaccuracy making your task a
legitimate that difficult at the same
time if you think too long you might
still not find a clean way but you've
shown your opponent that you are worried
and I've seen a lot of games go wrong
because of that a component has no hope
because you think so long the opponent
is like why is he not making Android why
and then sometimes he's like is he
really worried and then he starts
thinking like ah okay maybe I have
something actually this works both ways
you cannot think too long here so I
think ding should take his couple of
minutes like five minutes maybe and okay
make that move beat F5 or G6 just make
it make something
yeah and I mean he understands let's not
forget this is the world championship he
knows what he's been through
so I think ding he knows this is the
last the last hurdle and if he crosses
it successfully you know he'll have a
very pleasant evening
you know reminiscing about the bullet
that he dodged today yeah talking about
Richard about uh yeah
about what he's going to play next game
like C4 and G4 Richard report has rained
it in a little bit when it comes to his
repertoire a couple of years ago it was
like he would play C4 E3 and G4 I mean
you probably remember that phase
yeah there are three phases uh so a very
young Richard report I don't know if you
know but at some point I Was preparing
for him for the second phase of his but
I looked up his first place so very
young we should report only one E4 only
main lines extremely well well and
narrow prepared like your classical kind
of well prepared kind of guy who's just
playing like one thing all the time and
like well prepared in that and then at
some point there was a shift from one
day to the other the whole E4 thing
stopped and it started to be only the
wicked stuff like the D4 Knight C3 this
reverse triggering all sorts of C4
Knight C3 G4 only the weakest stuff was
there and now there is the third phase
where he yeah
does both sometimes it goes for the
mainland sometimes he does the the
wicked stuff and I think that is
actually suiting him very well just to
be this balanced player who sometimes
plays a solid patch of sometimes uh does
a crazy
you know Spanish where he sacrifices a
piece on G4 like he did against uh mvl
and the Grand Prix ding meanwhile made
the choice Knight D3 it's a more classy
choice this movie five is ugly it's
clean but it's ugly 93 is the the more
classy way to to do it
so what did we come up with against
Knight T3 King E4 again
I just don't make waiting move but the
computers are just it's very nice F5 as
well oh of course Knight F5 Knight F2
or wait is that oh yeah yeah that's good
enough oh yeah that's good enough I mean
because King F3 you can play Bishop F5
yeah this is uh so dead yeah
um oppon is irrelevant I can bring my
Bishop here and nice and sit there or
forever
is nice and if you go here I'll take
here
so in fact this is a better order
because after King 45 you're sort of
with black you gain some time on this
operation again the temperature
nice
good move
that's why it's uh there's the upside of
taking time you can nicely take your
time and come up with something super
accurate
yeah and clearly he's in F5 because that
literally is the only move
and again Jan is doing this lean back
thing
you know where he seems to be about out
for the drop but you're right they
they're they're waging the psychological
world let's let's see we do want to take
a break but let's uh wait for Jan's move
uh because okay every every move I think
a dropper is increasingly yeah I don't
know if you want to take away if you
want to take a break like maybe we you
know we just uh work hard and then we
take a break for the entire day after
it's over yeah it's uh it's a question
here
yeah I mean I'm uh I'm fine either way
yeah but ding is back in the room
thing is back in his restroom
okay again nepo
again the the look to the side yeah okay
let's end the game here well you know
one time I read this is annotations uh
to his win against yangi one time he
actually mentioned in the sanitations he
said that he on purpose in the opening
tried to
appear as if he doesn't want anything to
confuse you and get into thinking that
he doesn't want anything and actually
then to Spring a surprise on him
sometimes Jan's bad language can be
deceiving but in this case if you look
at the position as well
I think he he really doesn't want
anything I mean it's not like he's
hiding his uh his uh you know devilish
intentions I think there's just there's
just nothing in there and uh yeah he
just doesn't have much after G3 I don't
know I mean you're gonna go again go to
Five you can probably not go F5
I guess a five is the easiest
oh yeah five just boxes in although
again we there's this whole King E3
Monkey Business the engine also so just
I'm just looking at alternatives
oh this yeah okay it's actually very
clean just
this is 94. yeah it's a dead draw yeah
it doesn't like a five but probably a
five is there is it also okay five oh
he's actually losing that's funny
this is actually very interesting it's
very similar to this um
women candidates Tournament game between
relating yes but that was an amazing end
game yeah that was a draw but this is
not a rush this is I mean she won as
well but this is actually a two song
because in that position quite
interesting I'll show you the difference
in that position this was a stalemate
but if we could bring up an announce
board we
um just so we could show that end game
yeah
she takes his time so we'll take this
opportunity to Joe could we maybe replay
uh and you should do that line one more
time yeah yeah so we're talking about
this line we don't have to do this but
okay this is a draw and now we can sort
of suicide with F5
try to stabilize the pawn structure and
then we have this position which is very
similar to that game
except there are some details like this
Pawn is there this Pawn is there and
it's it's all kind of a little different
but this this theme there was that you
could go Bishop E6 this was like a
stalemate
but here I've got this almost available
to me
C3 and B4 opens up some squares for the
bishop but I guess white spawns are two
just too far Advanced although it's
never actually as easy as it looks to
win those types of positions you mean
this C3 takes before
you actually can win either probably you
should go to the king side like the only
reason you're winning maybe is because
of the G6 fun I think
oh yeah
the yeah because the apron is also the
wrong uh color that would yeah you know
your
you probably are I am pretty sure you
are
ultimately I guess the idea is you go
around yeah here yeah you're right you
just suggest you just go around and need
to collect yeah
but it is completely relevant because
here I just made this move at five
cutting of the diagonal for the bishop
instead I just go here
and just wait I guess
and then go back and
that's it
it's nice one Knight B3 is another way
to do it and uh is that what he did
that's what he did yeah wow yeah I think
machine like Precision he doesn't like
this F5 move he finds it a bit ugly so
he wants to do without it
understandable goes again he just he is
just as a magnetic attraction to that
that chair
and Jan or that little
half smile there's a lot going on behind
the curtains but I've made an attempt as
a commentator to not overestimate my
ability to read body language which is
pitiful you know I used to do way too
much of that and claim for certain you
know what this means and what that means
you don't know what any of it means they
could just be you know they might not
even know why they're making the facial
expressions yes they are yes and uh
supplier you also don't want to read too
much into it you do want to read some of
that but very often a player Smiles
because he had some very weird thought
of what happened to him this this
morning it has nothing to do with the
game at all or um and you suddenly start
doubting your move because the guy
remembers his breakfast
I mean it's ridiculous
yeah it's just impossible just to uh
predict what goes on behind the scenes
Knight B3 King E3 about to happen King
three is also an attempt to show that he
doesn't even want anything like I'm not
even entering with the King to D5 it's
just
I'm just done under Fire I'm just done
with this game and just
I come in peace yeah I come in peace
exactly
this is the message now watch him
decline the trade with like Knight E2
and then and then come back you have to
be so much yeah
but I mean you should also not okay I'm
not going anywhere not like there's no
point no I think he will make a bishop
move here let me shoot D6 and uh takes
takes
and that's it
here you can afford to play F5 and but
you'll stand
yeah the game is about to end Yan
waiting for ding to carry out Knight B3
yeah promising start I have to say I
really like as a professional uh for me
like
the most interesting part is the opening
to be honest because unlike other
tournaments the players have spent so
much effort so much time and they've had
so much help of people and software and
hardware and everything and they really
you know they they've done their best
their motivation is the highest to come
up with ideas and I'd really like to
watch the opening phases and see what
ideas they brought and today the idea
Jan brought to the table was really very
interesting I'll just offered it wrong
yeah yep and Shake Yana for the draw
thing took a second
handshake has occurred the first game of
the 2023 feet a world championship as
concluded in peace but it was not a
peaceful game it was anything but a
peaceful game
and Jan's facial expressions we don't
want to read too much into them but we
know one thing for certain this is going
to be a bitter pill to swallow in the
early going of this match because if
you're young you want to get into you
want to avoid the kind of here we go
again mode where you start replaying
what happened in the madness match now
what happened in this game and for ding
just a
big big bullet dodged as you put it
yeah yeah for sure you know Sian should
probably just think to himself that was
not a big deal not a big chance and some
players they don't even look at the
computer afterwards they ask the second
and the second stops and downplay the
advantage that he had second should just
tell him yeah you're a bit better but it
was not no big deal next time like you
should probably improve there here but
this it's no big deal it was fine anyway
and then you're like yeah okay it's both
knowing deep inside that it was a missed
chance pretending it's not just not to
carry that psychological that negative
emotion uh for the next game
that's really interesting inside I guess
that is oh yeah I've seen my own seconds
right I mean I've seen that them do that
to me and I know people say that I've
really missed and they're like yeah it's
fine okay it's really not fine okay
whatever let's
yeah no for sure but then there will be
a extensive analysis and some you know
chess-based article where someone plugs
that position to the engine for 15
minutes and sometimes it ends up giving
plus six you know like but it might turn
out that it was completely winning or it
might turn out that it was actually a
draw
yeah I mean it's today's case I can't
imagine that white was really winning
but nowadays you never know the engines
are so Advanced they see it all to the
end and sometimes they say winning in a
position that just looks better but just
they just couple it to the win they say
it's over it was all over
well ladies and gentlemen that was game
one the standings are pretty
straightforward right now both players
with half a point of course a draw
counts for half a point a win
ounce for a point for the winner zero
points for the loser the first to seven
and a half also known as best of 14 wins
the 2023 World Championship there it is
aim one is a draw Jana Pony will have
the black pieces tomorrow
and a completely new set of challenges
and you know there's still that feeling
of novelty in the first two games
because now it's ding's turn to show you
know to fire the opening bullet and show
what he's brought to the table yeah I'm
very much excited looking forward to
seeing you because uh you know he showed
he showed that he came well prepared he
didn't come empty-handed he surprised
the ding surprised the commentators the
kudos to him now let's see if Dean can
do that I suspect he will do it in a
different openings in closed openings I
guess one D4 1931 C4 but we'll see what
dink has brought to the table I'm
looking for it
I am as well folks before we wrap up a
quick look at the schedule at a glance
uh there are no more than two uh days of
Chess without arrest day tomorrow is in
fact game two that is tomorrow at the
same time 2 A.M Pacific bright and early
5 a.m Eastern uh New York time and 11
Central European Standard Time every
game starts at exactly the same time so
mark your calendar but don't forget
there is a rest day on Tuesday again
there's two there's no more than two
games uh without arresting then
Wednesday and Thursday same time and
Friday is another rest day so mark your
calendars ladies and gentlemen because
this match is only going to get more
hype but folks it's been a long day uh
Anish I'll hand it over to you one more
time before I wrap up for your final
thoughts what what words what
descriptors come to mind are you
satisfied with the level of play that
we've seen here in game one
yeah definitely I think it's a very
normal situation especially in the first
game you you know there's extra
excitement extra pressure I'm like super
familiar as a player with the feeling of
missing Us opening Advantage at some
point and letting things slip out of out
of hand I think this happens a lot I
think nothing special nothing dramatic
there I I do think that the positives
outweigh the negatives today and I've
seen some great prep by nepos really
creative stuff in the opening something
new something fresh got ding thinking
got something going I think that's uh
promises you know promises something
something good for the for the match and
uh yeah definitely uh something
something I enjoyed and uh
we'll see if you know if there was that
if that was it if that was Yan's best uh
prep or or there's more to come but
definitely a good sign for for Jan and
his fans and for ding as well who
survived you know you must be very happy
because this is his first game in the
world championship match Jan has played
the previous one this is ding's first
one and he didn't uh fall flat on his
face you know as they say so he he
managed to keep his composure and
overcome his survive and tomorrow is his
chance to make Mark with the white
pieces
it is going to be his first wide game in
uh his first world championship match
and we will be on the edge of our seats
we'll be bringing you that game but
folks we'd like to thank everybody first
of all in the chat the tens of thousands
of you watching the 2023 feed a world
championship which has just begun we
have so much action ahead of us we'd
also like to thank uh our producer Hala
and our entire amazing team at chess.com
it takes a village uh to produce this uh
there were some opening Jitters but I
think everybody ended well in Anish a
great honor to commentate with you I'm
looking forward to tomorrow and for now
this was Grandmaster nishikiri
Grandmaster Daniel naritzki bringing you
coverage of the 2023 fide World
Championship we'll see you tomorrow
bright and early round two goodbye
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're five minutes away from the start
of the 2023 World Championship your both
players are very very very very very
very nervous right now right now what
move is Yan going to play a niche
quickly what's your call the game has
started it is in fact E4 right now big
decision for gun does he roll up his
sleeves is this the time to play 92 or
does he keep playing the waiting game I
mean a four very tempting Queen A4 Queen
V8 by the way it's a young infiltration
with the queen that's Young's favorite
topic he smells blood what's this I know
I know my man I know my man F4 has been
played ding is up from his chair he's
definitely surprised by this move
something something's gone wrong here
somehow he missed something and now he's
just slightly lost the threat maybe 57
plate I like it he just reached time
control and he just solves his last
problem and everything worked out for
ding he knows that this is in the bag
now oh yes handshake has occurred the
first game of the 2023 female World
Championship as concluded in peace
laughs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign